I
than
will
e
e I
know
ni
I wanted to you
speaker
I
Cor
actually
they
know
I
it's
hard
ience
the end of
day
should
and it's not over
first
very
muchy
B
GR
I saw
like
cod analy data
set
you know I guess
Def
pretty
interesting
tit I think oh
posters oh right
on
[Music]
just
the
build a couple weeks ago part
of
one
higher
scale
bste was
like so like do a lot
of
yeah
high school students and also like
particularly like women in minorities
because
right and that's what
is
so so I will be the person along with
one other person that's walking around
doing Q&A that's why I need to know
specifically about the handheld MS
okay
so this is their
um I don't think they need this because
you know they don't need it because it's
LCDs but this is their goes back M
that's what they need to go okay with
the
m for the Q&A Mark has them over there
okay so he'll just hand them out to you
and um for housekeeping housekeeping if
you could tell everybody if you have a
question because we're streaming this
and
please raise your hand and wait for the
mic okay
okay okay I'll let
you take the helm
Scotty cuz you know where it
is you the first presenter
I am the first presenter how did you how
did you uh pick that
straw uh
alphabe
doesn't look like you have a keynote
this well this is theirs I thought they
had everything on here um okay then you
know what bring your bring yours up
here
wow what's this going to be like when it
grows
older okay we don't care about that we
don't care about that
just open the
display there you go okay now you can
close it
okay and out of it uh yeah I would
actually not like mirroring I would like
it as a secondary oh
okay
I'm going to be surfing the web while
presenting so some people have stuff on
the web that they want to show what but
this will not
work um no I don't need
it
thank
you I'm first
after um the introduction so I'm the
first handle don't want
toed
are you
do
you
may they
SC yeah I'm
surprised I'll think private actually a
lot
of
hello everybody we're about to begin uh
my name is Michelle Hudson I'm one of
the organizers of the day of data so if
you have any questions you can find me
and ask me we have some Logistics to go
over before I introduce our speakers um
this is being live streamed so if you
are uncomfortable with that please do
not ask questions that you don't want
the whole world to hear um in addition
the cameras are here so if you could
walk behind them if you need to exit the
room that would be great coffee and
snacks are outside restrooms can be
found if you just keep turning left so
go out the door turn left a bunch there
will be
bathrooms this event is sponsored by the
Yale University Library Yale at the Yale
Institute for Network science the Yale
Institution for social and policy
studies and the office of the Provost
um so I think that's everything and we
can just start so I'm going to introduce
Susan Gibbons from the Yale University
Library she is our director and she will
open the day for
us good morning everyone um if you are
following us on Twitter and and wish to
um make comments the hashtag is yd o
2014 that's y dood 2014 and I hope you
will um comment throughout the day so
again my name is Susan Gibbons and I am
the university librarian and it's my
great pleasure to welcome you those of
you who are here physically in the room
and I know we have many of you who are
joining us online and we appreciate um
that you were able to join us today this
is the second Yale day of data um and
this emerged as a result of a workshop
that three members of the Yale Community
participated in Ed Carris from
University it Michelle Hudson who you
just saw and Jill parek from the library
they attended a National escience
Institute
and as a part of that institute's
Workshop they were asked to go around
campus and interview faculty and
interview administrators about questions
around data and one of their findings
was that there was a disconnect let's
say between the two that on the one hand
Administration thought that that um
faculty and scientists were quite
satisfied with how they are handling
their data and on the uh side of the
scientists and the faculty there was a
sense of there could be more services
there could be more assistance more help
in that area and we wish that Yale would
provide it so we decided to put together
this conference with the help of all of
our partners because we wanted to start
a dialogue on campus we wanted to bring
attention to the importance of data
we've always been using data but the
role of it now has increased the scope
the scale the complexity has gotten much
um deeper and we hope now that we're can
see that there's truly a community of
users on campus and perhaps collectively
together we can solve some of the
problems that we're currently facing
whether it's a tsunami of data a tital
wave or whatever however terminology
we'd like to use so I'm very glad to say
that um our day of data will be uh begun
with our keynote speaker um Ben poock
who is our University Provost he's also
the William brard um professor of
economics and I wish to thank him
personally for joining us again in the
second year and kicking off our day of
data
then so thanks everyone for being here
and thank you uh Susan especially for
your leadership here and uh uh uh Len
and others for for helping organizing
this and working so hard on this uh I'm
very pleased that the Provost office is
uh co-sponsoring this event this is as
Susan said the second annual day of data
and the response to this has been
tremendous um uh 120 people registered
to attend the event and the demand was
so great there's another 160 people on
the weight list which I think probably
indicates just how much interest there
is in data around campus and as Susan
said the events are being live streamed
uh I have to say I've never been on
Twitter before I don't know what that
means I I'm a little bit intimidated by
that uh what a fudy duddy I am as we did
last year there's going to be a bunch of
Yale faculty uh presenting uh talks
about their of data intent I research
and talking about how they navigate the
problems the challenges associated with
curating and stewarding data uh y's had
some exciting developments in this area
in the past year uh one of which uh I
mentioned actually last year which is
the new census research data center and
the leading force behind that Pete shot
will be presenting later on in the day
uh I'm pretty excited to see that
getting up and running because it's been
a long history going back to my time as
chair of Economics trying to get that to
to happen and it is now
happening um we're also going to be
talking about the Yale open data Access
Project at the school of
medicine uh I wanted just to to talk a
little bit about how important data has
becoming in research data is changing
the way in which not only we do research
but the way in which we approach
research in general and this is fairly
well understood in the sciences and the
social sciences I think at this point I
mean big data has become a bit of a
cliche in fact sometimes I don't quite
know what the borders between big data
and small data but it we all understand
that's important we understand
University wide at Yale that things like
computational biology and biostats are
incredibly important in the future of
what we do in the Life Sciences uh but
it goes beyond that so uh I give an
example from the law school which is a
possibly apocryphal story uh there was a
a lecture here maybe 18 months ago uh uh
highly empirical highly d intensive
lecture in the law school and as people
were going out one of the slightly more
um I'm I'm being live stream so I
probably shouldn't say it but let me say
it anyway slightly more fudy duddy uh uh
law school professors uh complained to
the person uh he was walking out with it
was a he I'm not giving away too much
there um uh that this talk had asked no
new questions this this very empirical
talk had asked no new questions uh and
this was meant to be a criticism and the
reply he got got was uh yeah it didn't
answer any new questions but it answered
a bunch of old questions and that surely
is the point that there are things we
can do with data we can ask new
questions with data but we can also for
the first time uh answer questions that
have been speculated about for decades
uh we're learning in in the uh
Humanities and the social sciences that
things that we used to answer with
anecdotes look very different when we
apply data and in fact the things we
thought were the answers turn out to be
wrong so these questions about how to
handle big data that are well known in
The Sciences little known in the social
sciences are going to affect all of us
and we're seeing this right across
campus uh uh extending I mentioned to
the law school but to the digital
Humanities projects as well that Susan
has been a big leader in uh they do
raise new problems and we'll have time
to talk about some of those problems
today the first day of data was primary
primarily about internal collaborations
at Yale uh the way that people here at
Yale are addressing cross-disciplinary
challenges of working with data and this
year we're expanding this view to look
at collaborations that extend beyond
Yale collaborations within and with
industry government and other academic
institutions we have a number of people
visiting today from other institutions
in Connecticut and Beyond and a warm
welcome to all of you we also have two
visiting speakers joining us Philip
Bourne is the associate director for
data science at the National Institute
of Health and he will talk about
initiatives uh at the institutional
state and federal levels and Kathy
O'Neal is director of the lead program
at the Columbia School of Journalism and
she recently wrote the very popular book
doing data science she will address the
cultural aspects of data which has
different meanings for different
people today's program reflects the year
that 2014 has been the year of Big Data
not only in universities but in the
public sector as well the rising
awareness of the issues surrounding data
policy have been very much in evidence
here on campus and at the institutional
level we're responding to this a number
of ways in particular with various
advisory committees meeting right now to
look at some of the uh key questions to
address uh at a recent Conference of
provos I was at a couple of weeks ago
I'm finding that similar committees are
forming right across the country uh
there are new regulatory issues to worry
about there are issues about the uh uh
new compliance we have to do with data
uh coming from uh Public Funding
agencies for
research so I'm very pleased that this
is not a one-off event but the start of
a series of programs involving Yale
faculty postdocs and students that will
hope will continue throughout the year
and we hope this day of data is going to
be an annual event uh I'm very grateful
to you being here today and I encourage
all of you to be involved in the year
ahead I I don't want to hog the floor
here so I think what I'm going to do
here is stop and allow uh people to ask
questions either of me or of Len or of
Susan but I might first just ask Len and
Susan if they have any comments they
want to
add
all right so I think I want to focus my
comments on what some people might be
wondering is why exactly is the library
involved in data and why is the library
pushing this question um because in many
ways um the traditional view of
libraries is the physical book and yet
here we are uh co-sponsoring uh an event
on uh data and the answer to that
question is a shift that we're seeing
very much within the library World which
is libraries moving beyond just the care
of the physical Collections and moving
Upstream in many ways um in the research
process so traditionally libraries were
involved in collecting the end result of
research which was often in the form of
a book or a journal article and bringing
that to a campus so that others could
build upon that knowledge what we're
seeing now though is that the same
skills that Librarians have been
applying in to that process can now be
applied to the research much sooner an
example being as you go out for your
grants you're often being asked and you
will increasingly be asked to create a
data management plan to submit with that
grant that plan will ask you how are you
going to store your data how are you
going to arrange it how are you going to
curate it preserve it how are you going
to make sure others who need access to
it can identify it find it and use it
that is what libraries do we have been
curating and collecting and preserving
and helping people disc discover and
gain access to information all along now
we can start to help doing it in a very
different realm which is with um data
but in order for this to happen I think
the Librarians need to be involved
earlier in the process almost as soon as
the grant writing happens and we now
have on our staff two data Librarians
who are available to work with you to
create that data management plan so that
when you're ready to submit you have
some um guidance on how to do that and
we don't work within a vacuum we are
working with other data Librarians
across the country who are familiar with
the requirements and the growing
requirements of those Federal funding
agencies so as you can see it's the same
skills we've had all along but we're
trying to apply them now in a very
different way to help all of you in your
research um and I hope you will through
this conference and through
conversations with us start to see the
role that the library can play with you
and um we welcome being one of your
collaborators we welcome being someone
who can join you in this process and
it'll be our job to sort of bring to
that conversation an understanding of
the resources that are available to you
from Yale whether from University its
from high performance Computing from the
other institutes and centers and perhaps
we can be that networking function
perhaps we can be that node on campus
that is aware of what others are doing
and to say that what you're trying to
accomplish has similarities has patterns
that we see in other research that's
going on and we can perhaps be the ones
to help you come together and think
about collaboration in ways that you
might not be aware of because it's so
difficult to move across the silos of
the University so libraries support the
entire University and we move move
across all disciplines so to leverage
that cross-disciplinary nature of the
libraries for the support of your own
research to help toine those colleagues
those who can help you and we can
hopefully also build a community of
practice the um intellectual Powerhouse
of Yale is
incredible and as you struggle with your
questions your methodologies or even how
to store my data and how to do it in
different
ways again perhaps a lot Library can be
that source that will help you find
others who can think about the problem
with you that we can be the
collaborators and the glue that brings
it all together so I wanted to take that
opportunity to make that pitch because
it is a very different way of thinking
about libraries but it's one that we are
now well positioned to serve that role
we're ready to hang out our shingle and
say come to us with your data questions
and I hope you'll take that as an
invitation um to contact us and now I'll
turn it over to Len
good morning everyone how's everyone
doing today everybody seems kind of
quiet that's okay um so uh first of all
thank you to all the organizers who put
this dat together I it really is a
fantastic event on campus and it
probably is uh the thing that's going to
be the Catalyst to really move us
forward because at the end of the day
when you think about what it's going to
really take to move things forward um
it's people so I'm sure you know the CIO
is here in front of the room and
probably the thing you're kind of
wondering is what great technology am I
going to talk about um and I would love
to do that um but I don't think this is
necessarily the Forum to get into all
the details suffice it to say there's a
fair amount of things going on with an
it that are very exciting particularly
in the area of high performance
computing we've been expanding our
capability in that space uh I'm very
pleased to announce that in partnership
with uh faculty on campus we've received
our second NSF uh grant for cyber
infrastructure um our first grant was
approximately $500,000 to implement a
science Network very high-speed Network
100 gigabit Network that connects our
major Labs on campus to our high
performance Computing clusters that's
very exciting and our recent Grant is
approximately
$800,000 again awarded through the NSF
and that's going to allow us to um put
some new technology in that's going to
increase the efficiency of the network
it's a a technology called software
defined networking and we're working
very closely with computer science
department on the implementation of that
technology so we're going to continue to
build out uh infrastructure uh we're
growing in other spaces as well we're
growing in the space of security and
privacy so as we think about some of the
high performance Computing continuing to
work in areas like genomics and
bioinformatics we actually looking at
ways that we can put in highperformance
Computing capability that's hpoc
compliant uh so we can we can deal with
uh the privacy issues and the regulatory
issues we have around data so you'll
continue to hear more and more and more
about those
things um so um I was asked actually to
respond to some of the comments Ben uh
uh was talking about so first of all
don't let the man fool you he's not a FY
Dy he's a very highly sophisticated
technology user I know it firsthand um
uh the uh and he's he's he's very much
like many other faculty and researchers
on campus that have great demands of
Technology uh one of the things that uh
Ben did say is uh this notion of
answering old questions and answering
new questions and and I wanted to
respond to that by saying sometimes we
don't even know what the new question is
and and and the the capability we now
have with big data uh conceptually we're
starting to look into areas where we're
looking at a predictive uh modeling of
big data sets we're looking at
prescriptive analytics and data that can
start to find new discoveries and answer
the questions before you know what the
question actually is so uh we continue
to do that we're looking at ways to
implement technology like data
visualization clearly you know big data
is a is a very popular term um and I
often ask people what they think big
data actually is um but uh it's to me
it's just simply it's something that uh
just takes too long to process if it's
if it's if you can't move it store it uh
uh process it manage it uh preserve it
it's probably too big and that's the
problem sometimes we have data that's
too big and it is an arms race we
continue to try and grow our
infrastructure to deal with it um but I
think uh the real challenge is going to
be how we think about using the data
what capabilities do we have and What
new technologies can we
Implement so uh it continues to grow and
evolve uh in the last several years
we've been uh building a stronger unit
within the organization we're currently
searching for a senior director of
research technology and the exciting uh
thing about that position is that we're
partnering with the Provost office and
the dean the deputy Dean of medicine and
what we're what we're doing there is uh
Imagining the creation of a center for
research Computing on campus something
that didn't exist before and uh why is
this so important I think it's important
because um you know again at the top of
the pyramid how we get at solving some
of these problems is really about people
and putting the right people in place to
start to work together and build
communities across campus there's lots
of benefit of bringing various
disciplines together to solve common
problems whether they're common
algorithms common programs that they can
share uh or just have a place to go and
communicate and work with their
colleagues on some of the things that
the they're trying to solve so I'm
really excited about some of the changes
going on in it really excited about the
Partnerships that we're building on
campus and uh I'm really excited that um
uh the you know there this about this
collaboration that's been formed between
its the library and other institutes on
campus to start to focus on some of the
big challenges around data so again I
thank you for having me here today and
uh any
questions so any questions for any of
the three of us Kathy
yeah oh hold on
microphone right in front
no all right hello is this working yes
okay um so I'm really excited about the
librarian as the sort of um the data
manager or like consultant of data
management and one of the things that it
strikes me as like really really needed
for a lot of people I I talk to who use
data um is this concept of
anonymization and in particular
deanonymization
so for example example I was talking to
a startup that is kind of surveillance
in New York City and they didn't
understand because I was a little bit
worried about people you know the
privacy and they told me oh this is not
going to be a problem because we're
going to open source all the data and I
was like no that's not what you do um so
it there seems to be like a real lack of
understanding of what it means to De
anonymize so-called anonymized data
sources I know this is just one of many
many different things but one thing
that's exciting to me about the idea of
the Librarians role is that they there's
at least a a person who's sort of like
in charge of of making sure that the
data users are informed about this kind
of
issue and it's it's one where I think
the one way we can move forward I hope
we move forward is sort of in data
classification and that classification
says with this data this is what can be
used I think what happens right now is
we each sort of come up with our own
classification scheme we have a sense in
our mind how the data can be used and
reused by others but we aren't able to
convey it in a way that makes sense to
everyone else so if we can start to
think about what are you know the five
levels or six levels that reflect things
such as the reused ability um the
anonymization of the material the the
Privacy the protection that has to be
there then it ends in the librarian's
mind it ends up being a metadata field
it ends up being a classification that
we express as we uh index that data um
but first we need that classification
system for us to then apply it um and
privacy for librarians is an issue that
has always been on our mind and there's
there's many federal laws and state laws
that require us to protect um you know
if you're circulating a book no one can
can know what books you're using so for
us that that's something that we've
always been on the Forefront of our mind
and I think we can apply to it but in
order for it to work we need some
standardization and standards is another
area where libraries are have have been
at the Forefront of creating national
International standards so we can
communicate without having to pick up
the phone to say with this data set you
can do the following things and so I I
think you're right to to point out that
there's classifications and other things
that we can be applying to the
data other questions or comments for me
or for
Ben yes sir hold on we have a mic coming
over to you
hope thank thank you um I'm an
epidemiologist uh who is on the edge of
retirement and as I think back over my
career I've got massive data sets
sitting on uh all all at Yale sitting on
either very large now brittle tapes or
floppy discs that nothing can read MH um
so it's it's a very practical question
about actually how do we physically
store these um these data sets now let
alone make them available to everybody
else which we want to do but it's just
it's just a very uh so far I've not
found an answer to this problem favorite
topic yeah my favorite it is my favorite
topic Ben knows this is my favorite
topic because digital preservation is an
area that that I'm I'm trying to bring
um a lot of attention to so your the
problem you describing is a problem
that's we see in many different fields
so for example when when the biny
library receives the papers of a great
writer what we receive are boxes with
papers and then floppy discs um audio
tapes every kind of a format you can
imagine so we've built up a digital
forensics lab within the library to help
us either emulate what was the operating
system the software um and the computer
to try to get that data off um or to if
we're lucky enough we actually get the
parts and we reconstruct what that
computer was so there's actually groups
on campus who are thinking about the
digital preservation problem which I
think then connects very nicely to your
question which is I now have content
regardless of what the content is a
manuscript or if it's data that needs to
make it to the next generation and how
do we think about what activities we can
do today to either catalog that it
exists it's in this format to get from
you as much knowledge as we can about
the data so that when you are have
retired and you're no longer on campus
to help us we have enough information to
try to do our best job in stewarding
that data to the Next Generation I'll be
over next week all right maybe Len has
comments on that as well yeah would
just I would just add to that that you
know that I I think as we continue to um
evolve we'll sort to see technology that
will kind of fill fill in some of the
some of the middle space there so so
clearly preservation curation are some
some some very key things but uh we need
to start to build platforms that have uh
the capability of ingesting High volumes
of this data across the institution so
we have a question of of uh ingestion or
the creation of the the data I think we
have a question of storage where we
going to store that and not have people
necessarily think about some of the some
of the typical things that you would
want to do with data like you know after
a certain amount of time maybe you want
to move it to uh less expensive type
storage devices maybe you want to
Archive it somewhere else opposed to you
know very expensive uh fast running
discs um so so we have the the ingestion
to capture we have overall management on
an ongoing basis I think we'll need to
continue to work in that space and then
last piece is dissemination and I think
you know new technologies that's going
to give us the ability to actually take
some of this curated data some of this
data that's being preserved um and make
it available to the world I think that
space in between is also an important
place where technology is going to play
a big
role hi Amy Justice I'm from the medical
school one of the things that I think
needs to be considered in this
discussion that hasn't been mentioned
yet is the whole role of the uh human
investigations committee IRB review
because typically when one puts in a
proposal uh one is asked to say when
they're going to destroy the
data and the feeling is that that's a
protection for the patients who are
involved in the study so that comes in
direct conflict with with the goals that
you were EXP expressing and not to
mention the goals of many investigators
who are very nervous about destroying
data for all the reasons that you might
think of so I would just suggest that I
think it's very important that IRB
leadership and National leadership
really in terms of how irbs are set up
and what they are expected to do must
participate in these discussions or once
again the investigators going to be put
in between the two groups who are
telling them very different
things I don't know whether to respond
or just say I I I don't think that we've
sorted out nationally where we are on
this uh we've got this real tension
between uh IB and and Hippa on the one
side privacy rights we as the first
question uh alluded to and uh the wish
to make data available and to preserve
data be able to reproduce results and so
on and I don't I'm not to be honest I'm
not that confident we're going to end up
in a good place uh I I I again this
isn't going to be I don't mean Yale end
up in a good place I mean the nation end
up in a good place I I think that these
tensions between uh privacy rights and
and uh access are real tensions uh and
in some sense the history of the IRB the
history of the human subject uh law and
and and and practice in in the US
doesn't fill me with enormous confidence
right I mean we we we we've kind of
grouped towards procedures and we kind
of know how to do them then we all copy
each other and we're looking around what
should we do with this case we go and
see what whatever Florida state did last
week or last year and so on and uh I
don't think any of us think maybe I'm
wrong I don't but I don't I'm yet to
meet somebody who thinks that we arrived
at where we've arrived at with IB Rules
by really sitting down and saying how
should this be um so we end up with
overregulation in some places and
possibly insufficient privacy uh um
regulation in others uh so I my my my my
worry here is we will see this we'll see
that historical process that s of
accumulated regulation and Law Without
necessarily thinking it through
abstractly and saying what we should do
I think we may see that occur again in
this area um uh it's it's uh it's a
frustration for many researchers the
tension between privacy and Big Data uh
that that uh and just what has to be
private if we if we if we apply the full
IRB standards to some of these large
data sets uh then we end up doing what
we all have to do this morning which is
sign a form saying we it's okay to see
our faces on TV which which my gut
feeling says at some point in time is
overregulation some at some point some
part of me says uh are we really going
to live in a society where we can't have
a discussion with with and broadcast to
Twitter without everyone having to fill
in a form that seems a Pity but I fear
that this this isn't going to end up in
a great place and by the way isn't just
going to be a us debate it's clear that
the European law particularly on the
Privacy side of things may end up being
what drives it because it seems like the
Europeans are being more restrictive on
privacy in some ways in a good way right
because some because there may be a lack
of protection in some areas in the US
but I'm not conf other people may have
different views I'm not confident this
is going to end up in a good place at
all I've often thought that if the
American taxpayer knew how much money is
spent in research for regulation that
they might have a very different view of
the roles of irbs uh I chaired an IRB I
certainly I was a patient advocate
before I went to medical school I
certainly am a believer in patients
rights to privacy but much of what goes
on in that discussion has to do with
protecting the institution rather than
protecting the individual and it's
really not about communication and
information it's really about protecting
uh
institutions I'll have something to say
about all of this later on but um I
wanted to ask a different question uh
which is something that to me that seems
quite fundamental and I haven't actually
heard mentioned yet which is the notion
of cultural change so with this
emergence of the importance of data uh
it seems that there's a there's a cost
of time and energy associated with that
um that and it also speaks to a
different kind of scholarship valuing
scholarship in a different way if if
you're expecting investigators to spend
more time uh helping with the process of
making data more usable that sort of in
a sense elevates data the value of data
within the realm of scholarship and it
needs to clearly if that's going to
happen there has to be give and take so
there has to be reward for that I'm
interested in what Yale thinks about
that cultural shift and um anything
that's happening that reflects
that I think it's just discussion for
everybody and the reason it's difficult
to say the sentence that Cote my eye or
the phrase that cot my eye is quote what
Yale thinks and you know there are
whatever some number of thousand people
at Yale and my guess is you got a
thousand different opinions uh on that I
think we're all uh struggling with this
um uh I it's inter about these
preservations of data issues that that
Susan mentioned uh and students coming
from the libraries um we've dealt with
thinking that the preservation of
information uh we've done with the idea
that that's important in the humanities
uh for for hundreds of years right so
our traditional view of the libraries as
as uh as storing uh written text and
preserving written text or in the case
of our libraries uh also uh uh storing
um uh ancient Prem manuscript texts on
on which are written in uh what are they
written on there clay so the these
issues have been around for libraries on
the history and Humanities side for a
very very long time also in art history
uh and so we're seeing them spread we're
seeing the same issues now spreading
into the into the
Sciences I my G feeling is that the is
they not that that there new issues in
that the scope is much bigger now but
they're not really new issues right the
idea that it's incredibly important to
preserve information and to make
information accessible to others and
with all the uh uh accompanying uh
problems of PR and regulation that go
with it I think that in some sense
they're just the enlargement because the
data is much bigger they the enlargement
of issues we we've been struggling with
for a long time I should let Susan this
is really Susan's area more than mine
but that
that's my gut feeling is again there
isn't what Yale thinks but I think that
I think that this isn't quite as new an
issue as we're claiming it is it's a
it's a it's the same issue WR much
larger I think the perspective I'd add
to that is um I see an interesting
tension within the humanities as the
humanities moves towards more data use
and the digital Humanities are emerging
there's a natural tension within the
humanities as to whether that is good
research and whether it is okay to be a
digital humanist and be accepted within
your discipline particularly when your
output might not be a book or an article
but may take a very different form and
may take a digital form so there's an
interesting tension on that side of it
and on the science and social science
side there is an interesting tension
around um the burden of caring for your
data and and sharing it with others um
and so in many ways I think there there
we're all sort of coming together around
a similar set of problems across all the
disciplines um in a way in the past we
had seen ourselves in very different
places that for the humanists the end
result was the book and of course you
saved all of your copious notes of how
you got to and the footnotes identified
everything very very carefully now in
the digital Humanities world how does
that look like how do you reference how
do you point back to so I think all the
disciplines are are struggling with this
new world where you need to convey much
more of the underpinnings and how you
convey those underpinnings is is sort of
what we're struggling with and then
allowing replication or reuse um and so
while
I think we look at it right now as a
burden as soon as we're on the other
side of the equation and benefit from
reusing someone's data that has been
really nicely documented curated
preserved and easily accessible will
start to see the value and and start to
internalize that value and hopefully as
institutions start to recognize that
that's an important part of the
dissemination
process
anyone
so I'm a a professor of Sociology in the
school of Forestry and Environmental
Studies and I teach a course on uh or
teaching a course right now on big data
and one of the things that I'm having a
hard time with and I'm wondering if the
library or it is going to help with is
just as important as the data are the
the methods we use to analyze them and
and that sort of thing and I know that's
not the focus of the today but I'm
wondering is there going to be more are
there going to be more resources in
terms of
of when I think of my students it would
be nice to be able to send them to some
sort of Workshop instead of having to
work with each student individually on
different methods and things like that
so some sort of maybe intensive training
or opportunities like that on whether
it's like uh programming skills or
working with databases
and so as we've been uh imagining what
uh the center for research Computing
would look like uh we've been thinking
that uh one of the key things that they
need to do is not only create community
and bring people together that can share
methods and techniques but also provide
some other services from the center one
of which would be uh something like the
equivalent of application development or
programming support so someone who can
work with your students and with you and
with other researchers that you're
working with to help develop your your
code uh that's one important thing and
the other thing that we realize should
be part of the mission of the center is
is to provide seminars workshops
training so that the infrastructure and
the technology that we're providing to
you you'll be able to to leverage it the
best way possible so so the hope is that
the center will be providing that for
you a comment here um going right back
to the cyc the committee that that
changed the curriculum at Yale which is
more than a decade ago uh we've been
struggling with uh how to coordinate
better our our early entry level
statistics classes and uh and one of the
struggles that was there then and I
hoped would have gone away by now but
hasn't is that different fields feel
very strongly about have very strong
disagreements about what are the basic
packages you need to learn uh so in the
social in my area of the social sciences
we end up teaching our students uh
essentially boot camps on how to use sta
uh and it we just think it's just a
waste of time for them to learn some of
the packages that they might learn in in
in in the stats department and the stats
department has similar strong views the
other way so uh um and these are these
These are strong and difficult social
norms because it's frankly true that in
my field if they don't know sta they
can't get a job uh so uh you know it
would be nice to have a common standard
Across The Sciences statistics and and
the more quantive social sciences but we
aren't there um uh I don't actually know
what the solution to this is I think
some of it needs to be uh kind of boot
camps for in the relevant Fields where
you learn these things I don't
particularly think you need to have a
whole semester course on how to use sta
for example it's really just uh you know
a couple of weeks to teach people how to
be an RA and teach people how to the
necessary techniques same with same with
some of these programming skills uh but
there is this slight it's unfortunate
that we see this Divergence of what of
the Right Packages because really what
you're talking about I think is basic
programming and the ability to use a
basic statistics
package
I believe then we have uh wrapped up our
session please join me in thanking Ben
for coming here and sharing some time
with us
today and we are now going to shift over
into our uh next session and Gary kidney
is going to be our moderator thank you
and hang in there we'll be right
back I'm Gary kidney I work in academic
its and I'm going to introduce three
people to you who will be part of uh the
next panel this panel is an
interestingly diverse panel come on
through you're going to hear from a grad
student a postdoc and a professor you're
going to go from black holes in the
center of galaxies to Australia's
Outback for and to political behavior of
America so uh the first speaker will
will be uh Vivic Ashok uh Vivic is here
to my left he is a PhD student in the
department of political science his
interests are political Behavior Quant
methods and politically political
economy his research looks at the
effects of information about income
inequality in voter attitudes and
behaviors and in addition to that he
manages the isps behavioral research lab
uh sitting beside him now at the moment
is Hana Haney uh Hana is substituted in
for CLA bowern who would have been our
speaker today on uh uh Australian
languages uh Claire is unable to be here
hany is the post-doctorate associate of
linguistics at Yale University uh she's
a specialist in historical Linguistics
and language documentation particularly
on the languages of Australia and some
American Indian uh angles her work
involves not only the Linguistics but
also crosscuts to anthropology and
evolutionary theory and I'll introduce
our third speaker who doesn't appear to
be here yet but we hope he comes popping
in before his uh uh time to present
comes up Palo copy is a professor of
astronomy and physics his main interest
is in high energy astrophysics
particularly what happens with gas and
radiation physics near where black holes
meet in the universe and in addition to
that he leads a a project called Yale
quest in Chile that looks for
non-stellar variable phenomena through
the world so first off
vivc
perfect um good morning everyone thank
you so much for being here and thank you
for letting me present about uh what
we've been up to at
isps um so my name is via shoke uh I'm
the lab manager at the institution for
social and policy studies behavioral
research lab
and over the past year we've set up a
behavioral research lab and we are we
are open for business now and I wanted
to talk to you a little bit about the
lab about Behavioral Science research in
a laboratory setting and so the brief
overview of the talk is that I'm going
to first talk a little bit about lab
research in the social sciences I'm
going to talk about what we did at isps
and what we're doing differently
I'm going to talk about the data
Gathering
process and I'm going to talk about what
we're thinking about moving
forward so just like the Sciences social
scientists have developed a number of
theories over many many years and a
number of these theories uh give rise to
co questions of cause and effect so as a
political scientist I'm interested in
why people vote we have a theory that
tells us that in closer elections more
people turn out but in closer elections
also see greater media coverage and more
campaign activity so how do we how do we
disaggregate the effects of each one of
these things uh and a good way to do it
is in the lab in in by performing an
experiment um in a more practical terms
uh governments and academics care about
the effects of policies so if we roll
out a school voucher system what is the
effect of the voucher system on
standardized test scores let's say so
social scientists have been doing
randomized experiments since the 1920s
and they're attractive because we have
control over both the treatment and the
assignment to
treatment more specifically a lab
experiment of the social sciences uh
contains some common features uh first
uh subjects are recruited and brought to
a common space a common physical
location they engage in behaviors that
are recorded and are tracked and they do
so all under the direction of a
researcher so these are the common
elements of a lab
experiment and they've been very
commonly used by psychologists and
behavioral re behavioral economists uh
in their
research the unique features of a lab
compared to other contexts where we can
do experiments are the following so we
can more precis L administer treatments
uh so when presenting a video I know the
quality of the video is going to be
equal across all participants viewing
it we have control over outside
influences so I can control the level of
interaction people have with each other
while taking part in the
study and I'm able to collect a lot of
data before and after the session
building a richer data set than average
and finally sometimes we do want outside
influences and we want people people to
be able to collaborate and to compete
with each other in the lab and so we're
able to assign them more complicated
tasks and monitor their
behavior so what's different about the
isps brl the first thing is that we are
truly interdisciplinary so we're
allowing for research of many different
types in the lab where equipped to
deliver behavioral games using a
software package called zre uh we're
able to deliver survey experiments with
tighter control uh using qual Trix or
any other web-based
platform and we also have media lab
which allows us to deliver rich media
like very high quality
videos uh and I think probably the most
important thing about our
interdisciplinary focus is that we're
constantly evolving at the RL so as
researchers approach us with new needs
or new methodologies pop up we are ready
to incorporate them into what we can
deliver so how did we set up we we set
up with the generous support and
encouragement from a number of people um
primarily the institution for social and
policy studies the center for the study
of American politics uh and the law
school um and specifically uh we'd like
to thank Jacob hacker Alan Gerber Greg
Huber Robert post John bulock and Ernie
Moreno the first thing that we thought
about was the space so we needed a place
where participants could enter the lab
from the street with minimal disruption
to anyone else in the building and they
could proceed conveniently to our lab
space the second requirement that we
thought about was our technology so we
purchased 16 workstations and a server
that can handle
delivery of these three different types
of experiments primarily and we worked
with network operations to set up a
network with the bandwidth and the
reliability we needed to deliver rich
media to the
workstations we worked with the human
subject committee for us to develop a
participant pool to have people that are
willing to be invited to take part in
sessions and also just maintenance of
the
lab
and finally we worked with treasury
services to develop a payment protocol
where we can pay the participants that
come into the lab in cash and then
reconcile those with researcher accounts
later so what we what we had when we did
all of this was a lab space so this is
our entrance between 87 and 89 Trumble
I'm sure many of you have passed it and
if you see the sign hanging it probably
means we have a session in
progress and then the space itself so
this is this is a
lab um in setting this up there were
challenges however uh and I think what
our greatest challenge was is control so
the advantage of a lab as I said before
is that the researcher can control
almost every element of the participant
experience while they're in the lab uh
but what that means is there needs to be
control over the workstations and there
needs to be a lot of uniformity between
the environments that participants are
experiencing when they're in the lab so
we had to control people's access to
programs to drives um make sure that uh
a participant couldn't plug in a USB
flash drive and copy data um along with
websites and other system settings and
the way we attempted to do this was by
using local policies and windows um but
they were pretty ineffective uh the
first thing is there are are hundreds of
um selections that you need to make and
once you change one on a workstation you
have to go to Every workstation after
and make that same change and so it was
very ineffective and so um its endpoint
engineering really came to the rescue on
this uh and we added the workstations to
the Y domain uh and then created
different user accounts for each type of
study uh and now what we're able to do
is we merg these local policies into a
group policy uh and all the accounts are
managed centrally on the server and so
if I make one change or allow new access
to one part of the computer or a new
website that's reflected across all of
the workstations so while we did most of
this inhouse and wanted to have a lot of
control over the way we saw this lab
developing um we did run into some
obstacles and and its really helped us
out so now we have the lab
how do we gather data um we gather data
both in and outside the lab we gather
data at three specific points the first
point is at registration the second is
in the lab itself and the third is any
after session data that we might choose
to gather and all of this data can be
merged into one data
set so upon Recruitment and we've been
doing this since spring where we've been
reaching out to Yale students and staff
to join our participant pool uh when
they register they're assigned a user ID
and an account and asked to take a pre-
survey of about 30 questions and this
pre- survey asks questions about
demographics the background some
political attitudes um some personality
traits and um this is managed by a
cloud-based tool developed by Sona
systems um and what's very nice about
this tool is that we are then able to to
create researcher accounts for the
researchers that will be using the lab
and what happens on this Cloud site is
that participant data is updated in real
time and researchers have access to it
immediately while protecting the
confidentiality of the participants so
partici participant data is updated and
then researchers can invite them to take
part in studies that they would like to
field in the lab and based on these 30
different criteria they can get the
sample that they want and they can
invite them directly and all that
communication happens through the Sona
systems website and is monitored by uh
administrators in the
lab and finally so this data is not only
interactive to the researcher but is
also downloadable as a data
set the second point of data collection
of course is in the lab itself so during
the during a session we collect data on
all the behaviors that uh that
participants undergo and we also uh
compensate participants about $15 an
hour for their time that's what we're
asking researchers to compensate
participants and depending on the type
of activity there might be Financial
incentives as well and so participant uh
participant behaviors as well as their
payment and attendance is recorded and
throughout the sessions participants are
only identified by this user ID that's
generated upon
registration and at the end of the
session now we have data on attendance
your behaviors and your payment and so
what this allows us to do at the end of
a session is build one big data set um
of the pre- survey and the
session and we also document the
protocol itself uh the experiment itself
that's delivered where the
randomizations take place so on and so
forth and we reconcile the cash payments
that we Advanced from the treasury
service with the researcher
accounts we update the participant
profiles online uh with their attendance
information uh so future researchers who
may wish to disqualify participants that
took place in a certain that took part
in a certain type of study can do
so and depending on the discipline of
the researcher uh they may get push back
from reviewers at certain journals uh
about how representative their sample is
and so we have a way of directing
researchers to outside sampling firms to
replicate their
protocol so moving forward what are we
thinking about uh right now we are
mostly spending our time on recruitment
we would love to get as many students
and staff members as possible in our
pool um we're inside Yale at the moment
but are certainly thinking about uh
recruiting subjects from outside the
Yale
Community while at the moment it's
pretty streamlined for a participant uh
we're thinking about a way of gathering
all the materials that a researcher
would need to be acquainted with the lab
uh the things that we H are able to
offer and put it in one place so uh part
of the website that we have at the brl
should be dedicated for researcher use
that's something that we're developing
um and something that we've been
thinking a lot about is how to Archive
protocols not just data and the programs
people write to analyze data but how uh
how what is the best way to Archive an
experimental protocol especially when
some of these files are very specific to
programs that might not be in existence
20 years from now and we would like
researchers to be able to find a
protocol and run it um even if the
original program used to deliver the
experiment is no longer
available uh and I'm sure we're missing
things so I would love to hear from the
audience about what your thoughts are
about the lab what we could be doing
differently and what you would like to
see us do in the
future thank you and please sign
up
[Music]
thank all right so I'm gonna take a an
entirely different tack here and um Talk
a bit about how data has changed the
field of linguistics in the in terms of
the types of questions we can ask and
answer um I'm going to be speaking in
place of Clare Bowen who's unable to be
here today um but I'm talking about a
joint project that we worked on together
so hopefully I'll be able to do her
justice so um Linguistics is a field
that has always relied on data it's a
it's a field based on empirical
observations about how people use
language how languages change over time
um and how languages are um so we use a
lot of different types of data to
understand speech
language and the use of language
everything from fine details of acoustic
signals to Broad corpora of actual
spoken or written data so data has been
an important part of linguistics for a
long time but the scale of the data that
we have available to us has been
evolving just as it has in many other
fields um Linguistics is unique in that
it crosscuts a lot of other areas
including both Humanities and social
sciences um so we find interactions
between Linguistics and Fields such as
anthrop anthropology um and even harder
Sciences such as biology um so today I'm
going to talk a little bit about a
specific question um that we've been
able to get better traction on using a
larger data set than has been available
in the past um and specifically I'm
going to talk about sound symbolism in
Australian
languages so what is sound symbolism and
why do we care about it as linguists um
well one of the fundamental ideas about
language um that can be traced back to
in the early 20th century is that the
relationship between sounds and the
meanings they represent is an arbitrary
one so we as English speakers know this
this thing here in this picture as a
horse and there's nothing about an H or
an o or an r or an S those sounds that
uh that has any relationship to this
animal right they don't represent it the
sound it makes or the way it moves or
the way it looks and in fact in other
related languages like French and German
entirely different sounds are used to
represent this thing so there's really
no relationship between the sounds that
we use to represent this object and the
object
itself but we know as linguists that
there are there are places in language
where that arbitrariness assumption gets
violated um so there are places in
language where the associations between
meanings and the sounds that represent
them are iconic in nature so just for an
example we'll look at a different
creature and if we're speaking Northern
Sierra you would call this he which if
you know what a California Quil sounds
like you might recognize that as
something that resembles the call of
this Quil so here we have a really
non-arbitrary assoc association between
a thing and the sounds we use to
represent it we find this in English too
with conventional patterns like the use
of GL this is the sound sequence GL to
mean something about Luminosity so we
have words like glimmer and glisten and
glean and if we had other words come
into the language with this GL sequence
um we might expect other words that come
into the language to represent things
about Luminosity to also use this GL
sequence and finally we have a more more
abstract type of symbolism that's been
studied in linguistics where higher
acoustic frequency sounds are associated
with meanings of smallness or nearness
so this is this is a a rather abstract
or synesthetic type of sound symbolism
where people use specific sounds and
specifically uh capitalize on their
acoustic properties to represent things
about the real world so an example is
the word kuk in Turkish to mean small uh
small or little um and people have found
examples of this in languages across the
world um so there's a whole um number of
references listed here where people have
looked at meanings that mean small or
near or large and far and I found that
they sort of a CLI where High acoustic
frequency sounds are used to represent
those things that means small or near
and low acoustic frequency sounds are
used to represent those things that mean
far or
large but this is kind of a problem in
that um people have gone about finding
data to discuss this problem um by
pulling out examples from languages sort
of at random as they find them so many
of these resources that I've listed here
um they give they provide cherry-picked
examples of sound symbolic forms in many
different
languages
but one of the questions that's remained
largely unanswered um through these
earlier methods where people have looked
at small samples of cherry pick data are
why sound symbolism arises so is it
something that happens as an accident of
History um where related languages just
happen to inherit the same forms and so
we find the same sound meaning patterns
occurring in multiple languages because
they have Inc they have inherited
cognate forms or is it something
cultural where speakers learn to
associate sounds with certain meanings
such as the English glimmer gleam GL
means Luminosity example or in fact is
sound symbolism actually something more
Universal so thinking about these
magnitude related sound symbolic
categories where acoustic frequency is
correlated with size or distance um we
need to ask is this an accident of
history is it something cultural or is
it something Universal and debate has
centered around this question for
magnitude related
symbolism because when we have a small
sample of of forms we can't really
answer this very well so today um I'm
going to talk about some claims related
to magnitude sound symbolism and that is
the old question so the old question is
uh what what causes magnitude sound
symbolism to arise in in many languages
of the world and the new question is how
does it how does it emerge in Australian
languages what representations of
magnitude sound symbolism do we find
attested in
Australia um so quickly I'm going to
take you through a little bit about the
prior work um talk about the data we've
used and then um talk about how our
results suggest new conclusions about
the nature of sound
symbolism so the data we have to work
with for this particular study is quite
different than what's been used before
whereas earlier researchers looked
through dictionaries or wordless or just
their own knowledge of say Indo-European
languages we've actually got a large
data set available to us so Dr bow has
collected a lexical database a database
of words from Australian languages that
has nearly 800,000 items in it for
Linguistics this is Big Data especially
for an area like Australia where the
languages have not been well studied so
some of these languages have very
minimal
documentation um we're going to look at
a sample of 104 pyongan languages that
is 104 languages that belong to a large
language family of Australia and also 16
non poman languages so 16 languages that
belong to about nine other families from
the same geographic area this is a type
of sample this is a type of sampling
that wouldn't have been available to us
earlier in the history of
linguistics and we're looking at
languages for which we have large
lexical samples so languages for which
we have more than 400 words avail able
which covers a good percentage of
Australia so when we look at our 120
language data set we have good coverage
over Australia except where you see kind
of the broad empty Western desert where
simply there isn't a lot of uh
population there's not not not a lot of
um languages spoken there so we've got
an empty spot but we have good coverage
of the actual linguistic diversity of
Australian
languages so for Australian languages
because they hav because no data set
like this this has ever existed before
we don't know a lot about symbolism but
we do know that in a hand handful of uh
Australian languages there's anecdotal
reports of symbolism for example in
things like animat Poetic uh animal
names and things like that um and there
are there's one systematic study of
sound symbolism but there's nothing that
compares across languages so we don't
know much about sound symbolism in
Australia in
general and in the few cross- linguistic
studies that do exist looking at sound
symbol ISM Australian languages are
underrepresented the data just simply
has not been available before to look at
symbolism in these
languages now Australian languages are
are an interesting case study to look at
for sound symbolism because unlike the U
more familiar indoan languages or some
of these ideas about sound symbolism
were first developed or the uh North
American languages where further study
of sound symbolism has occurred
Australian languages have unusually
small vowel inventories so if you look
at this diagram we find just three
vowels in that are typical of Australian
languages whereas they have large
consonant inventories so we might expect
symbolism to be manifested differently
in Australian languages than it is in
other
languages so what we did um was to
compare uh sets of vocabulary that we
expect to be associated with sound
symbolic sounds um so things that
Express meanings of bigness or smallness
or nearness or farness with the general
vocabulary samples we have for each
individual
language so we looked
at um we looked at lexical samples
between 400 and 8,000 items for each of
these languages and split it out into
categories General um distance and size
related
categories and what we're able to do
with this large data set is instead of
looking at individual forms and
individual languages and using that as
our as the entire basis for our
understanding of of sound symbolism in
that language we're able to pull
language data and examine patterns
across the languages of this region more
generally so we looked at percentages of
vocabulary since we have wordless of
different lengths we don't want to throw
away any data um so we looked at
percentages of vocabulary that seem to
show sound symbolic patterns um and we
looked at relative frequencies of sounds
within these samples of um samples of
vocabulary items so that we could see
whether observe patterns match our
expectations or differ from them um in
the past one of the big questions that's
Arisen that's been unanswerable about
sound symbolism is when we find evidence
when we find attested examples of
highfrequency sounds corresponding to
smallness meanings or vice versa low low
frequency sounds and largess meanings do
these things happen by accident is it
just because these languages have these
sounds or these sounds are frequent in
these languages that we find these
patterns or is it something about these
words themselves or these meanings so
we're able to better answer that with
our um with our comparative process and
we're able to measure the contribution
of relevant sounds to symbolic patterns
in different ways so we can look at the
percentage of sounds in a sample that
are of a particular type or we can look
at the percentage of words in a sample
that contain a particular type of
sound so we're able to use a simple
one-tailed paired T Test to compare our
symbol categories to our general
vocabulary samples and answer the
question of whether the frequency of
sounds in magnitude related vocabulary
is higher than its frequency in the
general vocabulary of the same language
so we did this for a number of different
categories overall uh kind of high
acoustic frequency symbolism categories
overall low acoustic frequency symbolism
categories and then subsets of these
symbolic word lists that represent
meanings of size and meanings of
distance
so just to give you a a little sense of
what we're looking at we're looking at
words like these um for our magnitude
related vocabulary words like low or
shallow um words like far or deep um and
also words like thin wide fat large so
these are the meanings we're interested
in looking
at so the results we found are
interesting in that they support some of
the ideas that have been proposed by
earlier researchers but they also open
up new questions um so we we were able
to identify patterns relating palal
consonants um which are a particular
type of consonants that are associated
with high acoustic frequencies um with
the kind of overall category of words
that mean smallness or nearness and also
individually with those smallness and
nearness categories we found a very
strong pattern here but when we look at
front vowels which are a type of vowels
um things like e a um that are typically
associated with that um smallness or
nearness sound symbolism we find that
they don't uh generally uh correspond
with these this high frequency category
of
symbolism but within The Nearness
category we find strong Association so
smallness doesn't necessarily seem to be
associated with front vowels as has been
proposed by earlier research but
nearness does um and then when we look
at high vowels we find similar patterns
where there's a a less clear um
Association overall between the sort of
uh smallness nearness and high vowels
but when we look at smallness High
vowels seem to represent smallness in
particular so here we're able to get a
finer grained understanding of what's
going on with different types of sounds
and different types of sound symbolism
than was possible before um when we look
at nearness we also find a uh an
association between nearness and high
vowels that's not quite as strong as uh
as what we found for front
vowels and then when we look at the
opposite patterns things are a little
bit Messier so we found found pretty
good associations between the smallness
and nearness meanings and some of the
sounds that have been proposed to
represent those types of meanings but
when we look at largess or distance we
find that the patterns aren't quite so
clear-cut so we find um we find
relationships between V consonants like
C or G um and meanings of distance but
we don't find very good associations
between those same consonants and
meanings of size um when we look at back
vowel which are another uh category of
sounds that are supposed to be symbolic
so vowels like or o um we find kind of
mixed results um we don't have a very
clear-cut pattern for how these relate
to distance and size meanings whereas
low vowels seem strongly associated with
both distance and size meaning so we've
got complicated results Happening Here
for distance and
size so looking at the results more
generally we find good support for this
sort of high class symbolism and more uh
messy support for this low class
symbolism but there's a stronger
association between high frequency
sounds and smallness or nearness
meanings than there is between low
frequency sounds and distance or uh
distance or size large size
meanings we find better support for
magnitude symbolism in consonants and
distribution of consonants across words
than we do with vowels which is another
interesting finding it's not been it's
not been discussed
before and we can relate this to
Australian languages and their their
relative inventory relative phonological
inventory sizes so as we discussed
before Australian languages have
relatively few vowels but a lot of
consonants um and so we can help to
determine whether this is a function of
inventory sizes or an independent
fact so we expected associations between
these high class sounds and front vowels
and palal and high meanings and we found
that we also expected associations
between these low class sounds so back
vowels and pal uh back vowels and veers
excuse me there's a typo and uh low
meanings and we found symbolism in both
meanings that are associated with size
and with distance so magnitude symbolism
seems to be robust in both of these
domains but we found some unexpected
things as well that earlier studies that
were based B on again these sort of
cherry-picked examples from a small
number of languages wouldn't have
predicted so we found that for
Australian languages consonants are more
robustly associated with magnitude
symbolism than vowels and we also found
that smallness seem to be uh better
supported uh seem to seem to be
associated with more symbolic sounds
than
largess so um just looking at what's
going on with sounds symbolism more
generally here's where we have an
opportunity to answer questions that
weren't very answerable when we were
just looking at small data sets so for
Australian languages do these patterns
of sound symbolism that we find across
languages arise from some sort of
universal tendency for people to express
meanings of size um or distance with
certain sounds or does it arise for
other meaning other reasons like
language specific Origins where these
languages just happened to have by
chance uh uh developed words for these
meanings that happen to include these
sounds or could it be that these
languages because many of them are
related have inherited the same words
and sounds and sound symbolic patterns
from a common ancestor or could it be as
we find in the Americas that sound
symbolic patterns have spread aerially
from one language into neighboring
languages and so on and so
forth we're able to gain traction on
this with our our large data set so
we're able to find that um it's unlikely
that this is a language specific thing
that just happens to co-occur at random
in uh many languages of Australia so we
find very widespread patterns of sound
meaning associations and specifically we
find um symbolic associations between
sounds and meanings in 54% of the
languages in our studies so using fer
exact tests we can compare uh the
occurrence of sounds in magnitude and
general samples for each individual
language and we find good evidence that
most of the languages in our sample show
sound symbolic
patterns there is some variation though
in exactly which type of sounds get used
to express these sort of symbolic
meanings in these languages so although
most languages show some evidence of
sound symbolism they employ sounds
differently in symbolizing
meanings so we can see that there's a
widespread preference for using certain
types of sounds
for certain meanings but there's a lot
of local variation in how these things
are manifested this isn't necessarily A
surprising finding but it does help us
to to rule out language specific Origins
for these
things we can also figure out whether
there's evidence for sound symbolism
being a
genealogical uh process in these
languages so looking at pungan and non
paman languages that is languages from
these 10 different language families we
can we can demonstrate that sound
symbolism shows up in languages across
all of these language
families we also find that within
different subgroups of the pyongan
family we find significant sound meaning
associations um and finally when we when
we run more sophisticated statistics on
this data set we can find out that
there's very little philogenetic signal
in the sound symbolic patterns that we
find so using a measure of um of
philogenetic signal blomberg's K we show
that there's very little evidence that
this is something that traces through
the philogenetic trees that relate these
languages to one
another um I'm going to skip a little
bit through this aerial Origins uh
section um we tested for spatial
autocorrelation in the data as well
again something we can do because of our
the data that we have and the coverage
that we have of Australian languages and
we didn't find any specific spatial
autocorrelation within this data set so
this leads us to believe that there's
good evidence for sound symbolism in
Australia um that we find some of the
same patterns especially in terms of of
the types of vowels that are used
symbolically in these languages as in
elsewhere in the world but we have a
more complex pattern arising where we've
got evidence for vowel height and vowel
frontness to be involved and the
significant use of types of consonants
that have never been reported to be
associated with
symbolism so we in to sum up we have
support for this frequency code idea
this idea that there's a universal
tendency for people to use acoustic
frequency to encode information about
size and distance but we have a lot more
information now about this the language
internal factors that uh help help to
determine how this sort of symbolism is
implemented from language to
language thank
[Applause]
you there questions later
right
which one which one are we doing which
one are you doing I'm not sure that was
cop okay did right here yeah under under
underneath that one underneath that one
let's close that move it out of the way
yeah
page where is
it full screen oh
slid
okay okay thank you so um I'm here I
guess to tell you a little bit what
what's going on in astronomy and
astrophysics and uh astronomies a branch
of physics some people will disagree
with that but it has uh um connections
to that and the talk will fall on a bit
on the themes that came out last year
where there were Talks by physicists and
another astronomer and also um some
people doing um climate simulations um
this is a big overlap okay so this is
the kind of stuff I do this is our
introductory uh slide when I show up and
give a talk the guys I started out being
interested are these which are mass
super massive black holes that uh you
might think are strange systems they
have gravitational singularity they
eject matter at the speed of light uh
with the Jets um but through big data
type things to in the sense of we
develop surveys that can find for more
and more objects we found that almost
every big galaxy has a black hole at the
center all right and moreover if we take
our galaxy as a black hole and if we
take the matter that fell into the black
hole and we think we kind of understand
what's going on um and compute how much
energy was was released by the matter as
it fell in it's a huge amount and if
spread that energy all over the Galaxy
our galaxy will be blown to bits to
Infinity so these little black holes
that turn out to be everywhere can
dramatically disrupt and change the
structure of the universe that we see so
as time has gone on this used to be a
kind of esoteric study for people who
like buildt atom bombs and stuff like
that because that's the kind of regime
you're in but now it's connected to
other different kinds of astronomy okay
so first thing um if in terms of
computing and big data in astronomy what
often happened the first real need of
big data was in studing systems like
this the reason this kind of system is
complex is um in order to figure out
what's going on you're in a regime where
you have gas and radiation going around
but the gas often has a low density so
that means two gas particles hitting
each other um they're not really
particles they can go through each other
so at a given point in space you can
have uh photons and particles passing
right through each other so to
understand what's happening you need to
understand how much stuff there is at
every point in space but not only that
you have to understand how much is
moving in every particular direction
with with which velocity so your problem
is is not a three-dimensional problem
where is the stuff it's also where is it
moving and how's it moving that's a
six-dimensional problem and as you
quickly discover by looking at the
universe I'll show you in a second the
universe and astronomical objects are
not steady in time so you had to add the
time Dimension so if you have I don't
know you sample some Dimension like okay
I'm going to study this system and I'm
going to take a box a meter in size and
chop it into hundreds okay and I do that
for all the other dimensions my problem
grows uh has a complexity of 100 to the
sth power you you double the amount of
resolution you have your problem gets
incredibly complex so the reason why
certain provos and uh in general Deans
that recruit faculty and astronomy
always groan when the astronomer walks
into the room is whatever you throw at
it I can suck up whatever computer power
you need and it's the same situation um
if you go to the climate studies people
over here if you do weather prediction
you need to have great uh control over
the boundary conditions and lots of
computers uh the initial boundary
conditions so you need to sample for
example the temperature of the Earth on
meter squares that's what we kind of do
now and then evolve It Forward in time
and if you want to get to 10 predictions
10 days down the road you need massive
supercomputers someday we might want to
go for hundreds of days or do global
climate change our computers are not up
to the task it we're getting there and
it's a miracle we managed to get where
we are now um but that's why there's
always from the theory side okay trying
to understand climate which is not
astronomy but the climate the weather
around here there's an insatiable demand
of computer power all right and why is
it big data because um you need the
largest number of computers clusters
these days you do things in parallel and
for example a cluster e has 10 terabytes
of RAM and so if I'm a simulator I don't
have access to the full cluster but if
I'm a super compenent clusters National
supercomputer centers I do um I'm going
to be dumping out snapshots of what's
happening around this black hole as
often as I can all right uh which means
maybe you're going to let me have 100
snapshots so 10 terabytes times 100
snapshot snapshots is one petabyte which
kind of counts as big data so that's
always been happening the thing that's
changed and I'm actually here to talk
about is the other aspect is connects to
herto um when people did astronomy The
Stereotype was a person climbing up on
the mountain top looking through his
telescope freezing to death and finding
some really weird object that exploded
and as often the case in her case that
was a cherry-picked object okay um
because they were looking at one point
in the sky and we'll see about stars
exploding later and they just happened
to see this one and for the first from
1950 to 1970 there were maybe sort of a
hundred supernovas known Supernova is a
star in a death row that explodes and
makes a very violent explosion and um
they're all over the universe but you
have no idea where to look and they last
for 10 days and if you don't have to be
looking in the right direction they're
gone okay um and so people made up
theories of supernovas this is the
archetypal Supernova this is what they
all should look like and everybody went
to work explaining it and then as time
has gone on we now have samples of
thousands of supernovas and guess what
they looked different from the first one
that was discovered okay maybe like the
sounds the frequencies are all wrong in
her case and um maybe a better example
is we look at our own solar system um at
first we thought we were unique then
from studying the Motions of wandering
objects in the sky we discovered planets
all right there are a few planets that
are bit different from us but um maybe
everything else looked like us and you
open books there's a nice theory for how
the solar system formed then now we
found hundreds of solar systems and most
of them look nothing like ours okay um
so we're learning something from lot so
it's the stage where big data and
Technology allows you to expand the
sample sizes that where the big progress
comes in and to expand expand the sample
sizes um where we're at these days in
astronomy also is Big Data in the
traditional sense of pedabytes of data
so let me tell you a bit about that okay
um and there's a project at Y which kind
of classifies uh his big data I'm sorry
the quality is not quite so good um what
happened was that in high energy physics
there's a person called Charlie Bal who
worked in uh building physics uh Cutting
Edge physics detectors and one way that
you measure uh how particles interact in
a particle collider is you put a bunch
of silicon strip detectors that
basically capture the charge from when a
fast particle comes in and you collect
it and those are called charge couple
devices and at one point his life he got
sick of particle physics because we've
discovered everything that we can
discover kind of so he went down a few
floors and talked to the astronomers you
know I know a lot about this CCD charge
couple device I know how to build lots
of them can we do something with that
and yes and so he put 112 of them in
here and made a camera with like a 161
megapixels okay so that's still better
than iPhone but maybe not for long all
right and this camera through various
permutations has ended up on an
instrument called the Schmid telescope
whose sole purpose is to take large
pictures of the sky so people have
always known that they need to make
large samples so what do they do in the
old days well all we had was
photographic plates so people literally
spent years photographing every single
part of the sky and so our previous
knowledge came from photographic plates
but they're not very good compared to
ccds so basically this project replaced
the photographic plate holder with a
modern uh Optical detector and um and
this they get the project working also
not only you have to retr for the
telescope but you have to put in data
links um there's about um 100 gigabytes
of data a night that has to get
transferred from Chile where this
telescope is um up to Yale and then some
of it shipped off to Berkeley and oops
let's see just to put in perspective
what this camera can do though um this
picture is more or less right if you
hold your thumb up that's sort of called
one square degree and the sky and the
moon gets blocked by that this is kind
of what the moon looks like on this
camera with the sky projected on it so
uh this takes a picture of a relatively
huge swap of Sky all right not as big as
you'd like but it's a lot in when in one
night you can cover approximately a 20th
of the sky so after a month you can have
covered the whole sky and then you start
repeating it okay so that's what we're
at okay okay um and this shows you
slightly out of date how much Sky been
covered in this orange band right here
we visited the sky more than 100 times
or 200 times which nobody else has done
quite like that all right so what can
you do when you go visit the sky you
quickly discover that the sky is not
stationary all right and if you have
appropriate software to remove all the
noise and you can see our ccds our
cameras were cheaply built and so
they're not performing that well but if
you have good noise reduction algorithms
all right um you can clean stuff up and
I don't know if you can see this but
there's a spot here and every two hours
you take another picture and the spot
moves across this turns out to be a
Kyper belt object a big asteroid moving
slowly on the outer Fring of the solar
system this same camera installed at
Palomar um found an object that was
quite massive in fact more massive than
Pluto and caused the demotion of Pluto
to be a minor planet if you've heard
about that this was only possible by
scanning the whole sky and looking for
things moving across there all right the
other stuff is of course you can can
find Things That Go Bump in the night
here's one of these supernovas it's a
star inside a Galaxy and here's the
Galaxy flattened out and then if you
look very carefully here you probably
can't see it there's a bright spot that
brightened so this star is actually
outshining the entire galaxy which is
contains 100 billion stars so that tells
you it's a special phenomenon what you
can do is you can subtract off the the
light before the Supernova appeared from
the the Galaxy plus the Supernova and
you see something called a point source
consistent with one super bright star
right and you can measure that Lumin it
you can plot the Luminosity the
brightness is a function of time and it
looks like this and um after you collect
enough of these objects you see that
there's a pattern associated with them
and you can there are some systematic
effects the shape looks slightly
different you can correct for it after
you've done that you can turn this
Supernova event into something that
astronomers really love called a
standard candle where you know the
brightness and knowing that if I take
the apparent brightness and I know the
real brightness I can use the the
brightness goes as one over distance
squared that you learn in school I can
get the distance of the object and using
this um people have proven not our data
our data is part of it but um have
proven that the universe is flying apart
as if there's anti-gravity Dark Energy
pushing it apart okay and you can also
do other fun things like this this is a
particular uh pretty bright star and
when you look at it and you you plot
Luminosity as a function of time you get
a point here you do it the next night
the points way up here you go down you
got a complete scatter plot say what the
heck this is going on this star is crazy
it's theast IC all right but if you're
clever and you mix around you discover
hey what if I take all the points
separated by 1.5 hours and you discover
hey they're all the same brightness okay
so this is a periodic Blinking Star with
a frequency of several hours and if you
take the luminosity and you it's called
phase folding as a function of the
period like every 1.5 hours you plot
those points you get a beautiful diagram
this is not random at all okay so how do
you find this okay well what you can do
is you can take intensity as a function
of time and uh it's kind of a mess
because um this telescope you see has
data gaps there were clouds stuff broke
in the telescope um there points that
are off this is very noisy bad data
which causes all sorts of problems for
uh standard Applied Mathematics stuff
okay but if you just go ahead and
blindly for transform it um you'll see
that some strong period pop out if you
do a modified version this is a
different statistic same thing happens
and then if you fold this and just
require that the points do not scatter
randomly and you have a measure like how
close of the points clustered you pick
out the same period and that's what you
get all right in order to do this though
I have to go searching in order to catch
this reduce this curve for every object
every light curve I have to search
through 200,000 periods okay and do some
other cleaning stuff so there's actually
a non-trial amount of computation in
doing that and how many objects are on
the sky well it depends what you want to
search but for this telescope and its
size they're up to like 500 million
objects that you could search so if you
want to make a complete all Sky survey
of these there's a non-trivial amount of
Big Data pattern recognition data
cleaning and stuff that needs to go into
it all right so just to give you a feel
for what we're dealing with with this
particular project how much data we
talking about here um uh if you consider
what you can do from the ground um we've
reached an interesting point in time um
because stars twinkle unless you do
something special you can't do better
than one arcc of resolution whatever and
that means that there's no point in
billing uh higher pixel detectors except
unless you want to somehow sample the
resolution better but um to zeroth order
okay this is the best you can do uh
until you play tricks and go into space
and in one square degree box I had the
moon inside it therefore I'll end up
having 4,000 by 4,000 pixels which is
twice the resolution of an ultra high
defition TV frame all right um and there
are 40,000 degrees in the sky and if you
interpret how many frames is that okay
that would car respond to about six
hours of uncompressed progressive ultra
high definition video at 60 frames per
second so it's actually not that large
amount of data anymore this was
Unthinkable when I was in graduate
school but as often happens this was
also Unthinkable uh my thesis was done
partly done on a computer one of the
best supercomputers of cray 2 with 2
gigabytes of memory which is unheard of
this thing has two gabes of memory okay
so um and then if you put in standard
color information you end up with um
okay made a mistake 21 12 bytes or 2
terab
okay you can hold the entire sky as
detectable by human eyes with reasonable
telescopes in a few terabytes okay and
therefore you might think astronomy is
over all right let me assure you there's
lots of things we can do to add another
factor of thousand to this okay for
example um your eye measures three
colors red green and blue right but if
you take the light that's arriving you
and disperse it as a function of energy
or frequency you'll see all these
spectral lines it's called a spectrum
atomic spectrum so instead of having
three colors you'd actually like to have
4,000 measurements as a function of
intensity and then it turns out that
objects don't emit in the optical most
of the radiation comes somewhere else
you want to add a few other Decades of
energy resolution and so I can blow up
this number but uh this has been a holy
grail for many years let me make a whole
picture of the sky all right that's what
it takes to do it um for astronomers for
the last 100 years that's what they
expect and then the next step is the sky
has changing so let's do it again and in
quest we have like 100 exposures third
of the sky so we're dealing with
hundreds of terabytes of data so that's
what we need to deal with um okay and
are there any special data needs besides
the ability the need to Crunch this
rapidly okay um this data unlike other
kinds of data like last year we maybe
had talked by geneticist the gene
sequencing machines are getting faster
and faster every year so if you lose all
your data well that's not such a big
problem as long as you're not sampling a
very esoteric population you just bring
in a few hundred volunteers and the
machines now are 10 times faster than a
year ago and you quickly regenerate your
data set here that's good because um you
may know like there was a crab
pulser neutron star that was produced as
a result of a supernova explosion and
people went back to Chinese records in
1066 to identify this guest star that
appeared okay the universe is changing
all the time and what it looked like in
the past is extremely important for
interpreting what happened now so it has
deep archival value this is why people
have not thrown away these photographic
plates there are a bunch of Yale Harvard
is when like two years we have ended up
digitizing like 20,000 of them and
they'll be converted into a more usable
format okay but we want to make sure
this data propagates in time and is
properly curated so that's one of the
the the key things all right um so so
that's that aspect of it and how's it
being handled all right um so to show
you why we're a pain in the neck to it
and stuff uh it's okay the data is
currently handled by um high energy
physics nodes on Omega and maybe about
40 terabytes of this space we have 20 5
terabytes on the RSS server uh and then
we have a mirror and comparable
computing power at Berkeley at the
national uh nurse doe super Computing
Center but right now to be honest the
bulk of the analysis that finds these r
l stars and everything is done by two
and a half four you boxes white boxes
with 12 Intel cores each and 24 dis Bays
filled with 3 tab commodity drives from
New Egg if you know that is and it has
uh what used to be not anymore a large
amount of solid state drives which allow
you to to move data quickly and a large
amount of ram need to use Lou Ram fast
raid cards it's a specialized
architecture to move data fast it's
putting a lot of data next to CPUs so
one of the themes that is emerging in
our field a lot of other fields I think
is having an architecture where data and
CPUs are next to each other because
moving data is extremely expensive so
you want to do the computation as close
to the data as possible so this is doing
it and we are running a mix of operating
systems the bottom line though is
depending on what you're doing choose
the best tool for the task these two
boxes cost $110,000 and for certain
benchmarks they outperform Omega
Hardware it cost like the $500,000 level
so there's a big performance difference
imagine what you could do if you had a
hundred of these boxes and we tried to
put an MRI proposal we didn't get it but
something did get get it and um this
isn't so different from what we proposed
at John's Hopkins University there's
something called the data scope there
like 100 machines like I just talked
about and uh storing the data local to
the computer okay one mapping of users
to know to let them run their custom uh
programs and they add gpus okay and get
rid of various bottlenecks so this is
optimize to handle like astronomy type
data where lots of things come in you
have lots of little subunits uh files
that need to get moved around okay the
old file system on the Omega supercom
computer here was optimized for taking
terabytes of data and streaming it
sequentially and throwing on to the hard
disk as fast as you could the kind of
analysis we do has millions of little
files that need to get gone through and
cross-correlated and and and put
together so it's a different kind of
architecture um but one reason besides
my great proposal skills why this
probably didn't work is um John's
Hopkins has a great track in this kind
of area there's something called the SLO
Jal Sky survey which was a full really
big map uh before Quest was made of the
sky and it involved millions of dollars
and tens of hundreds of postto um and
John Hopkins was one of the leaders
there so they have a track record Gale
and astronomy does not have that same
track record and I think in other fields
we don't quite have it either so I'm
hoping by by bringing people here
together that we can all get together we
have the knowledge cuz I know we've got
people spread all over and uh enhance
our ability to do stuff like this okay
is there a Next Generation where are
things going it's only going to get
worse okay um there was this picture of
a Schmid telescope okay and the person
standing next to it was like this large
now the person is this large and you
take a big mirror telescope you've seen
and you squash it down you make it a
very fast lens so it can see a large
amount of Sky all at once and you
increase the mirror size by a factor
10ish
okay this is the biggest baddest okay
widest vastest deepest eye of the new
digital age all right this thing is
going to be producing data it's called
the large synoptic survey telescope um
synoptic means daily it surveys the sky
every day basically and what's the data
scale for this the numbers the
resolution is not that different from
before um they want to sample the the
profile of the light so they have
instead of one point per pixel they have
five or 10 all right they can do half
the sky every night so they generate
four ped a year right and that amazed me
and other astronomers until you start
googling around and look at the data
sizes of data sets like eBay and stuff
they're also in the pedabytes so one
thing that's changed with astronomy is
we've been a little spoiled and thinking
we're one of the biggest baddest data
generators in the town we're not um the
industry web is far outpacing us and
anybody has large sensor networks um
they're generating huge time series just
like we did and you can you eventually
will have thousands of sensors or
imagine taking you're predicting traffic
patterns Google does this to make your
uh Google Map you track 100,000 cell
phones and how their velocities go and
you can find traffic that's a huge data
set that's even worse than what
astronomers are doing so we're not
necessarily the biggest bad guy in the
town in fact my feeling from looking
over this was help a lot of stuff is
going on technolog is evolving very fast
and I need to get up to speed and even
though I've only been here 20 years a
long time not that old but I was not
trained in any of this all right and in
our department I would say most the the
posts we hired recently know some of
this stuff The Graduate students coming
in don't so somehow we have to change
how we teach acquire the technology
train the new generation of grad
students maybe some of which will have a
specialization involving Computing uh
data aspects so uh not only do you have
to this thing generates some interesting
uh science cases because when the
Supernova goes off you have to jump on
it with many instruments and we're not
ready for that but you better know
something about data cleaning which is a
before you do the data mining and
there's an article in New York Times
that said 80% % of data miners spend
their time cleaning so they're better
known as data janitors okay and how to
pull signals out of messy data and then
um you're not going to deal with the
full data set but I wouldn't be
surprised if you took some subset of it
like 10% 5% 1% we're going to be pulling
in hundreds of terabytes over the
network and we need to push it around
with ease that's not quite possible
today so we need to evolve as a
university I think to be able to do this
cuz other fields are in the same uh boat
and that's um pretty much what want
wanted to say um a general comment about
where astronomyy is going and where the
emphasis uh was needed at various times
people said no we need the biggest
baddest computers and other times people
said no no no think before you compute
and what's actually happened is since I
graduate from graduate school our
ability for example to simulate the
universe from the first perturbations
that made the micro background then
collapse to make uh the galaxies we see
today that ability has improved by a
factor of million in 20 years okay um
half of that in log space factor of a
thousand came from the hardware the
other half came from novel algorithms
and ways of thinking about the problem
so the people and the knowledge about
the problem and the physics and the
hardware are both equally important and
to make best progress you need to push
on both fronts and um one way to do that
is because uh astronomers are not
necessarily the foref funders for all of
us to get together and talk so a
proposal might be some of us could meet
semi-regularly and talk about what are
you doing that's cool in your department
and hey maybe I can do the same thing uh
too so that's where I'll leave it at so
astronomers generate and use lots of
data and we need to learn how to move
into the big really big data era
ourselves and some of the tools that you
can use are not available off the shelf
we have to develop our own okay thank
you so all three members of the panel
are available to take questions I think
we've got about 10 minutes so
please
about
Asom
um I guess you know all the photo
pictures are Optical right so how the
weather would affect on that and how
much you know you would have discuss
what would be the cut off and for the
pictures not would be usable right
exactly that's that's the name of the
game um and so if you require the
pristine conditions depending where you
are if you're in New Haven none of the
nights are usable where this telescope
is mounted in the middle of the desert
in Chile at very high altitude where
there are very few clouds even then 10%
of the nights are lost but some of them
you can recover because um even though
there's a cloud um the Distortion is not
so bad from the wind the cloud absorbs a
lot of light so the stars are dimmer
than they ought to be but if you have
enough area in the sky you can see hey
all the stars are dimmer and you can
compare in the past and you can actually
correct that out so there's some
real-time Corrections you can apply that
enhance your probability of success and
but as you saw in those gaps we were
losing five or 10% of objects and um
some people take the attitude I only
want clean data but if you do that you
lose sorry you lose some of the time
series like you're looking for periodic
objects and you throw away all the bad
data with some Criterion uh you will
lose detection power so what people tend
to do is you specify how much data do I
throw out and you assign a quality
Criterion and then you adjust that but
one of the tricks is to figure out how
is the weather and so astronomers now
have weather classification systems or
auxiliary telescopes like this lsst well
other telescopes whose sole job is to
figure out what's happening with the
weather and the transmissivity of the
atmosphere and everything so that's
that's a crucial point and one way to
get around that is to put your telescope
in space and forget about it so there'll
be a next Generation Space Telescope for
example but that's what makes our life
so difficult is we'd like to have a nice
continuous data Train That's evenly
sampled and you apply your for theorem
well no you lost data for 3 hours and
this data the error bars are twice as
large and so we need a system for doing
knowledge inference based on fuzzy messy
yucky data so that's that's the future
for
us just a quick note to the panel
speakers as you are answering questions
please come up to the podium to answer
the questions thank you
sorry for the asop physics um I know
there's
a ideally uh the data would be uh
uh but are there efforts
[Music]
to period of time the changes in all
these images would be just light and and
is there an effort to like compress the
data over
like like the past yeah you you can
absolutely do that sort of like video
compression the same way the problem is
though that the range of astronomical
time scales um is large I can show you
like one of these blazar the black hole
its Luminosity changes by more than
Luminosity of a galaxy in five minutes
it's it's a trick involving relativity
but it's doing crazy stuff on five
minute time scales okay and other things
take years or 100 days so coming up with
a suitable time frame depends on the
science that you're doing the people in
this lsst project are doing exactly what
you're saying but they're having big
debates all right how are we going to
compress it and what are we going to
analyze it by and different scientists
want to have different algorithms so the
best thing is if somewhere in a vault
somewhere you still have the data when
someone comes up with a clever idea you
can you can find it another thing that
compresses data is if you look at our
data and make a picture most of the sky
um 95% is filled with noise all right
but unfortunately if you know where an
object is and you have 100 exposures and
you add them together what was
previously noise the signal will
actually pop out and so if someone else
later discovers an object and you threw
the information away cuz you compressed
it cuz I didn't find anything there
you've lost some Discovery potential of
course they're funding and space
constraints and everything so you do
what you can ideally though every single
Pixel has information um it's for people
down the road who have different ways of
analyzing it and different thoughts and
oh that was a really interesting
phenomenon what you threw away all that
data so um and the human eye um um
doesn't care about things with
frequencies much faster than 20 per
second and stuff so we can throw away a
lot of data and jpeg stuff um that you
can you can uh help with um you can do
some compression there are lots of those
compression algorithms you can gain
factors two or four and people will use
those and we use that we have a gain of
factor of two by compression but not
factors of 10 or 50 like inid uh
compression so that's a huge topic
for and so be
discussed hello okay it's on um first of
all that's messed up about Pluto I think
we can all agree on that um my question
is I have a quick question for you and I
also have a question for the linguist um
first of all um what do you have an
explanation for why the things that we
observed like the supernovas are were
outliers in two different ways at the
same time one that we observe them and
the other that they look nothing like
the ones you then later saw and I'd love
to hear that explanation and my question
for the linguist is um as I understand
it and I might have I was in the
bathroom so I might have missed the part
of the talk where you talked about your
data is this like a snapshot of the
current state of languages and to what
extent I mean obviously languages evolve
over time that's why we have a genealogy
of of languages but what is the time
frame that would where you could
actually see that happening because
that's like one of the most fascinating
questions for me about language thank
you yeah in our case it turns out for
example if you look at the Sun and
that's the first star you ever saw it
turns out to be completely average okay
but when you have it's just small number
statistics um there's some chance always
that you'll find a guy to be honest most
objects are not such large outliers but
if they were rare and you take the first
one that shows up often times it's not
represented like if you're admitting
student you want to talk to several
people never do uh unless you absolutely
have to don't trust what the very first
person tells you that's and if you have
to bet okay you'll bet that he's an
average person but there's always
outliers just regarding the uh the
situation with language documentation
and the language data we have um in some
places we're really lucky to have
historical documentation so for the
European languages we have records that
go back quite a while for Australia and
many parts of the world it's it's very
like many parts of the world where all
we have are the things that were
attested in this Century um and many of
these languages are not spoken anymore
so we have a snapshot of what these
languages look like perhaps in the early
20th century perhaps later in the 20th
century um but that's what we're looking
at as one snapshot in time and what we
as linguists are trying to do especially
we historical linguists is trying to
leverage that data to figure out what
the data tells us about the past so
those fogies you talking about those
have actually been constructed from data
about attested languages not about
historical languages for most parts of
the world where we're actually able to
use the Contemporary data to reconstruct
the past so we've got a a window of
about 10,000 years most people think for
that
yeah so about language I mean have you
looked at the relation between emotion
and the actual acoustic signature of the
words because this must be common across
languages quite a bit there is work on
that um so uh it's one of it's called
corporeal sound symbolism in the sort of
Hinton at all schema of sound symbolism
so there's there's definitely work on
how acoustic frequencies signify things
about emotion and state of mind and
things like fear and anger
yeah we don't have data about that for
these Australian languages we don't have
any um if you have a corpus of actual
conversations you might be able to
extract information about that but we
have limited
data so in order to keep us on schedule
let's take a few moments and thank the
panel and then maybe five minutes to get
set up for the next uh uh speaker thank
[Applause]
you question that was so fascinating I
could not believe how fascinating that
was very exciting oh my God it was so
exciting
yes
this
e
ch
long
okay let's get started with the uh the
next
session test test test one
two I'd like to introduce our first of
two keynote speakers
today this speaker is the first
associate director for data science
appointed at the National Institutes of
Health formerly he was the associate CH
Vice Chancellor for innovation in
Industry
alliances a professor in the department
of pharmacology and skeggs of the skagg
School of Pharmacy and pharmaceutical
Sciences at the University of Cal
California San Diego the associate
director of rcsb at the protein data
bank and and an Adjunct professor at the
Stanford Burnham
Institute I welcome to you Dr Philip
[Applause]
War thank you Karen it's very nice to be
here and uh I've enjoyed the morning so
far um so as was said I'm actually the
first person in this job and it's really
um I guess I don't know how far I can
think ahead but I decided you're having
a day um I'm thinking in months and also
grants tend to be the on average of the
order of four years so that's sort of uh
at least some of the thinking that goes
into the title um so what what I'm the
question I'm going to kind of address
here today is uh what is nih's overall
approach to data and what does it mean
to you uh and I know some of you here
are not uh in fact in the biomedical
Arena um and so but I think this kind of
generalizes uh and and certainly based
on discussions I've started to have with
the other agencies uh which frankly
there hasn't been enough of in the past
um I you know I think it translates so
just let me give you a little context of
how um things got started at least in
the NIH space um uh the director of the
NIH Francis Collins uh realized several
years ago that uh that the data
Revolution was coming to bi medicine and
uh convene a working group to look at it
and that led to a report which the
findings you can see here on the screen
um kind of things that are fairly
obvious um sharing uh cataloging
training the kinds of things we heard
about today already um one thing I would
emphasize that is the idea of support
for all of this throughout the research
life cycle so this has to go on from
almost from the moment ideas are
formulated to leading to hypotheses to
uh questions that are asked to D that's
generated using software uh which leads
to results which are then disseminated
including uh in the literature but now
increasingly in other ways which it has
been mentioned and another part of that
was the idea that there would be someone
to sort of uh lead this initiative and
uh which I think is an expression of the
importance of this this this kind of
role in fact I report directly to
Francis Collins in this role and it seen
very uh important within the NIH it got
kicked off uh by uh Eric green who's the
director of the human genome Institute
initially uh and that led to something
called the big data to knowledge
initiative so I'm going to sort of uh
not talk too much about uh these thing
or that initiative per se but some of
the findings and some of the directions
that we're going in uh which I think is
important to institutions like Yale uh
because not only will it tell you where
the funding uh areas are likely to go
but I think it also speaks to uh General
philosophy of what how we're thinking
about things within the NIH and how I'm
interested I'm interested to see how
that mirrors to what goes on in an
institution such as this because we
refer things as you'll see in a moment
to the notion of uh the NIH becoming a
digital Enterprise and in many ways
that's kind of what we're talking about
here and that has some very interesting
connotations I think um so let me just
give you a little uh my own bias because
so can take with what I say with a grain
of salt uh until six months ago I was a
tenur faculty member at UCSD and I gave
up the sunshine and 10 years to do this
um but uh I certainly don't think as a
Fed at this point in time and hopefully
I never will um and I'm also very much
into the E science and open science
movements of which I've been part of for
a number of years so let me give you a
few observations that um we haven't
necessarily heard about um uh I'd say uh
today so far so first one is we talk
about the promise of this big data but I
would argue we don't even know uh the
value of the little data we don't really
know the value of the data that we've
already got at least from the point of
view of the federal agencies we don't
actually ask the right questions we ask
questions like okay well how many
terabytes are you generating how many
people are accessing them and and and
that's about it you know but when you
start digging down into the granularity
of the data who's accessing what data
object or research object when and why
and those are the sorts of questions
that are not asked which is kind of
ironic because those are the questions
that data oriented companies ask
themselves every day and one of the
reasons I would surmise that we don't
ask these questions uh is because we
don't actually think as a business we
don't think in terms of supply and
demand about this and my argument would
be going forward we're going to have to
think about this
uh as much more as a business than we do
today because what we're doing as you'll
see and I'll emphasize this a few times
just doesn't
scale um so we've already heard about
the value of curation and and so forth
and but you know that is expensive in
terms of time and money and when you do
that it's at the price of something else
and the question is what is that
something else and how do you evaluate
uh how much you should you know how much
time and money should be spent these are
not uh simple questions and then if you
start to look at data retroactively it
becomes really expensive and I know this
from personal experience with something
like the protein Data Bank where for
several years we spent about 40% of our
budget retroactively reviewing and and
essentially homogenizing the data that
we already had so that we could actually
com do comparative analysis that no one
perceived as being important important
when we first started collecting this
data but became comp important later on
so we're now a much more educated about
the importance of uh of this kind of
activity um but if you have to do things
retroactively it's very
expensive and then I would say and
you'll see how we're structuring our
thinking in a moment um but I would just
say that good Data begats Trust trust
trust begats community and Community is
God what I mean by that is the idea that
that we do being the NIH uh should
really be done without the the community
driving it and we just know from
previous experience in a series of
different resources that that Community
gets has to trust in what we what's
being done and you know good D good data
is essentially key to that and we
certainly experienc that in again I'll
just cite my experience with protein
Data Bank um that getting that Community
Trust probably took five years of
running the resource uh and that
involved engaging the community in every
single step of what we were doing around
defining standards uh around uh the
kinds of uh applications that we
provided uh on the data and so
forth uh as I said already what we're
doing is not sustainable I mean you can
be a first grader and you see two graphs
if you look at biomedical research and
you look at the current um funding
levels and I I'm anticipating that these
aren't going to change significantly in
the next several years they are
decreasing uh in biomedical adjusted
inflation dollars and yet any any graph
you want to look at Visa V the data it's
growing uh at huge rates and in the way
that we just heard in the previous talk
so you know how do you reconcile this
and I think um so this then comes into
this idea that we really don't have a
business model right now uh currently
for scientific data dat if I look at a
few observations uh WI a what's going on
at the NIH that needs to be addressed is
we have a little idea how we spend uh
how much we spend on data I went round
there are 27 institutes and centers at
NIH focusing on different diseases
different organs and so on I went round
to every single one of the directors and
I asked two fundamental questions you
know how much are you spending on data
related activities and how then the
harder one was how much do you think you
should be spending um
what we do know approximately uh because
we've scraped extra mural databases and
so forth and looked at things inter
murly that we're probably spending well
over a billion dollars a year on data
related activities it's probably much
more than that actually of course how
you define it makes it a little
difficult but uh we don't have much idea
on what we should be spending and that
brings out a natural tension um the
tension there's a sort of a culture
clash between the more observ in terms
of biom medicine the more observational
history and the new analytical
approaches to Discovery and there's
tension within uh
organizations uh whether they be U you
know medical centers um academic medical
centers or whether they be the NIH uh
about those relative those
constituencies so it's it's these are
all things that uh that need to be
considered so let's see
here uh okay so
the observation I would make for an
academic Medical Center is the idea that
the it it's not that different to what
we have at the NIH you have a set of
effectively uh of silos of
information and what you're trying what
we're moving towards with this notion of
a digital Enterprise uh is really
breaking down those silos to some extent
and I think data is an example of a
catalyst that can make that happen so an
example of that would be and maybe it
exists here but I haven't actually
encountered it anywhere else yet is and
I actually wrote about this in an
article but the uh is the idea that if
you look at students coming in
increasingly those students are doing at
least part of their training online they
they're taking online testing and so on
but if a student does exceptionally well
in a particular fragment of a
course then there there's no way
currently for really that information to
be conveyed to the professor who has a
profile which which would indicate that
they're an expert in that particular
area so that kind of cross connection
could highlight to the kinds of students
uh that would be uh would be very
valuable unless you're actually teaching
that course you probably wouldn't uh
make that connection and that's just one
trivial example uh of the kinds of cross
cutting that can take place um and that
to me is the whole idea of this digital
Enterprise So within uh the associate uh
director of data science office we've
come up with a mission statement that
sort of reflect reflects this the second
part of that uh in italics is really
just taken from the NIH Mission itself
but what what we're trying to do and
what's going to be reflected in funding
calls and so forth is help enable this
notion of an ecosystem that takes us to
this digital Enterprise where we uh
increase the rate of discovery uh by
virtue of how we use data so it's it's
more than just about Big Data although
big and I I'm not necessarily a fan of
the term Big Data uh for reasons I'll
get to in a bit but I think the
important thing about it is it brought
me here it B you know it it actually
brings attention to the whole problem
and I think that that's uh that's that's
definitely a good thing so I guess one
of the things we need to ask ourselves
is what what are the kinds of things
we're trying to solve so one of them
which I've been harping on already is
sustainability so uh if if we have this
model where we can't currently sustain
what we're supporting what are we going
to do well right now what we do as a
federal agency is we fund something we
fund something then one day we say
there's no more
money and you know that's not a healthy
model I mean another model is to is
would be what I would call a 50%
business model so we're going to say
here's a grant this year you're going to
get all the money you've had in the past
to sustain this data but that's going to
ramp down by a certain amount for the
next four years until it's at a 50%
level so you've got this amount of time
to actually figure out how to uh sustain
that data more efficiently and that
could that could mean a number of things
um it can mean a partner it can be
merging it can mean a whole series of
things um so you know the that's just
one example other example is efficiency
uh we already heard a little about the
issues with patient data and and having
uh access uh one of the things that
we're looking at is the notion of The
Trusted investigator so right now if you
want to for example access data in a
resource called DB Gap which is uh
genotype to phenotype information every
time you want to do that you have to go
and get uh new approval uh there's the
notion of being a trusted investigator
where you actually have a blanket
approval that allows you to access this
data of course if you lose that trust uh
through some event then um it's like
being disbarred I suppose so we're
looking at this kind of model I'm not
saying that's actually going to happen
but I think uh there's definitely uh
need for creativity in this kind of
space
uh reproducibility has been touched on
here today A little already but clearly
this is something that really worries uh
the folks where I sit at the NIH so you
can imagine the situation that the uh a
congressman or woman was sitting there
reading the newspaper and reads as has
been published that whatever it was 60
70% of seminal cancer studies could not
be reproduced um and they say to
themselves why on Earth are we giving
the National Cancer Institute $4 and a
half billion dollars a year if all this
work can't be reproduced this has
potentially very wiring Ripple effects
uh throughout the research Enterprise
because all of that would trickle down
uh if that happened so there's a a very
Avid effort right now uh with across all
of the 27 institutes and centers to
actually look at this reproducibility
problem and clearly data accessibility
software accessibility in fact
accessibility of all the research
objects within the Enterprise um are is
a is a a step in that direction of
dealing with
it um and then the whole accessibility
we're in a situation where when clinical
trials are run uh there was suddenly a
discovery that many clinical trials
weren't even registered even though
that's the law so there are lots of uh
these kinds of nuances around clinical
uh data as well and then I'll say a
little more about traines in a second so
the idea is to create uh help Foster an
ecosystem and I see that ecosystem is
effectively a three-legged store there's
the community there's the policies that
go uh into place which is sort of the
top down so I would see that these are
essentially the policy is sort of a top
down approach and the community is a
bottom up approach and then of course
you need the infrastructure to support
all of this um and then on top of all of
that I think what you really need is you
need uh the notion of a virtuous
research cycle and this was actually
drawn at a recent Workshop we had um
sort of Advisory Group that came in to
provide some information this was
actually drawn by uh Dave Glazer from a
chief engineer at Google uh and the
notion is that none of this is going to
happen without there being the value to
the investigator who's going to be
required to do some of this we can put
policies in place but if there's no
value in doing so to the investigator
getting them to do it is going to be
extremely difficult so these things need
to be harnessed such that when we do
some of this whatever it is whatever
policy we want put in place whatever
infrastructure we put in place we do so
in such a way that it's it adds value to
uh what can be done with research so
that's that's the notion behind all of
this uh what are we doing to seed this
kind of uh new
ecosystem uh well my office is actually
very small uh but there are a whole
series of people across the 27
institutes and centers that participa
and this year we're spending about $30
million on this and next year it's going
to be of the order of $80 million most
of that money goes to the extral
community to uh enable help Foster this
uh
ecosystem so uh we have a whole
organization associated with that and I
won't go into that and a whole bunch of
people are doing it so what are the kind
so let's let's take each leg of this
stool and look at what it is that we're
dealing with that we need to deal with
well at this you know we're talking
talking about a pretty complex system
here so aside from the agencies the NIH
itself there's many other agencies uh
that are all part of this that we're now
interacting with and there are many
other government uh branches that all
feed into this and at the same time
we're all driven by uh various
initiatives particularly the holdr memo
that relates to open data so there there
is now you know a mandate that this data
has to be made available which is really
the dve either what I've learned in my
brief time in government is it's also
referred to of course as a non a
non-funded mandate so all of this has to
happen without any additional funds from
the federal government to support it so
this you know this this brings into the
question uh the sustainability issue
again and then the private sector is
involved in all of this and I think one
of the uh pushes that I really wanted to
have in going to the NIH that Francis
Collins is supporting is the idea that
we do much more with the private sector
than has previously done been done
before and so that involves
pharmaceutical companies uh it providers
and so on and then there's a whole
series of organizations uh that play
into this and I think what we're doing
uh and looking to do with these uh with
these folks is that they're
representative communities we haven't
actually necessarily interacted with
very much in the past particularly for
example statisticians computer
scientists mathematicians so we're
really looking and I'll give you one or
two examples of things that we're doing
to Foster that kind of uh new
interaction but it's clear that this
this all of these types of people need
to be brought into the mix if we're
going to uh enable this ecosystem so
that's one leg of the store uh so what
about policies as another leg uh well
clearly we need much better data
clinical data harmonization so the idea
that if you have uh one set of
represented clinical data uh that's
being collected uh in one type of
electronic health record that in fact
and another that there's some level of
synergy between that some level of
synergy can be got that is very
difficult right now anyone who's worked
with this kind of data and this is true
of other data types as well um it knows
what the problems are even though we
have standards for for some of the
information within those records so but
we we need to do much more we need new
standards uh we need uh reasons to adopt
those standards uh and we need examples
where they've actually been adopted and
they're working
well um another example policy which is
relatively new within is much more of a
notion of adoption of the cloud so there
was there's been a lot of resistance
within NIH to the cloud across the NIH
but now there are a series of cloud
pilots and different institutes and I'm
going to give you an example of
something that's going on in a minute um
but DB Gap is this uh genotype to
phenotype database that is uh we now
have to go ahead to move that into the
the cloud into a hippoc compliant Cloud
uh another thing is the notion of data
citation so this is what I was alluding
to when I made a comment earlier this
morning is elevating the value of data
within the scholarship Enterprise and
the idea is that uh so there's a
technical Nuance with this which makes
it uh feasible more feasible than it was
before so what happens when a journal
article gets published uh in the
biomedical science
that's represented in an XML format
that's Jets so-called Jets compliant so
that's then ingested by PubMed and pubid
Central and made available to the
community either as an abstract or as a
full text so what's happened is there's
an extension to that jats which supports
data
citation and so that means you can have
a machine readable representation of a
data citation which of course you can
then use to generate as we do for paper
citations different human human readable
forms so we we're moving towards saying
that data citation at the NIH that data
citation is a valid uh ENT entry within
your uh scholarly record whether it be
in your bib sketch when you apply for a
grant if whether it be in a report uh
associated with that Grant so this this
begins to elevate uh the value of data
this is in keeping of course with the
fact that data journals are now emerging
where good quality data sets are valued
as part of
scholarship it was mentioned earlier at
the beginning with the the libraries are
helping with data sharing plans this is
good uh unfortunately I say this as a pi
that the current status of data sharing
plans is is basically a joke uh you know
in in the first of all in the NIH only
grants over 500k direct uh budget per
year are required to provide data
sharing plans well this this seems to me
to be crazy it's sort of saying that uh
that uh you know small Grant data
generated on small grants doesn't have
any value this doesn't make any sense at
all there's a move to move that all will
come into play fairly shortly that all
grants and this is part of the uh
directive from uh the office of Science
and Technology policy anyway that that
that has to be all of that data has to
be available um so that means all grants
will have data sharing plans to describe
how that's going to happen but you know
we have no there are not there's no way
that right now that anything is done
with that with that with those plans
they're not enforced so there's no
incentive to do anything with them but
what we're moving towards is the idea
very soon that there there will be more
more enforcement so that enforcement
will come from the idea that first of
all the machine read the data sharing
plan needs to be machine
readable so which is ironic actually
right now that it isn't at least parts
of it so for example we will be able and
you apply for a grant we will be able to
extract from that that on year two of
this grant you you're going to put data
in resource X so after two years there
will be an automatic trigger that will
go out to Resource X and see whether in
fact there are data objects within that
Grant uh within that resource sorry that
actually have the grant number that uh
that uh you that you you you have so
it's a way of automatically closing the
circle and then of course if the data is
not in there there could be good reasons
for that but if the if the data hasn't
been shared when it should have been
shared then you know we can put a bit of
pressure on on getting that uh in
getting that to happen in a in a fairly
automated way I mean these things need
to be introduced slowly and carefully so
it's not like this is all going to
happen overnight but this I'm just
giving you a sense of the general
movement uh which is essentially saying
uh more data should be shared and we
need to value that uh the the people who
do that um on that note of value we're
also looking at different review models
so there's a general notion that data
Centric grants within the NIH framework
are not don't necessarily review very
well but the study sections doing it
they they're generally part of uh other
study sections or are they part of a
study section where that the emphasis
May for example be more on experimental
work and the data part doesn't get
reviewed very well so we're looking at
ways uh of dealing with that we're going
to do some experiments this fy15 which
starts actually next month um so one of
the things we're going to experiment
with with some of this big data to
knowledge funding next year is in fact
open grants and open review so if you
have a you know and you know many
investigators won't want to do that
they'll feel that they're giving too
much away but we'll see whether for more
data oriented grants there's interest in
doing this so the grant itself would be
open and accessible for people to look
at uh and also um the review process
itself and the reviewers would be open
uh it may be that we don't get any
applicants and we don't get any
reviewers uh but you know these are
experiments that I think we want to to
actually I mean the course that one
driver in an optimistic sense might be
well you know supposing you're riding a
grant on a on some form of uh rare
disease well it doesn't get funded so
what would happen to that now
essentially it would go into a black
hole and potentially resurrect itself in
a different form in a year from now
right um here is an opportunity that it
would be out there and an advate group
or you know a blue button or red button
whatever you want to put it could
actually be put onto this to to try and
raise funds to support that Grant so
whether that will have foundations and
so on could potentially pick it up who
wouldn't normally have known about it um
so and there other I won't go into a lot
of details but there are other uh sort
of approaches for this okay so let's
let's go to the another leg of the
school let's go to the uh the
commons uh which is part of the
infrastructure so so we're actually the
next week or two we're standing up
something which we call the
commons uh and effectively what that is
is we have what by these directives that
come all the way from president of
United States we have the why for data
sharing what we don't have is the how
and then we have an endgame and we have
different types of data so those
different types of data a lot of which
is of course the long tail so it's all
this data that according to these
directives is going to need to be made
accessible in some form which right now
probably languishes on a lab desktop or
somewhere in the lab for a while and
then disappears um that is you know
example of longtail data so potentially
and and often that that data doesn't
have a home it doesn't fit into a
traditional resource where uh things go
and then there's a whole series of high
throughput experiments that are done in
biom medicine uh you know what happens
to that data right now there are core
facilities that provide that data to
investigators which are funded by the
Nia but they don't actually maintain
that data typically for very long either
so that's another form of data and then
of course there's a special needs of
clinical uh and patient data uh and then
associated with that is the end game
that we want out of all of this of
course which is you know some high
quality data that's usable for which
Discovery can be made and so on and then
in the middle there a series of
stakeholders it's not just NIH awardees
uh it's the rest of Academia it's the
private sector and it's other government
agencies and so what we're doing doing
is we're putting together an environment
uh that's only we're only we're standing
this up and we're going to test it out
it's going to be a small project a more
small agile approach um through a thing
we call the commons and the the awards
that we're about to make are need those
folks that have those awards are going
to need to be Commons compliant so what
does that mean um I'll explain that in a
second but the the basic idea of being
in the common is at the the simplest
level it provides a Dropbox like storage
so you can drag and drop uh NIH related
or other for that matter information and
data uh it brings computes to the data
uh because in large SC in large part
this initially at least will be with
Cloud providers and it provides a place
to uh in principle to collaborate and
discover so that's sort of you know the
beginnings of what it's going to look
like but I don't think any of this is
going to work without what I alluded to
earlier is a new kind of business model
what we're looking at in the longer term
uh is uh a business model that changes
the way that we currently fund Computing
uh across uh the the
ni again this will not be is this will
not be done on mass it will be done in
in a set of trial agile experiments to
see whether there's value in this but we
believe we can get much more compute
value than we currently get
so you take a series of Commons
compliant resources and their compliance
Revol only involves two things which is
still under discussion but one of them
is that whatever goes in there whatever
research object goes into the commons
has to have some form of identifier so
it can actually be indexed and
found and that that finding will be done
by an award that's already been made
it's going to be funded as of October
the
3rd um and then beyond that there will
be a set of Providence for each of those
research objects and then a series of
metadata depending on the object type
the at the beginning that will be very
what's required will be very very uh
cursory and limited it's really about
providing attribution for the whatever's
put into the
commons and so that's that's the commons
and there's a with a set of Commons
compliant resources that could be HPC
facilities they could be government Labs
it could be public clouds could be
private clouds as long as they conform
to these rules we can find the
information the research objects are in
there and they can be operated on and
then the value of this is the business
model and the business model basically
says um rather than giving you money to
go out and buy your own computers and
other we're going to give you credit to
spend in a common compliant
resource and you can spend that credit
wherever you want so if you do work that
has is very compute intense but on
unlimited set data you'll probably go to
a different provider than if you have a
lot of data and minimal compute because
they have different charging algorithms
associated with that so that drives
competition in the
marketplace uh then what happens is you
get that credit you spend that credit at
a Common's compliant resource the
resource bills the Bro a broker service
the broker bills the NIH the NIH pays
one bill a month which goes back to the
broker that distributes this across all
of the uh the common compliant resources
so this is something that uh we want to
try and we believe that we can get uh
significantly more compute resource for
the dollar than we currently in the way
that we currently spend uh compute money
so we'll be experimenting with this uh
across uh 200000 across fy15 again with
specific applications that support the
whole research life cycle so there's
there's actually motivation for working
in this space so it's the opportunity to
actually do real science in this kind of
environment it's not just trying to
build it and they'll come kind of thing
we'll look for specific applications
that are really going to work in this
kind of
environment um so and then I think the
last thing I would say is really about
uh training and diversity we've touched
on this but I think the there's really
the need uh it's sort of at the center
of these uh of these three parts of the
these three legs of the store but uh
without that uh you know I think we're
we're going to be in some trouble and
part of the issue I would say that
bothers me I can illustrate with a
little story so when I was in San Diego
um Google didn't have an office in San
Diego they had an office in Irvine which
is about 60 miles away so what they
would do is they would run a pretty
fancy bus every day from San Diego to
Irvine to take Google employees up there
what I noticed over a period of several
years is more and more of the folks in
my lab were actually getting on that
bus and to me that was that's somewhat
disturbing for a variety of reasons but
now I'm at the NIH it's disturbing
because quite often those people have
been trained to do various types of
biomedicine and yet they're now perhaps
doing something completely different
that's not necessarily a bad thing but
um it it's it illustrates a strain or a
loss to the biomedical infrastructure
and research Enterprise and when you Pro
when you probe as to why some of those
people are leaving yes on an NIH Grant
you're never going to be able to offer
someone the salary they're likely to get
it Google but some of those people did
not want to leave they want they were
Scholars and they wanted to be
appreciated as Scholars and they felt as
data scientists in the academic system
many of them weren't treated as as as
formal Scholars and I think there's a
general recognition that this this is a
problem and in fact we're in the throws
of organizing a workshop with the
National Science Foundation to actually
bring in uh VPS of research Vice
chancellors of research and so forth to
actually sit and address this sort of
problem of how to uh really recognize
these people and I think there's a
willingness to do this because there's a
growing uh realization I know this
because I was a a part-time
administrator University tour recently
that there's the potential to lose money
I.E through indirects because grants are
going elsewhere because there aren't the
cad of data scientists to support them
within that institution and the kind of
Center I heard about earlier today
obviously is a good way of addressing
that and I think we we would be uh very
uh interested in in figuring out ways
for how we can support that kind of
Enterprise uh so you know uh you know
and I think another aspect which where a
place like y could be really helpful is
really I think uh given uh proportion of
our budget that goes into diversity the
idea that we have uh partnering grants
with uh with other smaller
institutions uh where where that can
foster diversity where those people can
come and they can do joint training in
places like uh like Yale um you know
this is something we're exploring for
next year um and we're actually really
doing a whole assessment of what we Fund
in respect to training in data science
across all of the NIH because uh it's
clear that in in we're not we're not
necessarily being uh as effective as we
could be there are certain institutes
for example that are all all funding the
same kind of thing when that could have
uh and then there are other areas of
important data science that are just not
getting addressed so these are just
examples uh of what we might do um with
respect to
training um and there will be certainly
diff additional uh training grants uh
was mentioning earlier that there's also
I think we definitely support the idea
uh of libraries being an active uh
player in the data science Arena uh and
I think we're actually going to uh
provide some grants probably this uh
this fiscal year where there will be the
opportunity to apply for funds where to
encourage Librarians to further engage
with researchers uh around the data
curation uh the data distribution and
the data use uh problems so I guess it's
much better to have a dialogue and we
we're going to hear some other comments
and i' I've purposely not said too much
about the clinical space because I think
that's going to come up next um but I'd
say the closing question is you know uh
I sit each week now in the office of the
director and we have a meeting every
week where we spend half of that meeting
really describing the efforts that have
gone on on the hill that week to try and
get more money for the
NIH and you know there's a very it's
very interesting going from being an
outsider to an Insider and I think every
researcher ought to have a window into
the NIH to see how PE how much they try
to get more money to support biomedical
research but the fact of the matter is
as hard as they try uh you know it's
that hasn't changed uh you know so you
know so the question is we're now asking
ourselves given that flat budget what
can our office do to improve data
science activities because it's
absolutely clear this this the level the
types of analytics that are coming in
biomedical research through the Advent
of this data really required us to
change the way we're doing things and
that's the sort of cultural shift I was
sort of alluding to earlier and that's
without a doubt the hardest thing to do
of all so I'll just stop there and uh I
guess we're going to
have
our next speaker is Dr Amy Justice who
will respond to Mr born's presentation
um Amy is Professor of medicine at the
Yale School of Medicine professor of
Public Health at the Yale School of
Public Health and section chief of
General Internal Medicine in the VA
Connecticut Health Care System she has
conducted research focusing on outcomes
and chronic HIV infection for more than
20 years please welcome Dr Justice
[Applause]
thank you uh before getting into a
response I thought it might be helpful
to tell a
story uh I came into the informatics Big
Data World by accident I'm a general
internist I went to medical school when
I went to medical school I told the
interviewers I wasn't interested in
doing research I wanted to be leader in
primary care I was very interested in
figuring out how we could provide
Primary Care more efficiently and
appropriately to all people in the
United States that was my my goal as a
young
individual and as I went to medical
school I began to realize that uh I came
from a legal background and I questioned
everything and you know that doesn't
work very well on the wards people don't
really like that they say we do this
because we do this they don't want to
have 20 questions about why we were
ordering this test or that test or the
other test so I quickly realized that
maybe research was a little bit more my
cup of tea because in research it's good
to question everything right and then I
started to rotate onto the VA health
services so uh for those of you who
don't know the VA has a national
electronic medical record system it's
had it for a very long time uh it's
extremely complete and integrated uh
with the VA Healthcare System so
Pharmacy fill and refill data is in
there we know about what medications
people are taking we know all the
Laboratories if they go to one VA in
Florida during the winter and another VA
in Connecticut during the summer we can
follow them from those two places it's
really a pretty amazing system and it's
been fully paperless for more than a
decade so as I was training I began to
realize this is a gold mine there's an
incredible amount of data in this system
and so I started to ask people so if I
wanted to do some research on this data
how do I get it out
of the system and people said I don't
have a clue you you can't get it out
once it goes in it's there it was sort
of this magical thing well then I began
to talk to some programmers and to learn
a little bit about what was behind the
scenes and about how you might be able
to get that data out and eventually I
was able to pull the data out in a small
way and that was the beginning of my
career I've built a cohort study of
veterans aging with and without HIV
infection in the VA that now has 15
years of observational data from the
electronic medical record system and
it's supplemented by a number of other
sources the reason I drag you through
that story is that I think that it tells
you of some of the issues that we're
going to face as we think about at least
one form of big data which is the
medical record data uh I have been asked
questions at NIH like okay so you're
going to build the cohort who's going to
do the
science just to illustrate the Divide
between what's considered science at NIH
and what isn't considered science at NIH
I've also been told well this is a
purely observational
study uh meaning that therefore it's not
scientific uh these are biases that if
team science if Big Data if all of the
things that Phil mentioned as being
really important are going to happen
have to be overcome we have to get over
our biases we have to understand that
people who understand observational data
are an important member of the team
and along those lines we need to learn
to trust each other which is something
that Phil was absolutely mentioning um
something that is not easy for people
who need to get their next Grant funded
to do it's also sometimes not easy
because our institutions make it more
difficult and Phil and I've discussed
some of those issues but one of the
things that I would like to hear about
is how are we going to improve the
responsiveness to observational science
and the value of observational science
uh in this new
domain okay that's a good question um oh
here
sorry so let me just say that I think
there's some precedence for this history
here uh perhaps in slightly different
domains for what has happened and uh
Mark G and I can certainly attest to
this because we're in the area of
computational biology but I remember and
so it's really the tracing a his
historical uh progression and then
comparing it to what you're you know
where we are and what what what you want
to happen so I'd say that what in the
80s when those of us doing uh biology or
uh medicine playing with computers were
were really Outsiders we were novel we
were Geeks we were very strange people
and then what happened is that the Human
Genome Project came along and that was
really in my mind at least uh a
milestone because not for merely for the
the fact of what It produced
scientifically but it actually
legitimized uh the informatics
Enterprise because at the time I was
working on a uh Colombia and we were
looking at the physical and genetic
mapping of chromosome 13 you could not
take that Grant on without having not
just a data sharing plan not sorry not
the data uh storing and manipulating the
data but you had to make that data
available you had to do a series of
things uh and of course the Analytics
associated with that data became uh
became important and in fact we actually
were able to improve the experimental
protocols by virtue of what we could
show analytically so that for the first
time forced us together and created a
Synergy between between those two those
two
groups um and then you know things went
not quite as planned I'd say what
happened at that point uh is that there
was a a sudden realization well maybe
this this this is the next big wave and
so half of the the few of us who were
doing B informatics uh actually went off
to Industry because industry was
offering great packages and so forth uh
with the belief that this was going to
be the next huge wave well five three to
five years later those people were all
looking for academic jobs again because
it hadn't actually realized re it hadn't
been realized it took much longer to
appre for that value to become a uh part
of the mainstream and then I think we
went into a mode where uh doing this
kind of science became almost was
considered a kind of service provision
it was necessary now but it was a
service provision to um to the the the
traditional way of doing biom
medicine and then I tell where we are
today is at a point where yes you can
get tenure and you can get all sorts of
rewards for being one of those
analytical people uh working with other
people's data so that it has been within
the system it's been legitimized and so
I think that's that's a good thing but I
think what I would I would argue is by
the end of the decade these guys are
going to be driving the ship because
it's going to be the fundamental part of
Discovery making and I think what we're
what we that was one of the reasons I
went there was to try to the NIH was to
try and help Foster that along so we're
still we're still at this point where
there's there's sort of a clh of
culture but uh I think there's I just
having talked to the leadership across
the NIH across all these institutes I
think there's a realized that when I I I
essentially just gave that exact Spiel
to the advisers to the directors when uh
not that long ago a couple months ago
and no one really pushed back on that um
so I I think there's like it or not
there's this belief that that's that's
sort of where where things are going and
I think it it's how it's how we make
that uh how we make that change and I
think from my point of view when I think
about how it's it's worked the best it's
come from a situation going back to the
original field of bioinformatics when
people started doing it there were a
group of biologists or biomedical folks
uh and there were a group of of
different types of people physicists
chemists mathematicians computer
scientists who started to come together
and there was quite a lot of tension in
the beginning uh and quite a lot of
misunderstanding but then what happened
is the NIH and others and the NSF
started to offer training programs where
they were training people at the
interface so they had to have dual
mentors and it was those students
ultimately that made the glue that
really start of course those students
now some of them of course are full
professors in institutions and going
forward so I think we you know so one of
the points is we need to start training
people for this new much better now for
this new world order if it if it's to
come uh and put those at the interface
between these traditional uh disciplines
so and I that's happening and I'm
encouraged by that I guess where partly
where I'm a little discouraged is when
in what we're doing with this big data
to knowledge initiative we needed to
have um a multic counil working group
because all of the different institutes
and centers NIH funded so and the
councils uh if you don't know are
essentially eminent scientists who
advise each of the institutes and
centers on on Direction and so forth and
very valuable bodies when I looked at
those from the point of view of who
would be good data scientists to to help
us with our initiative you know frankly
I came up short so uh but you know and
then there was a realization well that's
perhaps true we we are my Council I
really ought to have someone capable of
doing this so it's a it's a process but
I think we are moving in the right
direction
and then along those lines uh once
people buy the idea of data sharing
that's not the end that's the beginning
so uh our database we share routinely
with lots of different investigators but
it's not as though you can just go pull
the data go off analyze it write the
paper up and be done getting the data
elements is the beginning of a dialogue
uh what are these elements what about
the missing data how do I interpret this
what are the standards that have been
used as other people have used these
data elements there's a whole process of
back and forth if the science is going
to be excellent science yeah and I would
imagine that's true in genetics as well
although I'm sure Mark could comment on
that um so there's really a long-term
commitment that needs to be made on the
part of the investigator sharing the
data to the other investigators using
the data if the quality of the science
is going to be at the highest possible
level right now now there's no support
for that process or that time or that
energy so uh thoughts about how that
might
change okay so it's true and I think
it's it makes no sense to when these
resources one end of it uh clearly have
uh need to have a very long Lifetime and
yet they're funded in you know three
four five year cycles and that really
doesn't lead to sustainability of the
system it leads art course to the Google
Bus syndrome because if you know that if
you're doing a good job maintaining this
resource and you're communicating with
the communities and you're building this
Rapport and yet you know that in 3 to
four years you're going to be reviewed
and you're not clear it's going to be
funded if and an opportunity comes along
for another job well you know it's hard
to keep people in the system so you know
I think the the
longevity uh aspect has to be dealt with
but at the same time I think there there
are other models that need to be thought
about so what's really important is that
the people who do the data work are
often very passionate and very
knowledgeable about that data and we
have to be very careful that we don't
disrupt even the system that we have
that to to uh make sure that that level
of quality persists and even improves
based on you know it working with the
communities and of course that's the key
the community tells you if they tell you
it's crap then then you're going to do
something about it because you know it's
part of the cycle um but you know I
think at the same time so that needs to
be preserved but at the same time the
way we currently operate a number of
these resources I'm not convinced is
necessarily the right way anymore what I
mean by that is the idea that first of
all what we've done over many years now
is to create effectively stove pipes of
information Within These
resources and um um because they're
funded Often by different agencies in
different ways and so on and that was
quite effective at a time when you used
to go just to a small number of
resources to do your research but now in
this translational era we're going
across everything from you know genomic
proteomic met metabolomic all the way up
to to patient information and each time
we do that we're we're struggling with
every single one of these resources so I
think at some level um obviously
uh confidentiality not withstanding some
of that that data has to be sort of
bought and the idea of the commons is
essentially to bring that quality data
into a more open framework where in a
sense it could be more or less
crowdsource so you might still have the
resources you have but you're now
allowing more people easy access to the
data to take and build collections of
subsets of data that meet these sort of
translational needs so you know I think
just experimenting with this and seeing
whether in fact there is any uptake uh
will be an interesting experiment so one
of the things we're going to do with
this Commons idea is to seed that
Commons with a set of
uh series of research objects uh both
data and software and uh narrative
they're already essentially out there
but not necessarily very accessible to
give you an example from The Narrative
side um you know pubs we've had all this
movement in Open Access so we're talking
about data now but open knowledge
through Open Access publishing has been
around and been uh policies that were
put in place a number of years ago and
it's you know it's been somewhat
successful about 15 to 20% of all the
biomedical literature this year will
will be uh Open Access um from day one
um if it's funded by the NIH it has to
be open access
after um after a year anyway but so
that's all available but it's not to
actually do something
so that means you can read a paper much
more easily than you could otherwise it
doesn't necessarily impact institutions
like this which have a lot of access to
literature but if you're believe me if
you're in a developing world it's a huge
deal and there's some beautiful stories
of successes that have come from Open
Access but that's another story The
Point here is you know you have you you
you you that is which is currently in
Pub Med Central uh within the NIH is not
particularly accessible so the idea that
that was actually also was also
maintained in that way but was also
seeded into this Commons where it could
be you know it could be dealt it could
be analyzed by easily by a larger group
of people and combined with other forms
of data to make collections I've seen
you know and these are pressing issues
I've seen some very interesting
collections recently associated with e
bowler so the idea that you know you
know there was a whole series of these
research objects out there that
reflected narrative on paper around Eola
uh you know drug databases where
information associated with Eola could
be extracted where this could be started
to be put together this is you know
there's precedent for this but it's not
easy to do right now so the idea that
this could this kind of aggregation
could happen in an easier way uh is
definitely something we want to
explore and then finally my question it
at one point journals were talking about
requiring that a data set be posted
supporting the analysis that was being
presented in the paper and I'm curious
is the n NIH going to get involved with
that is there some way that that could
be a requirement at the time that the
paper is accepted for publication as a
way of jump starting this idea of
sharing at least uh deidentified
data yeah so the this is happening with
some journals uh already the public
library of science for example and I was
actually involved in this will not
actually publish a paper unless the
associated data sets are available and I
think one of the ideas is that those
particular data sets would have these
digital object identifiers assigned to
them in the same way that papers do and
they would be uh accessible and linked
uh through for example through the
commons but also to uh
activities uh at the NIH and that that
that's actually ongoing so you know but
I think there there needs to be much you
know that's that's one set of
Publications and others are following
but it it's not all of the biomedical
literature but there are drivers for
this and the reproducibility driver uh
is a big one um the idea that you know
that funding may be lost to the system
if we can't reproduce things better is
driving uh this you know this kind of
notion and the point that was made
earlier about uh software software is
another part of this uh is is an equal
part but there's there's more to it than
that there's even all of the physical
parts as well um so if as a bios
specimen database there ought to be if
if if if you're using specific elements
from that resource then that should be
you know well characterized in the paper
so at least there's a you can return you
can resolve the source of that content
whether it be virtual or physical and uh
so there's moves of foot for example for
assignment of identifiers to antibodies
and so forth so that there uh so that
there can be you know we begin to
characterize a paper in a much more
quantitative way than we've done in the
past so let's just open it up to
audience Q&A for five minutes and then
we can uh go up and have
lunch
great presentation thank you very much I
have a quick question uh one of the
things that is uh you know obviously
necessary and many people mention that
constantly is access to full text
articles to you know to do natural
language processing and analyze it etc
etc and one of the obstacles is uh the
fact that there is no API or you know or
programming interface to this types of
of data resources and another one is the
copyright itself so how an ah is
involved or trying to address this
because that's big impediment in finding
like a concrete example finding um you
know potential drug Target for um
genetic variation that nobody have ever
seen and uh for that you need you know
computers people cannot do that kind of
stuff I'm I'm I'm not the first part uh
I think the the idea I'm actually on the
PubMed Central Advisory Board and that's
where the idea of putting that content
into a much more accessible way but I
have to say that um even with the
literature there are problems so an
example of that is that the the
literature itself is represented as XML
but it's not necessarily as standardized
as it should be so that because and so
the licensing record which defines who
can do what to that that publication is
is in number of cases missing or just
uninterpretable so we're not absolutely
clear uh what what the issues are and
this is again history repeating itself
so as people start to use the data on
mass as a corpus uh they realize these
problems and you know they start to be
addressed so that kind of thing is now
being add addressed and it involves
getting the Publishers to to sort of
conform better but you know Publishers
it's very important that they be in Pub
and Pub Med Central that's where the
main access points are to their their
content so you know and then I think
this common idea one of the the the
thoughts there is that you know it's no
good waiting for a small group of people
at the NIH to build apis to this stuff
let's make it accessible and then
encourage the community to develop the
apis which of course will be
characterized so that you'll be able
what you can't do now is you can't how
do I find an AP ey to this stuff right
uh and I think the idea is through these
these Discovery indexes is not only you
be able to find the API but you'll get
some sense of its value because you'll
be able to see how of how frequently
it's been used and any commentary that
people want to say about it so this
starts to take on I don't want to
necessarily use this term but sort of
almost like a Yelp like uh you know
context um and so that was that's sort
of the you know the way that I see this
heading um and your second question was
about resources to do I'm sorry I didn't
quite get what you were trying to say in
the second
part that that was just a concrete
example of where this type of analysis
would be critical because it is
impossible to do you know to to keep in
memory uh you know all the types of
genetic variations that can occur you
have to do you know really good you know
natural language processing of uh the
body of literature to find out some
obscure things
okay so I think that would this I would
again this needs to be every part of
this has to be evaluated so I think if
we put if we put this out there maybe we
you know we we we we make some awards to
I'm probably not supposed to be saying
these things we make some awards to uh
actually develop apis to this content
and then I think equally important is we
have to evaluate what the usage pattern
is and then we need to make you know
adjustments accordingly you know this is
I I I don't want to give the impression
that any of the things that we're
approaching here are these big
monolithic you know build it and they
will come kind of approaches this is
really to do some Nimble experiments
over the next year or two uh and see
where we go with this if I could just
add something so one of one of the
things that concerns me about the
explosion of information is that we need
to pay careful attention to what is not
there to missing data uh patterns of
missing are very important we know in in
the uh research literature that there's
a real publication bias right for
positive findings especially for smaller
studies Etc and I know in my own work
with the electronic medical record
system studying where the patterns of
missings were really helped us
understand what the problems with the
data were that we were dealing with and
if you don't ask those questions in a
very systematic a very rigorous way you
can make very uh ill-founded conclusions
from the data in front of you and I
think when we then go up a whole another
level of sharing data across data
research sites we have to be really
really careful about thinking about
missing as creatively as we think about
the data in front of
us hi um so when I was teaching my data
journalism program this this summer we
had a guest from propublica come talk to
us about an interactive that they had
developed there in their small data team
where they sort of explained they let
people like search through the Medicare
d that had recently been open sourced
and then they sort of showed little
Graphics that explained you know for the
doctor you found maybe your doctor this
is their percentile rank in terms of how
many times they've done this procedure
or this is you know this is how many
procedures they do Etc and I remember
thinking like why is it up to a
newspaper to do that like why isn't that
being done by the federal agencies and
why don't they have teams of data
journalists who think about how the
taxpayers who fund this stuff would like
to interact with the research studies or
with the data itself or you know or just
the results or just even the funding for
the
research Consumer Report would agree
with I've only been there six months I
don't have good ANS I
mean there I don't have good answers to
it I mean it there's no good reason I
mean that's that's the bottom line I
mean but uh I
think the but there's there are steps
along the way I mean I think the direct
the directive that that came down from
you know essentially the president about
open data that is really driving things
in in a different direction and it's you
know the fact that people are now
thinking for the first time well there's
all this open data you know we can be
doing you know we're doing these kinds
of things and you know I think it's it's
almost like you know the internet in a
sense what we've done what we we're it's
a we're creating a thin layer on top of
the internet and before we had that we
had no idea where it was going to go but
it went to amazing places and lots so I
think just by opening things up in that
case it was creating a protocol uh you
know to allow communication I mean we
need that here as well it's not just
about making the data open we've got to
have you know the idea that you can of
course you know there's commonality
across these data elements that you can
actually make these kinds of connections
and that's going to start the value of
that is going to start to come
ultimately you know in my mind all of
this only gets driven by economics the
the the you know the the value
proposition has to be there and so it
you know it may not be a value
proposition for the uh for the uh for
the feds to do it themselves but it
should be it should be done through some
kind of public private partnership so
that there's there's value all around so
that you could get that kind of
information but that whoever did that
let's say it was a third party that they
actually that whatever Revenue they
generated in so doing uh actually got
fed back to support some of the the the
public data itself so this is the kind
these kinds of mod you know and then you
say well would I pay for this service
and maybe you wouldn't but you know
there you know there are lots of
creative companies out there who offer
tons of free services but make lots of
money
they're bringing it I'm sorry let me
just can I just respond to that it
brought about the other thing I wanted
to say which is I'm going to push back a
little bit on this concept of a business
model in the context because I've worked
in business I've worked in Industry um
when we're talking about like NIH we're
talking about something that is funded
by the taxpayer with lots and lots of
money and what I just mentioned is like
a data science team which would take
maybe $100,000 to do um maybe $200,000
to maintain like for a longer period of
time it's not going to pay off because
it's going to be free it's not going to
pay off directly but and it's very hard
to to gauge what it means to be
worthwhile in that context if it's a
free open source you know if it's open
to the public but on the other hand the
public will probably appreciate it at
least the ones that interact with it I'm
just I'm just making the point that when
we talk about business models it it
sends off red flags that you want to be
able to
measure like the worth the worth of
something which isn't always easy to do
when you're talking about public
interest this is a public interest
agency so to some extent we have to
assume that that things that open it up
to people are in their best interest we
can ask them if they think so but you're
not going to be able to get revenue from
that kind of thing and I I don't think
you should that's just my opinion but I
take your point and it was the best
answer I could come up with but as I
said before I started saying that I
don't have necessarily have good answers
for this I mean I I I've become way more
sympathetic than I was in the past to
that this would only cost a couple
hundred thousand dollars to do this well
the problem is of course there are many
different of those kinds of of
opportunities and it's actually you know
and it is a lot of money that the you
but it is still nevertheless limited you
know has a limit and so maybe we just
need to prioritize things more but I can
tell you talking to investigators who
you know when that priority doesn't
agree with what you know the fact that
they're no longer being funded
it's really tough and you know but I
think keeping the Public's interest at
the Forefront of all this clearly is
obviously you know
critical so um Phil sort of following on
from this uh question you talked about
the fact that um you know good data is
very expensive it's expensive to
generate expensive to maintain and I was
curious do you have now or will the NIH
be developing literally a like a
distribution of data costs or values
that one could look at like you have a
sense now of like what's what's
expensive you know in terms of dollars
per gigabyte or you know what's an
expensive data set what's an inexpensive
data are there actual numbers that you
can quote or that we could find a
website um no I mean I don't really have
and I have to say a lot of this comes
from my experience with data and various
resources over the years and what I
observe uh in the in in these other
resources but what I would say is that
what we're not doing enough of by the
virtue of the way we fund these things
and I kind of alluded to this but just
to restate it perhaps hopefully a little
better is we're not transferring best
practices enough we're not you know
we're not we're not working enough
together to to understand what really
works well and tools that are really
useful for curating this data set
methodologies we've used to curate this
data set you know those those even
though it might be different data that
often you know the process can often
transfer and that of that you know
doesn't happen and I mean I'm not
talking just about uh what happens in in
different areas of genomics I'm talking
about what could happen what I've
learned recently is that Noah uh is
doing some very interesting things with
atmospheric and ocean data uh and they
have models for public private
partnership and they have models for
curation and they have models for the
that I would you know as a researcher I
never discovered so I think if if we can
start to you know we're now all meeting
because of these open data things maybe
there's hope I mean I'm hope you know I
have hope that you know you I say I'm
not a fed I'm just not worned down by
trying to do but there is there is all
this cross talk going on and maybe some
value can come from it but I don't have
specific examples I do know I mean I can
tell you as as you know just one data
resource right now something like the
protein Data Bank just in the US that's
a 6 million a year Enterprise and
probably $3 million of that is spent uh
more than that actually $4 to5 million
is spent on the curation activities for
that data and we could we could talk a
little about that offline but I think uh
that clearly has had enormous impact and
value on that Community but I think
going forward we we ought to be thinking
about you know uh other models as
well question there's a question
here
thank you Phil can you say a little bit
more I know we don't have a lot of time
but a little bit about the expectations
that the ni has for the institutions
that are supporting these researchers
what would you like them to be able to
offer what do you think they need to
offer um terms of infrastructure
policies and guidance so forth I think
what I'm most interested in is what we
do with the people so it's really
because that's the the lifeblood and
that that comes from the institution but
so these you know various training
initiatives um and what we can do to
really Foster this this training and
also I would say coming back to my point
about valuing uh people within within
the organization you know the the
so-called data scientists and project
scientists who are very important to the
Enterprise and and I think becoming more
so you know are we appreciating those
enough in the system is there enough
soul searching uh within
institutions uh that these people are
being well taken care of so I'd say and
that you know and and the training and
and certainly the diversity of training
which is a a big thing for the NIH so I
would say those are just sort of
recapping or of things that I'd really
like to see uh institutions happen and I
and I think also one of the reasons I'm
here of course is to have much more of a
dialogue with individual institutions
that are pushing in this direction um
you know I mean I I just know from where
I came before I was there that there was
in the Southern California region there
was uh a huge demand for people doing
this kind of work there were 4 and a
half thousand open jobs and yet at that
time UC San Diego was not actually
training we had no data science program
per se and uh there was sudden
realization that you know this this had
to happen in part because we didn't get
some uh important data science grants
which had to show that there was a data
science component already in place that
was a wakeup call for our institution
and now I think there's you know this
notion of uh of really thinking about
this and actually even thinking about it
in the context of this digital
Enterprise idea where you start to break
down the silos between these respective
uh parts I mean there's just no question
that there are discoveries that are made
of of connections between investigators
of course when they read each other's
papers but there's a possibility that th
those connections could have been
discovered if some tools had actually
looked at their data they don't actually
have to reveal the data but if you if
there's a tool that looks at P for
patenting data and finds two data sets
from two investigators in two different
departments who would never come into
contact and yet there's some commonality
there I mean you have to be careful of a
fatigue alert and all these sorts of
things but there's at least the
potential that you would actually
discover the commonality and those two
people could be put in contact with each
other um without revealing the data and
they can make of it what they can and
that would happen essentially the day
that the second data set was actually
created and essentially in this Commons
or in this public space um even if it
was institutional Commons so you know I
think it's a way for institutions to
create much more collab there are the
opportunities are beginning to be seen
for creating opportunities for
collaboration within institutions that
don't which are not you know not the
traditional ways of doing things and
having them happen much more quickly
than waiting for uh the published
literature thank you very much Amy and
Phil so we will um have a poster session
now the Y Institute for Network science
is on the third floor of this building
they've allowed us to use their space
we'll all go up there get our lunch look
at the posters if you're tuning in
online we'll be back at 1:30 but there
is a link on the YouTube video to where
all the posters are uploaded to our Eli
scholar site so please visit that and
poster session with us as well and we'll
see you back down here a little before
1:30
[Applause]
thanks
all right when you get up here I can
come up here and change it over for were
you're familiar with
computers I'm I'm not saying that if I
struggle oh yeah I'll see I'll be right
there you're welcome so to answer your
question yeah it's
up
this is
this is the baby right here okay okay
I'm not gonna mess up anything with with
yours okay no just take it just drag it
right on
the you in the right one yeah
okay just minimize
that okay
great and are you using PowerPoint using
um I think this is Adobe okay they have
a Doby okay great so now I'll just
eject get back
to all right hopefully they didn't you
off no not at
all just look at my slides real quick
and yeah and you are I'm the first one
Mar oh
you're do this uh yep let me just take a
look here how you do your
than
just grab
micone
sign I can just I'm us myone don't you
do
that
just
uh good afternoon welcome to the
afternoon session of uh the 2014 day of
data uh our panelists this afternoon are
uh Professor Mark gin uh he is the
Albert Williams professor of biomedical
informatics at Yale he's co-director of
the Yale computational biology and
bioinformatics program his research is
focused on bioinformatics and he's
interested in large- scale integrative
surveys biological database design
macrou CER geometry molecular simulation
Human Genome annotation gene expression
analysis and data mining that that is a
sentence um uh uh uh uh the next speaker
will be uh Professor Pinelli Hull she's
uh an assistant professor in the
department of geology and geophysics at
Yale her uh her research focuses on
understanding open ocean ecosystems
through the cazic disentangling the
causes and consequences of mass
extinctions and quantifying Community
response to Global change and the third
speaker speaker will be angel angel suu
uh she graduated from the Yale School of
Forestry and Environmental Studies in
2013 and she is now an associate
research scientist and lecturer at FES
as well as the Director of the
environmental performance measurement
program area her research focuses on
Chinese environmental performance
measurement governance governance and
policy professor
interesting
okay so first of all I want to thank the
uh organizers for inviting me to the uh
day of data which I've enjoyed immensely
so so far and I just want to say I
really appreciate the introduction but
one word was missed out of the
introduction it's my new word I now
think of myself as a data scientist and
so I'm focused on data science and that
is that encompasses now my my research
so that's what I'm going to be talking
you uh talking to you about today
biological data science and in
particular how we can use that to make a
map of the human genome and use that as
a tool against cancer so first of all I
want to put uh big data in uh biology in
the context of big data in general in
science I mean you've probably all heard
throughout today that big data is
transforming science many different
types of Sciences um it's obviously
transforming biological sciences and the
big thing in biological science which is
a little different than in other
disciplines it's really been transformed
by by a par one particular technology
and that is really diagrammed in this um
slide here that is the amazing Advent of
Next Generation sequencing the ability
to generate just gargantuen amounts of
data uh quickly and so this
graph shows um the decrease in cost of
uh genome sequencing since the uh Human
Genome Project finished around 2000 and
it's on a log graph so of course you can
see it's kind of exponentially um going
down in price and it's paralleling U
Moore's law for uh the increase in speed
and memory of computers but around 2007
um due to some uh tremendous advances
some of them here in New Haven by uh
4554 uh biosystems Next Generation
sequencing really took off and you can
see this the it's that's an incredible
you know decrease in cost which is now
leveling off but that really has led to
this tremendous amount of uh new data
and that's really changed the Dynamics
of um the the economic dynamics of um
genomics where it used to be initially
that most of the money in genomics went
into sequencing because that was the
center of genome sequencing now more and
more what you're really seeing is money
devoted to analysis of genome sequencing
and also procuring interesting samples
it's not just a generic Human Genome
it's a very particular uh Genome of say
disease patient and so
forth so the this large amount of
sequencing has given rise to these huge
databases that have um terabytes and
pedabytes of information in them and I
thought I'd give you a sense of the um
the sort of database World in genomics
at the moment this uh picture is from uh
Heidi Sophia at the nhgri and she's made
this kind of um astronomical view of our
our databases now um but I I think it's
interesting to see this is a little bit
old so I think these numbers have went
up uh considerably since then but
basically the public databases you can
see there sort of terabyte scale uh
databases the biggest one is about a
petabyte uh scale that people uh
download and what is in those uh
pedabytes the biggest one is the cancer
um genomics database called tcga and if
you look at that you can see it this is
a little text a little hard to see here
but basically it's split into many
different cancers say this uh line
represents breast cancer which is one of
the most intensively studied cancers and
then if you split that up you can see
that it divides into different
experiments that people have done such
as genome sequencing RNA sequencing and
so forth and these experiments have
different profiles in terms of the
amount of data they generate and so
forth and I'm going to be coming back
later to this cancer genome data but
what do people do with big data so what
is the goal of amassing these massive uh
data sets well fundamentally I think the
goal is to answer questions and really
also to make models and use those models
to make predictions about the real world
and in in kind of doing that I kind of
divide the approach up into two ways one
is where people just want the answers to
the question and they don't care so much
about the explicit uh structure of the
data they don't care about how the data
is set up they just answer their
question and I think of this as kind of
like Google search you know you don't
really know how the internet law
structure you put in your query into the
box and you get your answer that's what
you care about another one is where
people intensely care about the explicit
description of the data and what does it
look like and of course I think the
Paradigm here is also Google but it's
Google Maps as opposed to Google search
where you really want to understand this
is what the earth looks like and that
structure means something to you so how
do we think of uh genomics and
scientific uh Computing in these in
these um in terms of this dichotomy well
let me start off with um uh contrast so
last year we heard about this amazing um
discovery of the higs uh bozon and I
think and maybe some physicists here
will disagree but I think this
represents a kind of um example of the
first type of thing where they had just
pedabytes gargant amounts of data but at
the end they were searching for this
tremendous needle in this Hy stack you
know to find a few events that really
support this this particle this God
particle and U and you know so so and
they were happy with those those events
in that context and the contrast we
heard about earlier today is really I
think the astronomer View and so we
heard earlier about this SL digital Sky
survey earlier today but I think this is
an inspiration to a lot of people in
large scale data science I mean this is
kind of you know the universe the seeing
it all in one hole and that's a
tremendous inspiration it has been uh
for me uh and so what I think we want to
do in genomics is actually very similar
to that SLO digital Sky survey and
drawing inspiration for that the only
problem of of course is that we don't
have as an intuitive model as the
celestial sphere or the Earth so we have
to make a model to make a map of and so
the end code project that I'm going to
talk about has been trying to make a map
of the human genome and what we want to
do with this map is layer on all this
different type of data but the problem
of course is the map is a little bit
less
intuitive and so I'm going to be talking
about that map today and I should also
want to say a little bit about the end
code project because I think this
relates to how big data is done big data
is gener ated by big crowds crowds of
people and crowds are also known as
consortia um and they're organized to
some degree and so the human genome is
analy is annotated by this big consorti
called encode and that really um kind of
was created after the sequencing of the
human genome around the around 20012
2002 and it's went through a number of
very um organized um Pilots first
looking at 1% of the genome then looking
at model organisms eventually to whole
roll outs on the entire human genome
giving some sense of The
annotation so what does The annotation
of the genome look like or how do people
think about it well I think a big thing
in the encode group is to try to present
all this information in an organized way
and so we I think a a good model for the
organization is a hierarchy okay so the
idea is you don't want to go straight to
all the data you want to kind of
approach it in a structured way and so
you can imagine at the bottom there's
the data and the data actually if you
start with the image it would be gargant
amounts of but if you just start with
the reads you you're talking obviously
many terabytes of reads those reads of
course turn into so signals or sort of
um noisy signals on the genome and then
they're processed into progressively
more simplified representations that
I'll show you sort Peaks networks models
and eventually people write papers on
them but even in writing the papers
people want to do this in a kind of
organized fashion so the Public
Presentation of the papers is there's
many papers they're arranged around a
central Cal paper that's kind of meant
to be looked at first and then there's
maybe 20 or 30 papers around around that
that are kind of reference that Central
Paper in a reference B and they in turn
describe the methods for particular data
sets and so the thought process is you
can Traverse this huge data Trove in an
organized fashion and that's really the
goal of the Consortium so what I've this
is the outline for I was going to talk
to you about today and I might not have
time to go through all bits of it but I
at the beginning I wanted to just tell
you about big data and genomics this map
making and now I wanted to do a little
bit of dive and kind of show you what
we're doing what does the data look like
what are we really trying to do to show
you a view of our sort of linear
annotation how we annotate The genome
and maybe this higher level Network
annotation and then I want to give you a
sense of how we can apply this in a
practical way you know in medical
context for say um prioritizing cancer
mutations so first of all the linear
annotation so how do we think about the
linear annotation of the genome well I
think of it very much like the way
people would annotate books in libraries
and you know how that that's where the
word comes from right so here's a bit of
text that I've taken it's actually from
American scientists and I've tried to
annotate it and for me annotating it
often is get a highlighter out of a
different color and you highlight it and
then you put a little marginal note that
says what is that the significance of
that piece of text that you've
highlighted you've functionally
highlighted that piece of
text another thing that people do when
they annotate text is they take a number
of texts and they compare them they say
this text is like another text or they
say within this text there's a
particular phrase or light Motif that's
repeated over and over again and that
forms a type of um annotation so let's
take those ideas and now think about the
genome and we can sort of think about
the same way so first of all let's talk
about that comparison of text that comes
about in terms of thinking about
conservation in the genome we can take
the human genome compare it to itself
compare it to other people in the
population or can compare it amongst
human and other model organisms looking
for conservation at different
levels then let's think about the
highlighter we can highlight the genome
the way we do this is by doing a
functional genomics experiment that
gives a very noisy readout of what the
genome's doing is it being read out is
it being bound to is it being wrapped up
what's happening and then of course the
computer people process this signal and
turn it into these little highlighter
blocks that's the kind of mindset very
similar to what we do with text and now
I'm going to take a little bit of a dive
and show you what this actually looks
like for finding regulatory sites in the
genome so here's a signal this is a very
noisy signal this signal has a variety
things we use to process it we have to
compare it versus in uh control we have
to deal with the mapability and so forth
and we find little regions that we call
regulatory sites these are bound to by
transcription factors and are kind of
the wiring of our our
genome now one key aspect of all this
wiring in the genome is most of the
wiring sits outside of genes okay and so
people refer to this as being in the
dark matter of the genome and this of
course is a very astronomical analogy
also and I thought it kind of fun and I
hope there's some astronomers here to
correct me to kind of compare this to
real dark matter so supposedly this is a
picture of dark matter and supposedly
the way I understand it is you cannot
see dark matter but what you see is you
see its effect on the light of from
coming from stars and the way it lenses
the light of stars and this is very
similar to the way we want to think
about the regulatory bits of the genome
you look at their effect on the genes
the genes are like the stars they're
regulated and lensed by the regulatory
regions in the genome so that's what
we're looking at now the next thing
we're going to do is look at the kind of
conservation of the regulatory sites
that second type of annotation so in
general people this is a bit of a
technical graph and I'm not going to
describe in detail but basically people
have found that they have they're very
weakly conserved and mostly the genes
are very strongly conserved but if we
break all the regulatory sites up into
more specific sites we start to see some
of them are conserved to a degree and if
we actually look in detail at the
mutations that hit them we can see
um they particularly disrupt The Binding
sites of things in certain ways and so
the long insure of this is that we can
find groups of regulatory sites that are
both functional as being bound to but
they're also conserved so we start with
a list of 677 categories we develop
smaller lists of groups of sites that
are conserved and they're actually as
conserved as genes and we see lots and
because of that we see lots of the known
delarius mutations are in them okay and
so this allows us to regions of the
genome that are very sensitive to
mutations so we're going to come back to
this so that's sort of the linear
annotation so now let's move from the
linear annotation to a higher level
annotation so the linear annotation is
very nice but it's a very unstructured
type of annotation it's very much like
the parts list and you know if you're a
true molecular biologist with a capital
M you want to look at molecules also
with a capital M you want to look at how
molecules work how they move move what
happens in three-dimensional and
four-dimensional space and time that is
unfortunately too ambitious for the
current world we are in the genome we
can't do that for every molecule in the
genome so what happens is this network
representation which is kind of like a
2d sketch in between the 1D parts list
and the 3D molecular picture is a kind
of nice way of thinking about things
functioning so this network
representation Prett powerful and we
find in molecular biology that we can in
put a lot of ideas that we have about
molecules such as their transcriptional
regulation their physical protein
protein interactions in this same
representation and one thing that's also
very powerful about networks is there's
a whole new world that's I'd say part of
data science now springing up called
Network science where people study
networks and we have a new Institute
here at Yale the Yale Network Institute
and the neat thing is you can also draw
these Network pictures for lots of other
disciplines so in particular one of the
favorite ones is to draw pictures of
social networks and the nice thing about
these other other disciplines is people
have much better intuition for them than
they do about the kind of bizarre
molecules of the genomes kind of tables
and chairs for this world if that makes
sense so here's a social network that
I've drawn I've taken from the New York
Times it's called the blame game and it
shows the the arrows represent blame at
a particular event that happen and
notice how one person's even blaming
himself and the the key thing about this
picture though that's amazing this is
our social intuition if you just look at
the arrows you immediately get a sense
of who's in charge who's the master
regulator right and so what we want to
do is we want to take those intuitions
of how we can look at those those arrows
and replace the the Talking Heads here
by genes and then we can understand the
gene regulatory Network so practically
what do we do to make up a gene
regulatory Network I'm not going to go
into the details a little bit of a dive
here what we do is we find these sites
in the genome okay and then the simple
thing we do is the sites that are right
Upstream of genes we basically say they
control the genes and if we do that we
end up with a network that connects a
transcription factor to a Target Gene
through a binding site that has about
half a million edges in it it's a big
hairball and for a lot of people who
don't like networks it represents a very
messy hair ball and so to simplify it
we've developed ways of cutting this
hair ball down to about 25,000 edges
okay that we can analyze now the distl
sites that are far away from genes we
have to do other things for that I'm not
going to talk about now so now if we
take this hair ball that connects the
the 25,000 edges and we also relate it
to all of the um other networks that
contain genes we have we get this sort
of human Network that's a 100,000 edges
now you look at this this is a criticism
people have of a lot of big data science
they look at that and they say that
doesn't mean anything to me it just
looks like a huge hairball and that is
true however one of the neat things
about mining that data is if you look at
it in detail you can actually find some
really interesting things you can find
that the genes that are more Central in
the human genome they tend to sit more
at hubs and because of the way this
network is drawn you can almost see it
as more in the center of this network
whereas the less important genes sit
more at the periphery and so we're going
to come back to this idea of the hubs
being more essential okay so now we've
talked about big data in genomics the
making the maps just how we develop a
kind of simple annotation a linear
annotation developing a more elaborate
synthetic second levelor or annotation
and so now I want to talk about what do
we do with this how can we use it and
how do we think about how it works with
big data okay so the problem we're going
to approach is how do we prioritize
mutations in cancer this is a big
problem let me explain the problem H if
you can trct cancer and unfortunately
many people in this room probably will
what will happen when they sequence your
tumor genome well they'll find thousands
of mutations uh cancer is a the disease
of the genome so on order they'll find
maybe 5,000 mutations okay and now 5,000
is is a small number it's much less than
the normal number of variants in a
person but it's a lot you know what are
we going to do with 5,000 how are we
going to Target drugs that how are we
going to do experiments that so what we
want to do is we want to reduce that
5,000 down to a few key mutations that
are going to give rise to the drugs that
doctors are going to prescribe and the
things that people are going to focus
research on so it's called prioritizing
those 5,000 mutations so we're going to
talk about how we can use our map now to
search through those mutations and
prioritize them so we're going to start
with all that big data from cancer and
we're going to look in particular at the
Cancer genome sequencing here I just
show a selection of whole genome
sequences of prostate and breast cancer
it's about 100 in total now most of
these mutations in these um in these
cancers 99% of them occur outside of
genes and so there's been there's always
a myoptic focus in genetics on genes
because that's what we understand most
but when you look in a unbiased way at
the mutations that occur in a disease
most of them occur outside of genes so
99% of these mutations occur outside of
the genes and so we want to understand
which of those mutations are driving the
cancer which are important so what just
we're going to do is we put together a
very simple scheme that we're going to
use to prioritize based on our
annotations so we're going to take our
mutations and basically we're going to
say do they go into any of the are do
they head any those sensitive regions in
the genome that are both functional and
conserved okay then we're going to give
them say a point and then we're going to
ask are they particularly disruptive do
they mess up the say The Binding site
and then we're going to ask do they hit
one of those Network hubs you know if
they hit a hub maybe they're more
delarius okay so we're looking for
mutations that are very different from
the normal pattern of variation and then
we upwa it and prioritize that so what
happens when we actually do that on a
real cancer genome so this is a a one
prostate cancer genome sequenced in
about probably 2 or at least described
initially in
2011 and it contained about 2,000 um um
mutations in it too many to look at but
we can ask you know how many are in a
sensitive region how many are in a hub
and so forth and the key thing is at the
end we get down to one one mutation and
this one mutation people can do
follow-up experiments on they can drill
into detail what's going on in this
mutation and it turns out you can
actually see to some degree it drives
the
cancer so then next thing we did is we
tried to go from an idea into a
practical piece of code C that people
can use which is of course much more
difficult than actually having an idea
so we tried to develop an actual web
server that people could upload variants
too and they could use to prioritize
their mutations and we call this web
server fun seek and let me tell you a
little bit about the structure of the
web server because I think it gives you
a little bit of a sense of how you think
about the data so we have this huge data
context okay that we're going to talk
about and then we have our variants
which are much smaller variant only a
few thousand variants you can upload
them to a web server you can email them
around there's privacy concerns some
times but just in general they're not
very large data we have this huge data
context and so we imagine we put them
together and then we get a
prioritization that's the kind of high
level of what happens then we think
about this data context what we do in
the data context is we put a lot of
effort to taking all these very big data
set such as the Thousand genomes
polymorphisms the the end code
annotations and building kind of a
simplified data context that is big but
is maybe not the terabyte scale it's
maybe only a few tens of gigabytes okay
it's something people can download it's
something that you can manipulate so
there's I think there's a big issue in
dealing with large data is kind of
processing into small or manageable
things is very much like the way when
you take a picture in your camera now
you can't actually deal with the raw
image you deal with the processed lossy
jpeg that's what you actually deal with
and likewise we want to deal with kind
of simplifications of these large data
sets and then of course the within the
variant priorization we have all these
different features and we have this idea
of recurrence I'm not going to go into
these in any um detail just to say that
we use the the hubs and we use the
sensitive regions and other these sort
of site breaking things and so forth and
we wait them in V this a sort of entropy
based uh waiting scheme that we use for
the data I'm just going to zip through
because I think I'm a little going a
little bit over so let me just summarize
um what I've told you about today so
what I've told you about is a case study
in biological data science and basically
how we make a map of the genome and how
we use it as a tool
and so first I wanted to introduce you
to this map making idea uh for how to
think about big data which is really
contrasting to the kind of search idea
um then I wanted to talk to you about
practically how do we make the map you
know one is the very simplified you know
the Continental outlines and so forth
and then another is a more synthetic uh
view with a sort of networking type of
thing and so for the sort of linear
annotation we talked about finding
regulatory sites conserved regulatory
sites and for the network thing we
talked about how we build that Network
and then also how we find that the hubs
and the network are more constrained and
then how we take these two facts two
very simple facts and use them to build
a conceptual workflow to prioritize
mutations and cancer and then how we
build a software tool based on that and
how in building the software tool we
have to again think about separating the
very large data context from kind of the
sort of medium data context smaller
files that you can move around on the
web and you can process with and you
know of course I know that most of this
is targeted to um a biological audience
but I think genomics has been a big data
discipline for a while and I think a big
part of data science is learning from
other um other big data disciplines and
so I I draw inspiration from Pandora
which described its its um website as
the music Genome Project so they've
obviously learned from genomics and and
you know we I think through a lot of
discussions such as at today's Forum we
can have a lot of back and forth with um
different disciplines to learn things
and so finally I want to acknowledge a
lot of the people involved and as I've
described to you before this is a crowd
this is crowd science okay a lot of
people involved in this and so it's hard
to acknowledge people properly and give
them credit right if there's so many
people so I'm going to try to do that
really quick now so the enco Consortium
yeah maybe 500 to a thousand people it's
broken into a group and the group that I
talked about their work is called the
networks elements group it's about 50
people these are the people here and the
the group it's nice it's really split
between the people who generate these
very large data sets such as Rick Meyers
and um Mike Rick Myers at Hudson alfin
Mike Snyder um at Stanford and the
analysts um some of the lot of people
here for instance I'd like to um
acknowledge Joel rosowski who's an
associate research scientist with me
chiao Chang who used to be um a post
Alchemy now has a faculty position at
Dartmouth uh Kyan who's another um
associate uh research scientist with me
who really led a lot of this um
analysis um the cancer prior is even
more complicated this is a collision of
Consortium so no it is fascinating
socially so we have the Thousand genomes
Consortium which this is forly part of
which is also known as a thousand
authors Consortium because we have more
authors than we have genomes there's a
subgroup of this 50 people that's called
the functional interpretation group
that's what this group did these are all
the green people here and um they
include myself and also ecta corana who
is a sociate research scientist for me
now she's moved on to a faculty position
at
Cornell and this group collided with
another Consortium really the tcga or
the cancer group um and this a
particular small group here you see kind
of merge with them okay and this was led
by Mark Rubin at Wild Cornell in New
York um who helped with the a lot of the
cancer uh genomics and also key in this
endeavor was um Yao uh Fu who is a CBB
uh graduate student here in the um at
yel who really developed a lot of the uh
software um that I described uh for this
cancer priorization and with that I'll
thank you for your
[Applause]
attention not save it don't save it
okay all right well I'm going to follow
with a talk that I hopefully ties in
quite well um off of the previous
speaker because I'm going to be talking
about measuring the shape of life rather
than measuring the genomes that underpin
it and because of the broad audience
here today the goal of my talk really is
to give you an idea of the different
opportunities challenges and data that
are involved um in measuring the shape
of life and to talk about what I've done
to with my broader group to leverage the
resources that are available here at
Yale and one of my big hopes is that in
talking to you all we can talk about
ways that the data infrastructure and
scientific Computing that has been
developed in other fields can be used uh
in the shape of life as
well so before I get to the
opportunities and challenges of the
science I want to start with a story to
emphasize the point that shape matters
so this summer I was lucky enough to be
in Africa following um a researcher guy
Western who studies Lions out into the
field one morning and we happened across
these two darling little Wilder beasts
wandering across the Savannah and a few
seconds
later the five or six lions that were
creeping along the edges attacked the
wilderbeast and killed it now you can
imagine that had that wilderbeast had
slightly longer legs or had he jumped a
little bit harder or perhaps you know
had he been a little bit more attentive
because he really did not seem to be
paying much attention he might have
gotten out of the way of those lions
and so all of those aspects I just
described are things that can be called
a phenotype so the different
characteristics the express
characteristics that define an organism
and shape is a phenotype certain people
have longer legs can run a bit faster
than I can for instance um certain
people are better at climbing there's a
lot of different aspects in our
morphology that affects how we interact
with the environment so shape matters
and it doesn't just matter when it comes
to things like predation it also matters
in in uh interactions that can be
mutually beneficial to both parties
involved like here you see this darling
little bird also in Africa about to feed
on a flower and the flower is shaped in
such a way that when the bird feeds it
it also gets pollen on its forehead and
Carries pollen off to pollinate other
flowers and even though we can imagine
shape mattering more in things like
lions and Wilder beasts and birds and
flowers it also matters to organisms
that are a little bit stranger to us so
these are our Strange organisms on land
but in my research I studied the strange
organisms in the sea and Imagining the
causes and the importance of phenotype
in the sea or shape is a little bit more
difficult because they live in a
three-dimensional environment they can
be seen from all directions they're
floating it's a vast realm so
understanding exactly what their
phenotype does is a little bit of a
bigger problem but the most important
thing to take away is that even though
shape matters for how organisms interact
with their environment we typically
measure genotypes much better than we
measure shape and this isn't to say that
we shouldn't be measuring genotypes
because understanding the genomes or the
genes that underly these different
Express characters is critically
important for understanding Evolution um
in both the past um and uh short-term
variations in populations today but if
we're going to understand the link
between genotype and phenotype we have
to measure the phenotype or shape as
well and this came in very personal to
me because I actually studied both
genotypes and phenotypes in these fish
here and the amazing thing was with Next
Generation sequencing we were able to
sequence the genomes of uh across these
fish within the order of like a week a
few weeks but when I went to measure the
phenotype to measure its shape I sat
there for two months painstakingly
putting little dots all over this fish
and in its in its jaws to actually
describe what the phenotype was doing so
we are measuring the genotype much
better than we measure the phenotype and
we need to get on par with when it comes
to measuring
shape because in the end phenotype or
shape is the variation that natural
selection acts
on and here this is my favorite group of
organisms I hope you guys oh it's not
showing up so well these are planktonic
foraminifera these are single celled
organisms that have um that form a fos
uh that form a shell as they grow and
they're found throughout the world's
oceans so even though you've probably
never seen them before there's Millions
millions and billions of them in the
ocean um and when it comes to measuring
phenotypes it's recognized that
phenomics is really the next Grand
Challenge people are measuring different
expressions of of the um of organisms
not just their shape but also their
metabolisms um or other aspects of their
behavior but we're not measuring it on
the same
scale so really the goal of the talk
today is to talk through what the
opportunity is when it comes to
measuring
shape what the data is that we need to
be collecting and what the challenges
are and really we've been working quite
hard at this in my group for the last
year so I'm going to give our work as a
case
study so what's the opportunity when it
comes to measuring shape well the
amazing thing is we actually have the
material the tools and the methods to be
measuring phenotypes to be measuring
shape at the same scale that we're
measuring
genotypes to start with organisms are
everywhere it's what makes walking
around so interesting and when it comes
to thinking about the fossil record
which is where my research lies there
are actually huge numbers of fossils
ever since Darwin complained about the
notorious gaps in the fossil record I
think a lot of people wrote it off but
if you go out into the open ocean today
and you look at the bottom of the ocean
in many parts of the ocean there are
literally football fields deep sediments
that are made entirely of fossils those
fossils are entirely microscopic so
you're talking about billions to
trillions of fossils sitting there
waiting to tell you about things like
variation and evolution in the fossil
record so we just need to measure them
and the amazing thing is we use these
very same fossils in my case my darling
for manifa to do things like reconstruct
the evolution of past climates so we
heard a little bit about the
difficulties and the importance of
understanding climate Dynamics in the
past earlier today um but the amazing
thing is the climate system interacts
with Biology because biology is the
carbon store for the climate system and
off uh in many times and it's one of the
big uncertainties when it comes to
understanding climate Dynamics today and
in the past what is the response of
biota and how does that interact with
the climate system but even though we
can draw this here is actually a curve
of um oxygen Isotopes which can be
interpreted in terms of temperature that
go from back when the dinosaurs ruled
the day up to the present day so you can
see the long term changes in the climate
system and the reason why the the dots
are all scattered is because we have so
much data you actually can't see at this
scale the fine scale resolution so we
have this for temperature we have this
for carbon but we don't have this when
it comes to the biota themselves so we
can't tell you even though the fossils
are there we can't tell you how rapidly
these different species are evolving to
these changes so the opportunity is
really there um we just need to measure
it and when it comes to uh what can we
measure in the fossil record at least in
the open ocean you actually have
Representatives of many different parts
of the whole ecosystem so you're not
just looking at one group of organisms
you can look at many groups of organisms
at
once but to do this you're going to have
to use more tools than we traditionally
use so in the past when it comes to
looking at variation in the fossil
record we do it the way I described with
the fish you take out 10 20 fossils out
of a jar oh I forgot to tell you these
jars of fossils so each one of these
data points comes from a jar like this
and a single jar can have something like
two to 10 million fossils in it that's a
lot of fossils but instead of actually
measuring them we tend to just take out
10 to maybe a few hundred and give them
a name and maybe measure one or two
aspects of its shape but instead what
we're doing in my group here is trying
to use multiple different methods to
measure shape and tie across them with
informatics so um I've talked a little
bit about the the traditional way of
just um of quantifying shape by putting
little points on an object but you can
also quantify shape by taking really
resolved um threedimensional measures
and that's um through micro anut
scanning um and that's that approach and
that's actually been used uh to great
effect for a lot of um Recent research
on the evolution of morphology but it's
difficult to quantify variation because
this is so expensive and so slow that
you can get a very good understanding of
a few individuals but you can't study
the millions or the thousands of
individuals that will tell you about the
variation within a population the
variation that underlies Evolution
itself so what we're doing in my lab is
focusing on rapid High throughput
approaches um semi-3d morphometrics and
other other faster methods like grain
size and shape analysis through High um
throughput flow systems in order to
increase the amount of information that
we have and with the genomic analogy
when you measure things by Next
Generation sequencing there is a bit of
a trade-off between the Precision of the
measurement and the speed at which you
get it and I'm proposing the same
trade-off when it comes to morphology we
will get something out of having more
information even if there's more noise
in that
information and the final piece of of
why we should just be doing this already
is that we actually have methods um that
have already been published and already
been tested for dealing with this High
throughput morphological data so this
here is just an example um from Doug
boer's group where they've basically
been using automated 3D morphological
comparisons to compare teeth so the
teeth that they measured they just have
a a relatively small set of teeth but
they've measured them with micro C
scanning and so our group is taking
these same methods and then applying
them to the tens of thousands of fossils
that we measuring with semi semi-3d me
methods so although the opportunity is
there the fossils or the living
organisms exist the methods exist and
the tools with which to measure these
shapes exist we aren't really doing it
at the scale that we need to be doing as
a as a broader
community so the a lot of the work in my
lab is built around the premise that
closing this G data Gap is doable and
well worth doing and for many questions
it depends on your question of course
but for many questions you just want to
skip straight to the trait data and look
at things like variation and
shape so I'm going to talk about one
type of data
today and the key type of data is
measuring the shape of my microfossils
using um 2D and semi-3d
measurements so basically each of these
fossils this is the planktonic for
manifer single celled organism each one
of them is on the scale of one10 to one
millimeter in size so these are about
the size of a grain of small salt or
quite a bit smaller in fact but you can
see from this picture that their
morphology varies quite a bit and so
there's actually a morphological
taxonomy that matches up with with
genetics so we can actually identify to
species what each one of these organisms
are and when you look at these organisms
you can see within a population that
their shape varies quite a
bit so what we're doing is we're going
to sites around the global ocean today
throughout the Atlantic primarily and
for the last 80 million years to create
a database of morphological variation
Within These fossils um and to start
we're starting in the Atlantic today and
we've been trying to minimize the noise
in our data by orienting the fossils and
and prepping them in a certain way and
here you can see one of our slides and
the students that are prepping the
slides have been getting so bored that
they've been making patterns like Yale
on my slides um and we have things like
running horses and waves but um the goal
of this calibration data set is to
basically deal with the fact that if you
just toss fossils on a microscope slide
they have a random orientation whereas
if if you organize them uh from a common
orientation it minimizes the noise so
we're testing to see if we can skip that
orientation step in the future because
it it really is quite
painstaking but um uh over the last year
we've managed to put together um about
20 sites at this point which means that
we have on the order of 50,000
individuals that have been
measured but going but starting
essentially a new approach to measuring
phenotypes was a really daunting and
Endeavor and getting off the ground was
helped dramatically by the data
infrastructure here at Yale so what did
we do so we bought a microscope that is
better used uh oftentimes in histology
but we riged it so you can use reflected
light so it's an automatic Little Robot
microscope that steps around and takes
uh uh three-dimensional slices through
an
object we bought a data storage uh
server with 50 terabytes so we could put
our data somewhere and
um we looked into different options for
S uh for storing and sharing this
data and really when it came to solving
all of these problems at every single
step it was a big um there were multiple
hurdles because nobody's done done this
in this way for for fossils before so we
worked with people uh in the different
microscope companies to come up with the
best system for our
needs uh within Yale we worked with a
lot of people um on the storage and
Computing side I have to say when I
first started this I was worried about
properly identifying each one of these
fossils because as soon as you go
through a slide um I have to go back to
this as soon as you go through a slide
like this that has you know a thousand
individuals on it each one of those
individuals needs its own ID and its own
information with where it comes from and
so I sent an email out to to Yale's
Network and Kristen sort of caught me
and said hey we have the infrastructure
to help you deal with this let's get a
team together and figure out the best
way to put information on your images to
store them and to make them accessible
to the public so if you're starting out
in a new field I think one of the big
takeaway message here at Yale is that
there are people here that are actually
willing and excited to help you come up
with the best solution so that was a
really amazing thing that I've been uh
to have a chance to work with everyone
over the last
year and so what we've done up until
this point is basically build the
informatics pipelines to go from having
a slide to having the data out the other
end so if you look at a slide like this
the first thing that we do is we
automatically identify all the objects
we cut them up into unique objects and
we smack a label on them and that label
I don't know if you guys can read it
very well but it basically says it gives
every object a unique name it tells you
what site it comes from it tells you how
large it is tells you what time period
it lived in tells you it's latitude and
longitude and you get that for every
single slice every single depth stack um
but that's not what most people are
going to want when they do their
research they're going to want the
derivative data what's the 2D shape data
or what's the 3D wireframe data so the
pipeline also includes automatic
measures for measuring shape and we're
working on the 3D aspects of it at this
moment so I'm just going to end by
talking about the challenges that we
faced and the challenges that we still
facing actually and one of the big
challenges we're facing is that there is
no uh open access data storage um
infrastructure within the United States
as a whole for this type of data there
are multiple different Resource Centers
that claim to be something like gin Bank
where you can put morphological data but
they're actually not set up for data of
this magnitude so although I have a 50
terabyte server we're nearly filled it
up at this point so and um a lot of the
data storage that we have um
the the way that we cost out data
storage internally requires paying for
data on a year-by-year basis which makes
a lot of sense given the importance of
data curation but it's very difficult to
write into a grant to say that you'd
like to pay for 50 terabytes of data for
a 100 years so the problem with storing
data forever is a big one but I'd argue
that it's an important one because one
of the brilliant things about the whole
genomics Revolution was not just what
was done with the first set of genetic
data but it was the reprocessing that
was done after afterwards and it was
this whole ecosystem of
bioinformaticians who then learned how
to deal with the data as time went on
and you really have to have a big pool
of data for people to work on in order
to build up that sort of community so
I'm really quite um emphatic that we
need to keep this data long enough to
build up the community to deal with it
and that's a really big
problem so recur recurring data costs
are are really prohibitive um and it'd
be fun to think about alternative data
pricing structures that would allow for
permanent data storage um that can be
costed into a grant in an upfront man
manner um the second takeaway is that
yes this data is messy it's not as
perfect as if you Orient a fossil or
take a a resolve 3D image but data
volume itself can be transformative and
this is something that we we've really
learned from things like astronomy and
genomics and this message just keeps
coming up over and over again but data
is just data without people and really
transforming data into science and
answering the biggest most important
questions requires having the support of
a broad range of creative interactive
people and um I've been really lucky to
have that here at Yale but I'd like to
sort of beat the drum that we have to
keep this going if we want to keep
leading in datadriven
science so big data and measuring the
shape of life we're working on it guys
but we have a lot of outstanding
problems that could really benefit from
the expertise that's been built up over
the Decades of working on astronomical
problems and genetic problems and all
the other network problems that you're
dealing on so there's the opportunity to
actually look at the processes that
underly Evolution itself which I find
terrifically exciting but there are
really big hurdles um to to doing this
and no single lab or no single
University can do it on their own so
I'll just end with this isn't just for
tiny fossils these approaches should be
taken everywhere um but hopefully by
starting it with tiny fossils uh it Prov
provides a road map for others who want
to do something similar so thank
[Applause]
you okay good afternoon I want to first
thank the organizers of the day of data
for inviting me to present some present
some of my research and I also want to
thank all of you for being here it's a
gorgeous Friday afternoon and you're all
inside hearing us talk about data so
very fortunate to have you all here and
looking forward to sharing some ideas
for those of you who are not familiar
with our Research Center the Yale Center
for environmental law and policy we're a
joint Think Tank between the school of
Forestry Environmental Studies and also
Yale law school we are founded in 1994
it's our 20th anniversary we are not
having a party unfortunately but just
occurred to me today that we have been
around for 20 years and we seek to apply
academic rigor to real world policym so
I want to talk about one of the projects
that is our Flagship which is the
Environmental performance index and so
this project seeks to help policymakers
in the real world seek a a signal
through very very noisy data and so um
if there's one message that I want to
leave you with today is that measurement
matters and it matters for the
environment and so maybe your familiar
with this old adage that you can't
manage what you don't measure and you
can't manage well what you don't measure
well well what I'm going to argue and in
my research we actually see many gaps
currently in our understanding of many
environmental issues and so measurement
is still very Salient and we still need
to do more of it for the
environment so arguably data and
information has had salience for the
environmental domain since Rachel Carson
in the 1960s released her seminal work
Silent Spring and so in this work she
used science and demonstrated that
pesticides were accumulating in
agriculture and food change and
endangering human health and natural
ecosystems and so by demonstrating their
toxicity she was able to motivate a
public awareness campaign in order to
raise awareness of this of this
important issue and the danger of
pesticides but if we look at
Environmental Policy throughout the
years since Rachel Carson released her
work and arguably started this
environmental movement in the United
States environmental policy has long
been plagued by information asymmetries
data gaps and so as a result a lot of
our policies have been based on educated
guesses but not hard facts so I wish I
had the problem that Professor gersin
presented which is this hairball problem
of having too much data and not being
able to distill it down but actually in
my work it's the opposite we don't have
enough data and we actually have a lot
of gaps um so with the rise of the
information age we're starting to slowly
see a shift from top down command and
control types of governance and
regulation to those that increasingly
emphasize the role that data and
information can play so command controls
that first bubble top down regulation
moving more towards economic
market-based measures so right now
president salv is talking about an
internal carbon cap for the University
so that's falling into that second wave
but now we're really in this third wave
where there's a greater recognition that
information transparency and disclosure
can play a role in helping to drive
improvements and en environmental
policy and so now we're embarking upon
this phase of Big Data as my colleagues
just mentioned where data is playing
more of an active role where we can it
can actually drive improvements in
environmental policy and data and
information can wholescale restructure
processes actors and institutions so
this is where our work Falls in
particularly on the the work that I'll
I'll discuss next which is on
indicators so what what are indicators
well indicators are taking some sort raw
data and quantifying variables through
some type of transformation
statistically or some type of
normalization to then in the
environmental domain communicate some
sort of phenomenon environmental
pressure or state and so my work looks
at the role of indicators as they play
in this causal chain of moving from data
to information to eventually influencing
actors and policy makers and creating
some form of knowledge so the the lens
that my work squares Falls within is um
the role of indicators in the policy
process so what might some of those
roles actually be well first of all we
see that indicators and policy can play
an instrumental role so they can be used
as tools to evaluate whether or not
programs are performing well or whether
or not there are some critical areas of
concern they can also play a conceptual
role so where there's a new idea or
trying to connect to disparate Concepts
together indicators can actually Bridge
ideas together so I have this picture of
a molecule because it's interesting when
I talk about indicators and data policy
makers they say to me I don't want to
learn chemistry I just want you to tell
me am I doing better am I doing worse so
no chemistry no molecules no science
decision makers at least in my work they
don't want to hear it so they just want
to know up or down am I getting better
or worse and indicators can help provide
that information um last indicators can
also play a political role so I have a
picture of Francis Bacon here saying
knowledge is power and so in many cases
we see that policy makers use indicators
for some political purpose whether to
discredit a particular actor or to boost
their particular position so probably in
election cycle you hear a lot of this
Statistics my opponent caused the E
economy to downturn 10% Etc so that's
another way that indicators are used in
policy so now I want to turn to the
project that I lead here at Yale more
specifically which is the Environmental
performance index or Epi I think we
might have some Public Health people
here so I don't want to confuse it with
EPI and epidemiology because that's
something that it's very confusing on
Twitter when I just say Epi so I wanted
to make that clear talking about
environment and what this is is a global
ranking that we produce biannually here
at Yale in conjunction with Columbia
University and we rank countries on how
they well they perform on high priority
environmental issues like climate change
air quality Forest Fisheries Etc so now
I'll talk about how we actually use data
to create this index and ranking well
the Epi measures performance in two
policy objectives so we look at impacts
on human health so that's on the right
with the warm colors and we also gauge
performance in ecosystems so that's uh
the blue circle right there so looking
at these two objectives we're able to
gauge how well countries are performing
and protecting human health from
environmental harm and also preventing
natural resource degradation and then
Within These two policy objectives we
look at nine issue areas so this is what
I just mentioned Fisheries forests water
and sanitation Etc and where the data
actually comes in is on the indicator
scale so we look at 20 indicators for
every single country and these
indicators we use what we call a
proximity to Target methodology so we
take raw data and then we determine a
top performance Benchmark by which to
gauge how close or far every country is
to achieving that Target so a question I
get very commonly is well how do you
determine what those targets are isn't
that rather arbitrary well we try to be
objective by looking towards
International Frameworks treaties
scientific thresholds something that's
objective that we can objectively gauge
every country's performance on where do
we get our data we have to look towards
official statistics so um data that
countries report to un agencies for
example or we rely on satellite data um
in some cases we actually custom compile
our own data sets by calling up country
statistical offices to to get to get the
data so once um we're able to collect
all of that data and for every single
country calculate proximity to Target
indicators we assign a series of
statistical waiting at each level each
level of the circle to develop that one
number that represents a country's
environmental performance index score so
the size of the wedge in this wheel
roughly represents the the St
statistical waiting that we apply to
each level of
aggregation so for the 2014 index which
was just launched this past January at
the world economic Forum we ranked 178
countries around the world so to give
you a sense of how Global that is that
constitutes around 99% of the global
population around 98% of global land
area and 97% of global GDP so it's as
much of a global picture of the
environment as you can get that's really
out there so just taking a look at this
map the higher performing countries are
in blue so probably not surprisingly
North America European countries perform
quite well and the countries in Orange
perform poorly so a lot of subsaharan
Africa we have South Asia that performs
quite poorly and a lot of Central Asia
as well okay so what are some of the key
takeaways from this year's index and
This Global picture of environmental
data and results well what we find is
that performance isn't consistent across
country across countries or across
issues so if you look at results over
the past decade um issues such as access
or drinking water reductions in child
mortality terrestrial habitat protection
have been improving over time and also
are doing quite well so the the y- axis
is zero to 100 so think of a report card
with 100 being an A+ and zero being
failing miserably failing um so actually
fish stocks miserably failing which is
one of one of these dark green lines so
there are other issues such as
protecting fish species and protecting
populations against poor air quality
which are doing very very poorly so this
is something that we're able to do after
we compile all the data and analyze for
these Global Mega Trends another
conclusion that we walked away with is
when you have measurement and management
aligned real progress can be achieved so
we call this slide here the tale of two
indicators following off of Dickens the
yellow line represents the proportion of
the global population lacking access to
clean water whereas the Orange Line
represents the population globally
that's being exposed to poor air so very
very Divergent Trends and that reflects
the fact that through this International
framework called the Millennium
development goals there was a goal
identified to to have the global
population lacking access to clean
drinking water by 2015 and in 2011 the
world already surpassed that goal so
that's a a prime example of when you
have international systems that
prioritize and put a lot of investment
into monitoring and managing water you
can ACH achieve Real Results and then
another way to look at that is when the
two are not aligned as in the case of
Fisheries natural systems really suffer
so this is a plot over the last 60 years
of the percentage of fish stocks that
are either overe exploited or collapsed
and very very surprising and Stark
Trends here and it's largely because a
lot of governments don't regularly
measure and report on a lot of these
fish species so we had to actually work
with an independent organization outside
of the UN FAO to to reconstruct the time
series of these fish data so that we
could get a sense of globally how fish
stocks are doing and it's not a good
picture it's not very
optimistic and last um data gaps remain
so I talked about the fact that we don't
yet as I argue have big data for many of
the environmental issues that we would
like to gauge for the Epi so this is a
map of where
cities report air quality data to the
World Health Organization and you can
see many many gaps through most of
Africa Russia for example only has one
data point a lot of Southeast Asia
missing a lot of data and same with with
Latin America and in fact we're still
missing globally comparable data for
many of these issues that we would like
to gauge country's performance on but
because there isn't any data we can't
include it in our Epi so that includes
things like desertification soil quality
Wetlands loss nuclear safety so we don't
claim that the Epi is by any means
comprehensive but it really reflects as
much as the data that we have available
but also the many gaps that we still
face okay so another question I often
get asked is well how do you know that
anybody cares about the EPI and is this
actually making the policy impact that
you talked about earlier so I have
several theories as to how the Epi is
actually affecting and influencing
policy first of all by developing this
ranking by ranking countries from number
one to 178 8 what we're seeing happen is
a race to the top so countries are
competing against each other they're
saying well I'm Norway and Sweden is
doing so much better than me what is it
that they're doing that I can also do so
a great example is South Korea um in
2002 in our first iter one of our first
iterations of our index they performed
136 out of 142 countries and this was a
huge slap in the face of South Korea
they said how could this be there's no
way we can be doing this poorly and so
they created the 136 Environmental Forum
based on their ESI score and they
invited celebrities policy makers City
Mayors uh Civil Society representatives
to come together to talk about what they
could do to improve their score on this
index another way we see the Epi
influencing policy is the Epi is
becoming a platform for change within
countries so by presenting those
indicators consistently to every single
country they can make comparisons to
relevant peers and understand where they
might be leading and where they might
might be lagging so a prime example of
this is this this year we broke a story
in the New York Times that questioned
why the international attention has paid
a lot of focus to beijing's poor air
quality but New Delhi which has
similarly bad air quality has been
ignored and so using satellite derived
data this is one of the very few cases
in which we actually do have some big
data for the environment we were able to
show through our indicators that India's
air quality is just as bad as China's if
not worse on some of our indicators and
this was a huge surprise to new delhi's
government I came to work one day and
every single media organization had
contacted me The Economist New York
Times Wall Street Journal BBC and it was
because of this New York Times story
that I mean this is a terrible headline
we don't want anybody to be breathing
any smoggy or bad air but it really was
motivating for the Indian government I
mean they were just completely a Gass
and I said to them well if you don't
think your air quality is as bad as
beijing's cough up the data but the fact
is is that you don't regularly monitor
any air quality in your cities on a
real-time basis basis and some of our
researchers went to their official
websites and found that they were
reporting reporting realtime data as old
as April of 2013 and this was just this
year in January so it it was quite
shocking to them and since we called
them out in the New York Times They have
released um or they have plans to
release a new air quality index that
will link together ambient measures of
air pollutants to health impacts because
people there also have no idea how bad
the air quality is so some of the Indian
policy makers that I spoken to have said
oh air quality isn't a problem in India
it's not going to be for another 10 to
20 years and what I've said to them is
no it's a problem now and because you
don't present any data doesn't mean it's
not a problem and so I think that's a I
think a pretty powerful example for how
the Epi is actually playing into these
policy
debates um third we see that the Epi is
also working to set and inform policy
agendas so earlier this year we actually
had a delegation from Iraq come and
visit us this is at Yale law school and
we had a delegation from Iraq's Ministry
of environment and Ministry of planning
come to us because they were very very
concerned about the fact that in 2012
they performed last on our EPI and they
wanted to know how they could do better
so this was literally a week before all
the political situation happened and and
Isis struck and so if they had waited a
week they wouldn't have been able to
come but this was quite interesting for
us because as academics you operate
sometimes in an ivy Tower you have no
idea if anyone's paying attention to
what you're doing and this is a case
where they reached out to us because
they wanted to know how they could
better and they were putting things on
the environmental policy agenda because
they were performing poorly in those
areas on the
Epi last as I mentioned because we look
towards these International Frameworks
the Epi can be a powerful tool to help
countries track progress towards Global
goals so I was just in New York earlier
this week because the UN General
Assembly is meeting right now to talk
about the design of new Global
sustainable development goals that will
take place in 2015 when these old
Millennium development goals expire and
so because we knew that this process was
coming this week in September when we
started to develop our data sets for the
Epi we were looking towards the proposed
sustainable development goals for
guidance as to what might be most
helpful for countries so this is one of
these data sets that I mentioned that we
custom compiled on wastewater treatment
so one of these SGS that's being
proposed is on water and they want
countries to track their percentage of
of Wastewater that they treat um but
currently there doesn't exist any other
data set out there except for the one
that we put together to tell countries
how they're doing on this critical
driver of freshwater quality so this was
one of one of my researchers full-time
job for about four months is putting
together this data set so it's it was a
big breakthrough for us as well okay so
now is the the ulterior motive to my
being here today which is a call to
action to anybody who wants to help us
in this effort of trying to get big data
for the
environment and so what my I mean I have
a a definition of Big Data up here but I
think U my colleagues have have gone
over sufficiently what we mean by Big
Data but what I argue is that we still
don't have big data yet for the
environment and that's mainly because
whales don't tweet trees don't shop on
Amazon and even though you have private
sector companies like Amazon and eBay
Target for example who have realized the
value of Big Data it's not yet happening
or being applied or thought of very much
to the environmental realm so as a
result I I showed you all of those data
gaps and we're in the process of right
now trying to think about how we can
fill in some of those gaps but we
desperately need as much help as we can
get so one consideration that that we're
thinking is how we might engage citizens
and with a proliferation of smartphones
lowcost sensors citizen science how we
might engage everyday people into
helping us Source data from the bottom
up instead of relying on data source
from the top down from governments
because we know that in our research
governments have variable motivations to
not report data hello India um or
manipulate data hello China um so
because of that I I think that this
really calls for a data Revolution for
us to engage citizens companies
non-state actors into this effort to
help us really understand some of the
most critical issues that face the world
today which includes air quality and
climate change and these problems are
not getting better they're getting worse
so towards that end I just want to point
to a couple projects that my team is
working on one is we published this air
pollution map from an Eco hackathon so
I'm actually hoping that we'll be able
to host one of these here at Gale and
that many of you will be able to
participate but it's especially on data
visualization because we found that
something that's very powerful is to
actually put all the data in an easily
consumed format and let people react to
it so we hacked this map of air
pollution data using our satellite data
and that who data set that I showed you
earlier and published the map in the
Atlantic and NASA retweeted it shared it
all over their social media so we had
tens of thousands of people reacting and
commenting all over the world on air
quality in their country country and
their cities and saying well why is my
city this way or why is my country doing
that way and why if I'm Russia is my
government only monitoring air pollution
in Moscow so that this is something that
we found has been very powerful in
starting conversations getting people
excited about data and another example
that we're going to be ready to launch
is we have a couple students who are
computer science majors and programmers
whove been working with us to translate
our very dense scientific findings on
data and indicators into a more easily
digestible fun and attractive way so
they've taken this special issue on the
Next Generation air quality indicators
that we publish an atmospheric
environment and developing a series of
interactive infographics so that people
can learn about where the data gaps are
what needs to be done and hopefully we
can motivate political action that way
so I encourage everyone to visit our
website it's Epi yale.edu also have a
couple colleagues in the back Andrew um
presented a poster on the Epi earlier so
if you didn't get a chance to see that
definitely find him afterwards cuz he
did a very cool interactive display with
multiple iPads so it was quite fun um
but yes please get in touch and uh we'
love to hear from you and hear any
feedback that you might have about our
project so thanks so
much thanks to all the speakers we have
a few minutes for questions so if uh you
want to raise your hand we'll make sure
you're you're close to
microphone
this is for the environmental talk uh it
strikes me that in the presentation that
you not only tried to master the data
that you had available you tried tried
to harness the power of the internet to
lobby for more data and also to help
people understand the data that you had
and I I think that last piece helping
people who are not necessarily expert in
the domain in which you're working
understand the data and make it uh Every
Man's data every person's data I think
is a a laudable goal and I'd be curious
for you to comment a little bit about
the process that you have gone through
or your group has gone through to try to
get a handle on
that um hello okay that's a great
question and so I've been at Yale this
is my seventh year now and I've been
running this project for four and it
definitely took a lot of convincing of
my colleagues and my PhD adviser that
this is actually something that is
really worthwhile and is I do policy
research so what good is it if I just
publish a bunch of Dent scientific
articles which I have to do for my
tenure process but at the same time
students who are in our master's program
are only around for two years and so
they and many of them are professional
degree students so they're not here to
do research degrees and so I thought
about well how can we best utilize our
students interest and time and skills in
a way that will also help them get jobs
I mean they they want to go and work for
think tanks they want to do policy
research Consulting nobody's wants to
read an academic paper that they've
written for a class they want to know
that they know how to do sharp policy
analysis that they know how to use and
interpret data sharply and so um from
that I said I think we need to raise a
lot of money to invest in a better we
because our website before no offense to
any statistician out there but it was a
statistician who did our website and it
was it was good for a statistician but
it was very difficult to interpret a lot
of the Scatter Plots that were included
on the website so um it's it definitely
it takes a little bit of uh it took took
me a little bit of um galvanizing my
colleagues but I think once they
realized what Vision I had and the
results and the the response that we got
I think now it's pretty much selling
itself so we've had a lot of other
research search centers within our
school approach us and say who did your
web design what students do you work
with is we pull from students from the
art program from the School of
Architecture from our own school because
it has to be interdisciplinary and it's
fun for the students because then they
get to learn skills from the computer
programmers from the statisticians from
the policy research folks and so it's
been um it's been a it's been a process
it has not been very easy but I think
that now we're starting to hit our
stride and get a lot of recognition for
what we're doing but it is very very
challenging because I can't edit blog
posts every day and manage um
programming projects and so I've
actually now I've hired somebody who can
help coordinate all of the the Outreach
and then I can focus more on the
research but it it certainly is
challenging but I think it's really
really worthwhile and I'm happy to share
my experience of anybody wants to have a
meeting because I think it's so
worthwhile I think there's so much great
research that goes on here at Yale but
it gets lost within the the Ivory
Tower angel that so uh you pointed out
uh you know there were obvious and for
obvious reasons big gaps in in the lot
of the data so it's it's common practice
in like in geology looking at paleo
climate and so forth to use various
proxies yes do do you have are there
ways to do that here or we have lots of
proxies but they're they're not very
good so our agriculture category for
example we have very very crude policy
proxies so we say well have countries
banned or restricted their pesticide use
according to the Stockholm convention
which regulates these pesticides but it
doesn't actually say anything about on
the ground whether or not they've
actually implemented those commitments
so we have to use a lot of proxies even
this wastewater treatment indicator is a
crude proxy for freshwater quality so we
would like to be able to have comparable
water quality for all freshwater bodies
in countries around the world but for a
multitude of reasons that's just isn't
possible we just don't have any Global
indicator of water quality and so yeah
we definitely rely a lot on proxies but
governments don't really like that they
they want to know the output measures
and and what is the condition on the
ground and that's why I don't think
we're there yet and I don't think we yet
have big data to do that but that's a
really good
point hi um couple questions um is it
possible to use like a phone app to
measure air quality yet that's first
question second question is how do you
deal with known underestimates from
various people um when you don't when
you have to rely on government stuff and
the third really nerdy question is how
did you choose the weights for your
various categories so for the first
question yes people are designing phone
sensors so there's a Swedish company
that has developed some iPhone uh I
guess like little attachments that that
you can connect to your phone that will
measure things like carbon monoxide and
PE particulate matter and and various
things they're about $99 right now so
that's still not I think as cheap as it
needs to be but I taught a class at Yo
college College last spring that was
looking at urbanization and environment
in China and India and my students just
downloaded some instructions off the
internet and built a cheap sensor for
about 25 bucks so I think it can be done
but a huge question is what is the
reliability of that data how quality is
it and so that's something that we're
working on right now to try to I mean
it' be great to also include this as
part of our hackathon get the computer
scientists and the engineering students
and researchers together so that we can
manufacture very cheap sensors ship them
all over the world and collect better
data and um to your other question about
the waiting that is a very hotly debated
topic amongst our team and also with
external audiences and so we have to we
we try to look at the quality of the
data and whether or not it's a proxy if
it if it's an actual measure or if it's
a proxy so we downweight the proxies we
don't wait them as much as we do the
actual output on the ground measures and
then we debate them we say oh is is the
data quality good is there any reason
why we should be down weting those so
it's very very subjective and a lot of
countries complain to us and say I don't
agree with your waiting of this of this
issue or that issue so I I forgot your
second question but hopefully I answered
it bias oh yes bias um that's that's a
problem that's a huge problem what we
would like to do is to eventually
publish uncertainty estimates and
confidence intervals for every single
one of our indicators but with the
government reported statistics you can't
do that because a lot of times when they
report data to the UN they don't report
the uncertainty estimates so it's very
very crude and this is one of the
reasons why I think we need to get big
data because then when n equals all
right then you don't have those problems
so or you you shouldn't have those
problems in theory but yeah yeah
exactly Mark when you see these Federal
mandates
for data sharing policies you know EX
data sharing
policies as a as a researcher do you
look at this and say wow this is great
or what do I need to do just to get this
through the door and not have to spend
so much time on it well I I I certainly
think that the emphasis on data sharing
is a good thing obviously all all data
analysts love when people produce more
data and they share it I mean that's a
general truth um though I do think that
um it is the case that increasingly with
data sharing there it is somewhat
cumbersome sometimes and a lot of times
you know I you know collaborate and
interact a lot with a lot of researchers
who are um working towards those
policies and I realize how much work it
is and how very complicated it is and
sometimes you do get the sense that a
lot of people think that it's more work
to share it than it is to actually
generated and so forth and and I do
think there are times when the data
sharing it maybe is not in the best
interest you know it's it's better just
to get the answer and you know generate
another data set and so forth and to go
through all the work of trying to share
it um and and so
forth there's no more questions we're
scheduled for a short 10-minute break
and we'll reconvene for the next session
at uh at uh roughly 255 uh join me in
thanking the presenters
[Applause]
again
kunda and uh I've been asked to uh start
I guess this is session three we have uh
two speakers uh our first speaker is
Leandro tulus in the blue uh a little
bit about him he's a professor in the
depart Department of electrical
engineering at Yale and his research uh
interests include uh computer and
communication networks uh with an
emphasis on uh developing models and
algorithms for complex networks uh
architectures and protocols for Wireless
Systems as well as exploring sensor
networks and novel internet
architectures in addition he has a a
rather vast experimental platform for
conducting his
research uh leandros joined Yale about
four weeks ago
so he's brand new and I think he's still
unpacking boxes so welcome our next
speaker is uh Peter SCH he's a professor
of Economics at the Yale School of
Management he's a research associate at
the National Bureau of economic research
and a special sworn status researcher at
the US Census Bureau and his research
focuses on how countries firms and
workers respond to globalization he
joined Yale in 1999 so I'm guessing most
of his boxes are unpacked by now so so
welcome Leandra thank
you thank you sakar hi everybody I'm
glad to be here and I have the
opportunity to give this talk um the
flavor of my talk will be a bit
different than what we have heard until
now um our uh research is focused on
communication networks that is on how to
manage the transport of data from uh
where they are generated to the users
and uh I'll present u a few problems
related uh to current challenges for
mobile networking and how we address
them so uh we'll start with uh some uh
background and motivation of what you
will hear and the motivation is uh the
explosion of uh mobile data the last uh
uh few years and uh the diagram here uh
shows that and as we see the main reason
for um the data the mobile data
explosion is essentially the smartphones
and uh all the videos that
um uh either streamed to the mobile user
or they are recorded and uploaded by the
user uh so this is U some current data
uh the 2012 13 and 14 and some projected
uh um numbers for the data growth as
they are uh predicted by a study
performed by Cisco so we see that there
is uh an average annual growth of
66% and uh as we'll see in the next
slide that is much faster than
the mobile network capacity is
growing um the capacity of uh the mobile
network is
growing uh by various actions of The
Operators first uh there is some
increase on the available licensed
bandwidth then uh there is a continuous
additional deployment of new cell sites
and uh there are improvements of the
wireless technology itself that allows
to push more bits per Herz now all this
adds up to an average uh annual growth
that is of the order of
29% that is uh far behind than uh the
increase in mobile data so um uh that
stresses the mobile operators quite a
bit and they are look they look to all
kind of alternatives to deal with this
explosion of course there are
developments on the wireless technology
itself currently um uh we are uh using
um forg networks based on the LD
technology um and there is underway U
research for the next um generation of U
um mobile Wireless technology what is
called the 5G technology but this will
take a while it's a technology that uh
um will be based on the 60 gigahertz um
band and will provide um a very
significant increase of the capacity but
until then and this will take um a few
years at least uh there is an urgent
need to deal with um the the increasing
demand for uh
capacity and uh I'll present uh three
approaches we have considered recently
uh for dealing with this problem and the
first one is uh what we call data
offloading what do we mean by data of
loading um typically mobile uh services
are provided by uh cellular base
stations owned by the mobile operators
that operate in the license Spectrum
which is licensed to the different
operators now in addition to those there
is a proliferation of uh other means for
wireless access more specifically the
WiFi access points which are omnipresent
nowadays and they can be of three kinds
uh the residential access points owned
by individuals uh Enterprise access
points
uh as well as uh access points deployed
by different kind of operators which are
provided for service to the users now uh
these access points operate in uh an
unlicensed Spectrum band and uh they are
much cheaper in many ways than U uh
wireless access through the license
Spectrum to the cellular operator
websites so um one approach for dealing
with the increase in the capacity is to
try to use to use to the extent possible
uh these other means for wireless access
that is uh access points and fto cells
and uh offload a bit um the cellular
base
stations um now this offloading is
happening in many ways uh for instance
the mobile operator themselves deploy
their own access point networks and
perhaps you have uh seen some of it
already moving around for instance AT&T
has deployed 32,000 WiFi hotpots that is
3 2,000 access points uh primarily in uh
heavy traffic areas uh in addition there
are um other companies like phone uh who
have their own uh deployed access point
Network now uh besides those the vast
majority of access point we see they are
uh um residential access points or
Enterprise access points owned by
individual entities and uh the big
opportunity will be if there is an
effective way
to uh exploit the available capacity of
those access points for
offloading uh what do we mean uh if you
turn on your um WiFi interface of um
your uh smartphone wherever you are you
will see uh typically at least a
thousand a dozen or more uh networks
available but they are all
locked uh because they belong to
individuals if there is a way to make
them available some
how uh to you and have the mobile
operator save the capacity by directing
you to those access points instead of
serving you directly that will be a big
game for them and
um we started some ways to do that and
uh we came up with a method that uh
essentially views this interaction of
the access points and the different
mobile operator uh operators s a
market uh where the operators uh try to
buy in some sense Services by the access
points and the access points try to
benefit somehow by the fact that they
offer their capacity to The Operators to
uh redirect their traffic so in a
typical scenario we may have a number of
cell site andenas belonging to diff
different mobile operators and they
operate in the same area with a number
of access points each access point
belonging to different
individuals uh now uh each uh cell
site from um a technical point of view
May uh redirect their mobile users to
number of access points who are within
reach and uh
um and at the same time each access
point May provide uh this kind of
service to different Sal sites in the
sense that it may serve uh uh mobile
users from different
operators and the question is what is an
effective way of assigning
uh access points to mobile
operators uh effective from two points
of view one point of view is uh to do
the optimal allocation of mobile users
to uh access points and offload let's
say cell sites which are uh
heavily utilized and uh they are in
capacity and they cannot serve
adequately their users and uh at the
same time uh uh satisfy other uh
efficiency indicators like for instance
try to offload mobile users which are at
the periphery of the cell of a cellular
operator because those users are most uh
costly in serving them both in terms of
consumed bandwidth and
energy um now at the same time the
access point should should have some uh
incentives for providing their excess
capacity even though it is U free for
them uh the fact that they are providing
should give uh back some benefits so uh
these incentives should be somehow uh
proportional uh to the benefit they will
offer to the mobile operators and the
best way to do that is to create a
market now um it turned out that some uh
uh more traditional ways for doing that
like uh different types of auctions like
the vcg auction or the maafi auction uh
are not efficient for that particular
case because they they will require in
general an intermediate broker that may
need to invest in the market that is to
put uh money or some kind of utility in
the market and the best way to do that
was uh to
use um a double auction uh which is an
extension of uh a ky mechanism for the
network utility
maximization so we came up uh with a
setting for this double auction where uh
both the mobile network operators and
the access points are used as are viewed
as biders and uh they bid based on the
price on some prices offered by
uh an intermediate broker now it turned
out that the scheme was effective oops
I'll skip this um in the sense that um
uh it is uh a minable to a distributed
implementation through an intermediate
broker that uh emits uh let's say scaler
signals uh and allows an iterative
exchange of bid between the
participating biders and it turned out
that uh uh it converges to some uh uh
allocation of um access points to uh
cell sites which is socially optimal
socially optimal with respect to the
utility functions which are selected now
um by a careful selection of the utility
function both from the side of the
mobile network operator and the access
point uh this double auction mechanism
uh May converge to different um let's
say equilibrium points and uh the
challenge for um the designer is to
select those utility functions
appropriately now um I'll skip
to this kept us busy um the last couple
of years as you see for the related
Publications I'll skip um to the second
uh setting just to give you a flavor um
I skip a few a few FL a few slides uh I
will just uh um would like to let you
know that uh in um a week time in
October 8 I'll give the same
presentation the full version one hour
of it in the yin seminar so if you got
interested from what you hear today you
are welcome uh on octob toate in the yin
seminar so
um a second problem we considered is
what is called the user provided Network
and it is uh uh we try to address the
same Challenge from but from a different
way that is uh instead of uh leaving uh
the game of capacity to the cellular
operators that try to capture access
points we View uh the mobile user itself
as a um a potential Network
provider uh that is the smartphone that
the user carries may act both as a
gateway to the internet as well as a
relay to the user and uh by having U uh
the users assume those three different
roles that is uh
um consumers of service or relay or
Gateway in an appropriate way they may
provide service to each other uh without
uh uh with being transparent to the
network and the question is how to do
this
effectively by mimicking uh schemes that
have been adopted in other domains for a
similar purpose for instance uh
um the Airbnb is an example right of a
similar type of um uh interaction but in
a different domain now uh some uh recent
advantages in networking like the
softwar defined uh networks which are
available today uh provide all the
technical flexibility for adopting such
schemes and implementing them let me
give you some examples of how such a
scheme will work and what are the
challenges uh here for instance we see
uh three smartphone um
carriers uh in the first
picture that may act either as consumers
of service which is the client here or
as intermediates for uh providing
connection to the internet uh so uh the
two smartphones which are labeled
gateways they have a direct connection
to the internet one through uh a
Cellular Connection and the other
through a Wi-Fi connection and uh the
third user
benefits um from their own internet
connection to have uh uh uh to have his
own uh internet connectivity through
them
uh in the second picture uh we have a
two hope s scheme where uh the client
smartphone accesses the the internet
through a two hop connection to the
smartphone that has a direct access to
the internet through um uh through his
cell
connection and uh in the other two
pictures we see two other scenarios of
such role exchange between relay and
Gateway uh which have some um uh which
have which which provide uh eventual
internet connectivity to the final
client now uh as a network evolves and
the smartphones move around their
connections their direct connections to
the internet change both in terms of
availability ility or quality so
different potential scenarios of clients
relays and gateways become possible and
uh the question is uh which scenario
will be adopted its time such that uh
the internet connectivity is efficient
in terms of uh speed and energy
consumption and it's also fair fair in
the sense that uh
each user take its turn serving the
other user and uh we don't end up in
schemes where some users always act as
gateways providing both capacity and
energy for internet connectivity while
other users uh always benefit by uh
having internet connectivity as clients
without spending money from their own
Cellular Connection or
energy and um
we came up with u a scheme to do that um
I will just
um mention some highlights of the scheme
first uh the scheme is based on um the
nas bargaining solution as the
underlying conceptual framework for
exchange of services in employ some
virtual currency uh to deal with uh
uh to deal with a problem that uh at
different uh time instances time
instances different users have different
uh uh quality of internet connections
and they Pro they can provide service or
obain service and uh furthermore uh the
nasar gaining solution in that
particular case
um naturally provides uh a distributed
means for implemen ending it and uh
keeping track of uh which users have
benefit for uh how much time and how
much each user owes to the other for the
future so uh it turned out that um um
this scheme Works uh well and um
oops I'll just want to show you
something
and uh it turns out that it fits well
with u a very um recent framework that
is available by Open Garden which
provides a technology for doing that and
uh the credit scheme we proposed uh it
can be adopted by the Open Garden
framework for regulating the user
access so uh I'll take just a few
minutes to say a few words about the
third problem which again tries to
address the same Challenge from a
different Viewpoint now um the Viewpoint
is the following um again we need to
deal with uh the rapid
capacity uh demand the increase of uh
the capacity demand uh and this is a
problem that is faced by the mobile
operator itself that is the mobile
operator uh in its effort
to increase the infrastructure capacity
it deploys uh cell sites of uh different
nature that is some are
um large cells some are micro cells or
Pico cells in the sense of the cells
with a periphery of a few 10
meters uh but this uh requires an
excessive infrastructure for connecting
all those cells to the internet and uh a
problem then is that
um a bottleneck is created on how all
these cells will be connected to the wir
infrastructure so a method uh to deal
with this bottleneck is again an
implicit one uh that takes advantage of
the fact that a lot of traffic nowaday
days especially U Down link traffic from
the network to the
user um is repetitive that is a large
number of users are seeing the same
video or u a large number of users in
the same location access the same data
so uh a natural way to deal with it is
uh to add storage at different stages of
the network and in particularly close to
uh the base station itself so novel uh
mobile network architectures have
storage at all these different uh levels
and the challenge is how to effectively
use the storage that is what traffic we
should store at each particular uh
storage cash that is available at
different uh parts of the network now uh
in order to
evaluate this uh there is a number of
considerations one is uh the likelihood
that a certain piece of information will
be needed at uh a particular point of
the network and this can be predicted to
a large extent uh by considering uh The
Social Network structure of the mobile
users that is the characteristics of uh
uh the access characteristics of uh the
friends let's say of a specific user uh
another consideration is uh the service
cost of the different connections that
is uh certain links are more expensive
than others and I would like to use
those as little as possible and that uh
um somehow influences the kind of uh
data that will store in the CES
that uh offload those links and U
another consideration is the service
policy itself that is uh we need to give
a
priority um I mean certain types of data
have priority over the others and those
should be given priority in storage in
the local cases as well so um all these
considerations should be taken into
account in
determining
uh in determining essentially whether a
piece of data that is delivered to a
user will be kept at the local storage
of the base station at the same time or
will be or will just be neglected so uh
we studied this problem and we came up
with uh some
uh um some strategy for determining
whether a certain piece of information
should be kept in each cash and uh this
strategy is the result of the solution
of uh an optimization problem uh the
challenge was uh how to make this
strategy simple to implement such that
it is attractive to a mobile operator
since uh the direct solution of the
optimization problem uh was U not amable
for uh an easy implementation of the
mobile operator so uh we looked in some
uh approximation uh methods to the
optimal strategy that uh made possible
an efficient implementation by the
mobile
operator so uh I think I'll um stop here
I just wanted to give you a flavor of
the type of work we are doing and how it
is uh maybe remotely
connected
to um the the data problems the data
issues you have seen in previous
talks and um I will be available for any
questions you may have
[Applause]
later
okay I lost it
find
great um okay uh thanks for having me
here um again I guess a different kind
of presentation this is more about um
data that's going to become available
not my own data but data that's going to
become available here at y through a um
what's known as a research data center
um so I thought uh uh when you use
Census Data every presentation you do
has to have one of these so I thought
even though there's nothing in it that's
using Census Data I would put one of
these up um you have to put up one of
these disclaimers all the
time uh so I would thought I would take
you very very briefly kind of through um
what rdc's are what you might get out of
them and why um they're about to be a
lot easier to use uh for yis than they
uh were before um so what is an RDC an
RDC is a research data center um the US
Census Bureau and increasingly a lot of
other agencies um in the US government
um have been placing data Avail uh uh
what administrative survey data
available um for the use by for use by
researchers and um these data are
actually never leave uh swetland
Maryland which is where all the servers
are um but increasingly the census is
allowing centers to pop up around the
country um which point to those data um
so research data center is a physical
location outside of the Census Bureau
that uh allows one to access census uh
data as well as uh census is now taking
on the role of archiving data from other
agencies um and uh not just anyone can
walk in they're highly secure locations
um uh multiple passwords and IDs to get
in um but uh researchers who can become
qualified users of the data are allowed
access uh to these data and the great
thing about an RDC is uh they're open
247 365 so you with access you can go in
whenever you want um so that's what an
RDC is uh what kinds of data does an RDC
contain so there's a really broad range
um of information available most of the
data I'm most familiar with the data uh
in the first um bullet there as an
economist using a lot of the economic
data um but think of anything you know
of that census collects uh the people
census the business census uh
demographic data lots of different
surveys um these data are made available
inside an RDC at the level at which
they're collected so public data sets
might summarize for example the number
of firms that exist in an industry um
the economic census if you access it
through an RDC allows you to see the uh
align the data for every uh
establishment of every firm that
reported information um so tremendous
tremendously useful data for certain
kinds of research um and then there's
similar kinds of data available for
demographers for um Healthcare Etc um so
I'm not going to go through the data
sets but um they're relatively easy to
find the list of which data sets are
available and kind of the variables that
they contain actually I should say the
one of the interesting things about the
census is what's available publicly and
what's not so actually I think the
variable names actually are not
disclosable so one of the funny things
about writing a proposal is you have to
say what data you want to use without
actually having the list of the
variables that are available and the way
you kind of get over that hurdle is you
work closely with a administrator of an
RDC who kind of coaches you along about
the data that might be available um so
for example if you click on one of these
data sets it wouldn't tell you all the
variables in there it would kind of give
an overview of what information is
contained in that data
set um so that's what an RDC is how did
y get an RDC um so the green dots on
this map here are uh the locations of
all of the current rdc's census began
originally there was just one RDC it was
at census uh around the time that I was
on the job market in 1999 that was the
only place pretty much you could access
these data um since then uh census has
been building out this network you can
see it kind of roughly corresponds to
concentrations of academics around the
country um and census is interested in
building out this network even more um
uh and an RDC is a main uh kind of uh uh
Center for accessing the data census as
part of its model of expansion has also
been allowing uh branches to be
established under an existing RDC Yale
has been a member since 2006 of the
Consortium that founded the New York
research data center uh Princeton's in
that Columbia is in that the FED is in
that um that's located in Baro College
uh So currently I go down to New York
once a week to use the data there um uh
we applied uh successfully to become a
branch of the New York RDC in New Haven
there's another branch of the New York
RDC in Cornell um and uh with generous
funding from koh's we're going to have
this Branch RDC show up on hill housee
in one of the econ Department buildings
um it's if you if you the cost is about
$200,000 to set up this Branch that's
mostly due to um the costs within Yale
of making the space secure um and then
about 50,000 chunk of it is it equipment
that we get from Yale servers that I
mean uh dumb terminals that kind of
point back to
um
Washington um the floor plan uh not sure
how interest you the floor plan but the
thing is the center looks like this the
top of it is an an office for the
administrator that has to oversee the
branch and then that bigger room is a
space with six terminals um six
terminals depending on whether you've
done stuff like this before may seem
like a lot or a little uh the New York
office has uh eight Terminals and I go
down there I've almost never seen it
full we're hoping that six will be a
pretty good number um um but we'll see
how that goes um the key thing to
realize if you don't really know it is
that since Yale's a member of an RDC
Consortium anyone at Yale actually can
access the data uh for free uh given
that we're already paying the dues for
that and that'll be true for the branch
as well so really the only cost for the
user is to kind of get a proposal
approved by the Census
Bureau um by the way I wanted to put
this slide in we need an administrator
um and so if you have any ideas uh
around the room please let me know or
Sandra Greer no uh our administrator the
the administrator of a typical RDC is a
relatively senior fellow usually it's uh
PhD the one in New York is a PhD in
economics for example um we only need a
junior administrator someone working 20
hours a week um the hitch is that uh
that person who is the administrator has
to be an in a census employee that
they're not going to be a Yale employee
and so the way this works is we're
looking around campus for someone that
might be interested in this job uh it's
20 hours a week it's very flexible most
of the time you don't have to do much um
uh um and the way it'll work is we'll
identify a candidate hopefully within
the next month or two and then we
specify the parameters of that
individual and give those parameters to
census and then census hires that person
after a search for that individual um uh
and then that person becomes a regular
census employee and is on a employee
track within census um so any ideas
would be very welcome um so that was my
little pitch for a um administrator okay
uh now you know what an RDC is how can
you get access to an RDC um as I said
these are proprietary data they're
governed by a whole host of laws which
if you get access you have to learn
about the laws and all the ways you can
be punished by violating them um so I
won't bore you with all those details
but it's restricted by law and one of
the things that you may not be that
familiar with but which is an integral
part of getting access to census data is
your your research proposal not only has
to have the usual intellectual Merit the
census propos the proposed research also
has to have a benefit for census and the
reason for that is by law census can
only kind of provide access to these
data if they're in part of an effort to
improve the quality of the data at
census and so when one writes an a
proposal for research at the Census
Bureau big part of what you write in
your well a big in terms of um
importance not so big in terms of words
uh part of The Proposal that you write
is how you're going to benefit the
Census Bureau um and they have these
great quotes on their website about
about this uh and they're they're quite
I mean listening to the presentations
today um they should sound very familiar
uh you know census collects all of this
information and one of the best ways to
figure out if the information is correct
and make sense um is to give it to users
and see what they find and uh if you
have proposed research you'll be using
the data uh and in part checking the
quality of data because of all the
things that you're looking for um and so
they take that um that's taken pretty
seriously um and I should say it's not
that hard to uh come up with ways to um
improve uh census's data to put into
proposal and again when one develops a
proposal in conjunction with the
administrator of an RDC that guide you
along in terms of how to word this um
okay and then uh then there's the normal
the rest of the bullet points there are
the normal uh criteria another
consideration uh is the again I said the
major cost of getting involved with
sensus data is actually getting the
access and this varies the time it takes
from kind of deciding you want to start
working on a proposal uh to getting the
proposal approved and then getting your
security clearance for using the data
which isn't that onerous but is a step
um it takes about a year that that can
sometimes get longer that sometimes gets
shorter depending upon Staffing and how
things are going in DC and whether
there's a budget crisis Etc um but think
about a year half a year to a year to
get
access um if you want more information I
put these up uh if you want more
information you just Google Center for
economic studies consensus Bureau and
you'll get all these websites um they'll
describe all of these data
sets Okay that's mostly what I was going
to go through uh I have appendic slid
want to know more but I figured I would
leave that for questions either in this
form or you can come up afterwards or
send me an email or something and I'm
happy to uh give you more info
[Applause]
thanks so if anyone has any questions we
have just somebody
down thank you uh excuse me do you
provide access to high performance
Computing form of Yale at the same time
on the same stations to use I mean for
analytics to run application to execute
different analytics do you have do you
provide uh access access to high
performance Computing on the same
stations in order not to copy data or
such a thing yeah
so so all of the it infrastructure is
provided at census and uh so they have
uh the server Network and all the
software that is most often used you
know sta mat lab whatever um I wouldn't
characterize as a high-speed Computing
Network and there's no way to kind of
take the data from where they are so you
you know you're kind of using the the it
infrastructure that they have and you're
actually using it on the networks that
are holding the copies of so what sort
of you know high performance Computing
Farm do they provide the Census Bureau I
mean yeah I'm not sure about the
technical details it's kind of I think a
standard Unix type setup it's not one
that's hyper you know like the highspeed
Clusters that we it's not like that data
without analysis ability I mean they
could always add that I think if there
were enough demand to to to do that they
would add it um um right now it seems to
be pretty adequate I mean given I've
been doing research there for like 10
years it seems pretty adequate for the
the man that I've had okay thank you
yeah follow-up
question how B is this data oh um uh
okay so there are I tell about dat I
know the there are five and a half
million private establishments in the
United States um so one of the data one
of the data sets the LBD which tracks
all private establishment United States
has about 5 million observations you
know and then a whole bunch of fields
for that observation across years going
back to 1977 so data sets range the data
sets I work with about a gigabyte or so
when you put things together um no
problem kind of manipulating those data
sets I think
uh you can't always do that for example
in one statistical package but you could
always move to SAS or something if it
gets honorous so it's that kind of
excuse me follow up so um you mentioned
that they provide this ahrq data which
is hcop data for uh probably all of the
states and just for one state California
edcub data that I'm working with one of
the three databases it gets like uh
seven gigabytes for just four four years
five years so for the entire United
States it should be like more than 100
gigabytes or 300 gab I don't know but so
I've I've seen people running jobs where
they for example to the extent that I
can see the memory being pulled it's
like 150 200 gigabytes that they're
using for those projects they run those
projects I'm still doing my project with
a smaller and it seems to work rela fine
I mean I've never used that stuff so
maybe those you know their researchers
at Yale who are using those data set I
think in public health I'm not sure
where you are and so they might know
better for example what the what that
experience is like when they put all
those things in one file or try to
manipulate them so we are in out uh
Center for outcome research and
evaluation and we obtain data by
directly from a hrq
organization uh so I don't know much
about the medical data but I uh I mean
so I don't I can't characterize what's
there and I can't character as a user
experience but I could find out more or
point you to where to find out more if
you need to thank you yeah
sure um I have a quick question about
the restricted data and what you can uh
what you can do with it if anything
outside the terminals that you were
talking about so does all the analysis
happen at the terminals or is there a
certain point in the process of
analyzing the data where it is
anonymized enough that you can you know
take it on a flash drive and do your own
work with it um so the way it works is
anything that they figured out how to
anonymize they usually make into some
kind of public use data set um the way
it works is all your analysis uh which
is not anonymized you can work with at
the census and then you have to um any
results of that analysis that you want
to take out but not the data you can't
take the data out have to pass
disclosure the rules for disclosure
themselves are not disclosable so um
but to give you a sense of you know if I
run regressions of how firms have
reacted to something you basically have
to not be able to in any way identify a
single firm so if you're doing the kind
of high level stuff that I do it's never
really an issue the the users that run
into issues or if you want to kind of
summarize things happening at the census
Block Level or something where there
might be like a few people living there
that's an issue so the basic rule is you
do your analysis there and then you
present results in an aggregate enough
way that you can pass disclosure so
regressions and regression coefficients
are usually fine that goes you hand
those in along with a disclosure report
and the analysis of why it doesn't
violate disclosure it goes to a
disclosure review board they bless it or
they don't if they bless it they send
you the stuff and then think of that as
getting a bunch of regression tables in
the mail like in Excel or something like
that in
email great
thanks hi so leandros I have a question
for you about uh so you're in the
department of electrical engineering but
you're a Yin affiliate and what we
understand Yin is doing what we've heard
presentations last year at the day of
data was a lot about human social
networks so how do the sensor networks
that you're talking about sort of relate
to that is it really transferable like
the network of a sensor is the same as
the network of a person are you going to
be working more on human social networks
too so what are you going to do at yens
uh well um I think it happens in many
levels first first uh at the abstract
levels the the models uh the network
models for um the interaction of humans
in social networks and uh the network
models for interaction let's say of
wireless devices have a lot of common
aspects um for instance the questions of
how they scale and uh what are the
attributes that affect the the
scaling um
are answered by the same mathematics
essentially so the the abstract models
are similar uh the other is that um
there is uh a lot of interaction between
the two um in um uh the real world as
well for instance um a current Trend in
wireless networks that is a cognitive uh
radio as it is called which is uh which
tries to find very uh effective ways for
using the radio spectrum taking into
consideration interdependencies between
the different
devices um can um exploit uh a lot of
input that is generated from The Social
Network that is uh relationships of uh
people as they can be deduced from The
Social Network they they can provide uh
information on
How likely it is uh one to try to access
the radio spectrum at the same time with
somebody else and this is information
that is very useful for the design of uh
the radio access protocol itself so this
is just two examples of uh how the two
are um related and um not only those two
for instance the
presentation we have seen earlier by
Mark
garstein uh pointed to to some other uh
attributes uh which uh relate the
networks that um appear in the genomic
in the genomes with uh the netork the
networking structures that capture
either the social networks or the
communication Networks so uh I think
that's a main idea for the creation of
The Institute is to focus on these
commonalities and uh take advantage of
those to progress all these different
fields okay if there are no more
questions there is a snack break so if
you were looking for snacks earlier they
are now in the hallway and we will
reconvene promptly at 4:05 thank you uh
to Professor shot and tulis who gave our
last
session and at 4:05 we'll be back with
Kathy O'Neal for our final keynote thank
you
I will be introducing our uh second
keyter Kathy O'Neal um before I do I do
want to remind everyone that there are
evaluation forms on the tables please
fill those out and you can drop them off
at the Box on the way
out um Kathy O'Neal is director of the
lead program in data practices at
Columbia University graduate school of
Journalism and she's employed as data
science consultant at Johnson's Johnson
research Labs she attended UC Berkeley
as an undergraduate earned a PhD in
mathematics from Harvard and afterward
held positions in mathematics
Departments of MIT and Barnard College
doing research in arithmetic algebraic
geometry yes she's co-author of the book
that was mentioned today already doing
data science Straight Talk from the
front line and also very importantly
she's author of one of my personal
favorite blogs mathbabe dorg and if you
don't look at it you should and here's
Kathy thanks thank
you oh my God I don't know about you
people but I hate this room because I
can't see people around here and I mean
and I I love the uh organizers don't get
me wrong but the room isn't very good
for interaction I'm a very interactive
person so please feel free to come sit
at this chair over here or close by or
or motion to me cuz I don't like
speaking by myself over here I'm feeling
lonely already don't make me cry okay so
I worked in arithmetic algebraic
geometry that was really pure
mathematics and then in 2006 for some
ridiculous reason which I might go into
and you can ask me to go into I decided
to become a Quant at a hedge fund
exactly right before the credit crisis
um So I entered and got a front row seat
at the dysfunction that was our
financial system from 2007 to
201 um and then I left in disgust but I
by the way just want to say I loved the
data oh my God I fell in love with data
was very sexy I loved the analysis I
loved feeling like I was learning stuff
I didn't love other aspects of Finance
I'll bring it bring them up a little bit
later because I do think we have lessons
to learn from Finance um another thing I
want to mention is that I think data
science Big Data we've all complained
about the rhetoric around that and I'll
I'll do I'll do the same um kind of
started in finance not really it started
in a lot of different places but um when
people talk about big data and data
science I think Well Finance was the
first data
science and other people might say no
astrophysics was the first data science
and I would say well you know a lot of
astrophysicists became quants on hedge
at you know hedge funds on Wall Street
there was basically no data science
there was no analysis really of data on
Wall Street until like the black shs and
stuff and like the 70s and the 80s and
the bond market so and then all these
scientists came to to to um Wall Street
and they started trying out different
things from their different fields and
so it was like the first I guess what
I'm saying is the first
interdisciplinary data oriented science
happened on on Wall Street um so that's
one of the reasons I'm going to say we
can learn lessons from Finance because
that failed spectacularly in certain
ways in other ways it didn't so after
that I left I went to I decided to like
do something good for the world so I
went and worked as a data scientist it
took as much work as rewriting the my
title on my resume to get a job in um in
advertising startup tech company in New
York City where I was analyzing um the
propensity to click on ads for people
who you know had Macs versus PCS and by
the way people who have Macs have more
money did anyone know that um so after a
few months of working in data science I
was like holy crap this stuff is really
interesting and also kind of alarming in
in various ways so I got kind of into
thinking about it in a meta way rather
than just doing my job I wanted to think
like what is this is this a thing to
what extent is it a thing can we Define
it that's where I wrote that book doing
data science it was an e effort to try
to describe the thing that is data
science and whether it deserves its own
field um my conclusion is that it does
um we can argue about that um and then I
started also being kind of just like a a
skeptic a data skeptic which is actually
a hard A Hard Road to to walk down if
you work in New York City around a lots
lots and lots and lots of um Venture
Capital funding um so we'll talk about
that a little bit but just to make the
point that um there's there's a lot of
Kool-Aid being drunk around there so
guess who likes Skeptics journalists
journalists are actually kind of awesome
in that way they might actually go
overboard and like negative news more
than they should but one thing that was
cool about recently being hired by the
journalism School of Columbia to start a
data journalism program is that they
were like totally embracing my skep CRI
ISM for the first time so that was kind
of nice so that was what I did this
summer I was the program director for a
data journalism program that turned
journalists into Data journalists that
was the attempt anyway and I think we um
did a pretty good job we had some
amazing projects we taught them python
we taught them how to do data scraping
we taught them how to manipulate data we
taught them how to use algorithms we did
everything on the ec2 Amazon Cloud um we
had instances out there we made them
bigger when we had bigger data um so the
way I tell my husband the the summer
went was the first half of the summer we
we we taught them to think of themselves
as
Gods because they came in thinking that
anyone who could do data analysis was a
God and the second half of the summer we
taught them that they weren't Gods
because the second half of the summer we
focus instead on skills we focused on
other kinds of literacy so I think of
this functional literacy as like skills
like can you do python can you write a
code will it work will you get an answer
can you clean code can you put things in
Panda data frames the second half of the
summer we thought about well what else
could you have done and how would that
have changed the
result and we talked about to what
extent are the default settings on Excel
forcing you to think in a certain way
that was um it was a really great
experience and I was um happy
to sort of not only teach a group of of
young bright-eyed bushy tail journalists
how to how to do stuff but how to think
about
stuff and so that's one of the reasons
I'm here because I think that's an
important part so I was asked to come
pitch a Yale um data Science Institute
that's what I'm going to do and I'm also
GNA actually tell I'm first going to
tell you why I think you should have
one although you already might know but
I'm going to tell you why I think you
should have one and I'm going to be very
passionate about it because that's what
I do and then I'm going to tell you like
the Ticky Tac details of stuff because I
interviewed a couple people over at YY
at Columbia Institute for data science
and engineering which has had ups and
downs it was announced to Exist by
Bloomberg I want to say three years ago
but it's something like three years ago
and it's it's taken a while and we'll
we'll talk about why that
happened so
why okay here's the thing when I went
into um the hedge fund it was like
really
really intense and proprietary and I
wasn't allowed to talk to anyone
including my own officemate about what I
was working on I was working with Larry
Summers on some some project I'll tell
you guys now but not after the talk um
just kidding uh but we had one thing we
did have in our group which was the
Futures group was like this kind of
weekly seminar on on ways of thinking
about modeling um run by my boss Steve
strong who is really really a very good
modeler and he was a basian so we talked
about um prior beliefs and what were our
priors and just like the young woman who
talked about the um EP score or epos
score whatever it was um she talked
about downweighting data that you are
less certain of we did that we also
downweighted data that was
old um that the the extent to which we
downweighted data on you know what was
the halflife of a of a piece of data
like if it's a week old is it old news
or does it depend on the market is it
different in bonds than it is in
Commodities that kind of thing that's
the kind of conversation we'd have and
we called that Lambda often when we were
down weting old data we had this kind of
we we didn't even take averages of
things we took um you know averages
weighted by the the sort of
downweighting Lambda variable so that
was called our you know Lambda and it
was considered our belief in how much we
lost interest in in the data as it got
older as it became less
certain this was called a prior this is
called I I actually should have said I
should have said the overburdened Lambda
because what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to demonstrate that I then went
into data science and I found two other
ways of Imagining the same parameter
called
Lambda in a totally different context
but it was exactly the same thing it was
Lambda it was even called Lambda so
there there was some kind of like
magical undercurrent of understanding
that this is all the same thing but I
found in machine learning that people
did I think what was called Ridge
regression and then there was another
maybe a different part of computer
science that they did they did L2
regression okay those both had lambdas
and I don't remember which one is which
um but they were they were two different
names for the same
thing and it was
it it ended up being in exactly the same
usage as I I would have used my belief
Lambda in a in a regression and just a
simple multivariate
regression but it was thought of in a
totally different way so so it was
thought of for the most part so I'm
going to skip ahead in in one for one
slide for a moment in thought that you
would use it as a a insurance that your
algorithm would converge so you had some
kind of of you had some kind of I think
of it geometrically because I'm I'm a
geometer but you have some kind of space
and you're using some kind of Newton
algorithm to try to find some minimum
and you're like you know you're going to
find the minimum but is it a global
minimum or is it a local minimum and
you're like well if you tune Lambda if
lambda's high enough then it's forced to
be convex and then it's a global minimum
so whatever I just said I what I mean to
say is Lambda was used the same Lambda
used as a way of ensuring that your
algorithm would finish called the
convergence insurance I call it then at
the the some of the same people would
turn around and they would say well
that's that's how we know we have
convergence but actually we use Lambda
to tune our to optimize our algorithm so
we we sort of test our algorithm for
different lambdas and we see which one
gives us the most accurate result and
that's our Lambda so it's actually a
hyperparameter that people use to tune
their algorithms to optimize it for
their results does that make sense same
Lambda now I just want to make the point
that this Lambda which was being tuned
to optimize your results was definitely
not the same Lambda we
used at least in theory to sort of State
our belief because you know when you
state your belief you're not supposed to
tune it
afterwards um so I thought that was
pretty interesting because I'm like well
this is It's always called Lambda but
it's it's really literally meaning three
different things to three different
fields coming into this into this Miss
Mash of space called data
science and I think we can learn from
each
other so another example I came to and I
call these technical overlaps this is
the last one I'm I'm sure of it's a
technical overlap and it's an
interesting one and it's overburdening
one's poor little um Greek letter um but
the second one I'm not really sure of
but it's so fascinating to
me I was doing um a talk I went to
Berkeley to give a talk a math
colloquium and I I gave a talk talk
about recommendation engines because
they were like well can you talk about
something from data science because
everyone in math wants to learn data
science so I was like okay I'll talk
about recommendation engines and one of
the things I wrote about in my book is I
don't know if you guys heard about
hun.com it's kind of a fun story you go
to hun.com and they and you get asked 20
yes or no questions and at the end of 20
questions they know everything about you
and it's like really really depressing
because it means we only have 20 Di
iions of
interestingness like you know basically
chick flick or dick flick you know like
basically that's with the first one are
you a man or a woman that and then it
gets like less interesting from there
but then but then that's defines you
pretty much pretty much accurately after
that they tell you what kind of i iPad
you want or whatever they tell you what
phone you want and and they're right
it's really frustrating so that's a
recommendation
engine um that I learned about using
alternatingly squares it's called the
latent factor model and then I was like
looking around for other recommendation
engines to show the mathematicians in
Berkeley and someone from Spotify who's
a friend of mine um told me oh you
should use the ones we use they come
from this paper um from Google that
Google News if you guys know what Google
news is um everyone knows what Google
news is but I don't think anybody uses
it anymore but anyway
so they actually Ed there's two there's
couple it's a really great paper
actually beautiful
but one of the things they use is a
latent topic model the other thing is a
co- visitation model which is also very
sexy as a model uses Minash
um but anyway going back to the latent
topic model um that so the latent factor
model let me start at the latent factor
the first one requires you understand um
the sort of igen values igen spaces of
of matrices you sort of you rank you
sort of sort the IG values in in terms
of size and you take the biggest ones
and those are the most important ones in
terms of your variance and so it's
basically depends on a factorization of
matrices so but then at the end of the
day you choose a number of a number of
Dimensions that you actually give a
about and if your hun.com is 20 and then
you're like I give a about 20
things and then I can infer the rest
okay so the first 20 dimensions of human
nature are important than everything
else is
Trivial it's just idiosyncratic I should
say
um then okay so then I looked into this
paper and I thought I understood the
latent factor model pretty well I looked
in this paper I found the latent topic
model which was had its own technical
name plsi which you can look up and it
was based on a statistical model with
various assumptions about um
distributions and stuff but at the end
of the day you chose 20 you chose a
number could be
20 and then you did and then you had the
same number of variables as you had in
the latent factor model you I could even
tell you how many variables like
basically two very elongated rectangular
matrices of size 20 and the number of
people involved or 20 and the number of
items involved so in the case of Spotify
you're the items are songs and the
people are people and in the lat and
topic model the items are news articles
that you may not have read you may have
read and the people are people so you
have these two really long matrices and
this the choice of
20 and then you have some
arithmetic to update this when you get
new data so in and like that they were
presented in very different ways they
were optimizing to very different
looking things one of them was
multiplicative one of them was additive
but at the end of the day I was like you
know what I think these are the same
algorithm I just think that if you if
you make specific choices
for um for this distribution like
gaussian or whatever I think this will
come come down to the very same
algorithm and when I gave this talk in
Berkeley I just asked the audience is
this the same algorithm or not and some
guy who's a fifth year graduate student
in statistics is like yeah that's the
same algorithm and he gave me a
reference but I couldn't understand it
so I'm not really sure it's true but
here's my point my point is it's
probably true or if it's not exactly the
same algorithm it's really close and
it's coming from machine learning on the
latent factor model or even mathematics
I'm not exactly sure versus statistics
pure up up and straight straight up
statistics and it's like we should know
this we have these really large
companies depending on these algorithms
that are essentially the same thing or
or or if they're not it's an interesting
fact that we should be talking about
which no one is talking
about okay so I'm guess what I'm saying
is that there is technical overlap in at
least in industry and I'm sure in
academics as well that uses different
language that uses different even
different assumptions but but they're
the same technical thing and the fact
that they came they were they people
Came Upon them in totally different ways
is what makes them
interesting okay now I'm going to tell
you why we could never do this we can
never it's like get scared okay it's
never going to happen I'll explain why
so I spent as I told you the summer
working in journalism um at the
journalism school and I was doing like a
data Journal J ISM program for
journalists and I was constantly talking
to the computer science department
because many of my students are now
taking computer science classes and
basically and I'm not going to this is
an exaggeration and I apologize to
anyone who gets offended by this but
everyone in journalism hated me and
everyone in the computer science
department hated me and I'm cool with
that because I've got a thick skin but
there is a clash of cultures and it's
real so let me explain what I
mean journalism
and I'm just I'm going to it's
cartoonish what I'm saying okay but just
just there's an element of Truth to what
I'm about to say and again not saying it
to offend I'm saying it to clarify but
journalists care about the human story
human face on the
story what is who is that person that
who's the
victim if it's there's no victim there's
no story and that's not always true but
in traditional journalism it often is
true they think of the data person
generally speaking as a service person
somebody who like does the infrographic
and like gets paid by the
hour in computer science you have the
complimentary blind spot where you have
people who are focused on Fast um
efficient algorithms large scale um you
have it's very
Macho um you have to really understand
like you know web protocols to even get
coffee in the
lounge um and they're just like why
human messy stories individual stories
why who cares not relevant so I what I'm
saying is like to try to to try to bring
together even those two departments for
the sake of this emerging field of J
data journalism it's not easy but at the
same time well so this is my obstacle
slide so I don't have to I don't have to
give you the good news yet um let me
give you another example though and this
goes to um a a woman named Noemi alidad
who's in bioinformatics at Colombia and
is also heading the um Health Center at
the um Institute for data science and
engineering Columbia so I interviewed
her because now I have journalistic
approaches to everything which is fun um
so I interviewed her this week about
this talk and I said so how's it going
uh y's 3 years old how are things and
she was like well things are looking up
but at the beginning was really hard
because there was this culture clash
between bioinformatics and computer
science and I was like well tell me
about it and I don't want to make the Cs
guys Bad Guys by the way I love computer
scientists my parents are both computer
scientists but she was basically said a
similar kind of thing um she said you
know the computer scientists are like
well you no the at the beginning not
anymore at the beginning the computer
scientist approach was we don't need to
know the health stuff the medicine we
know how to mind data just give us the
data stop talking to us just give it to
us we will do it and we will solve
medicine and then the people um in
medicine were like these guys don't know
anything about the context they don't
understand missing values they don't
understand the bias um they don't
understand the difference between this
population and that population and I
already know how to do my analysis leave
me alone so we have the same kind of
complimentary blind spot in the
cultures um and complimentary values so
it's a real thing and that's within
Academia
so if if you wanted and I I don't want
to just have a data Science Institute at
Yale for just academics like
theoretically ideally it would include
people from industry and it would
include people from government who are
doing Civic data stuff and with open
data and all that stuff and we've heard
that from them today as well and we have
that same problem there is that you have
this complete you have the blind
spots um and you do value different
things um and and I don't I don't mean
like like I get paid for this I don't
get paid for that I that's the next
slide this slide I mean you actually
dismiss the other person's
expertise so part of a data Science
Institute is creating a community where
you talk enough about what your act
actual problems of your analysis are
until you have respect for that person's
expertise because it is a question of
respect um and by the way just to give
away um the ending of that story with
noomi she told me that in the last year
and a half um people have been writing
large grants together from the medical
school and the engineering school and
that through the grant writing process
and sometimes they got the grant
sometimes they didn't but when they got
the grants especially starting to
actually work together on these large
scale projects have given them an
immense amount of mutual respect so
those initial problems are fading away
so they can be
overcome however I'm that doesn't keep
me from having a second slide of
obstacles and by the way again raise
your hands if you disagree with me or
want to add something because I like
interaction um I just want to make the
point that I've been an academic so I
know what the problem the actual
limitations of an everyday life as an
academic are and that you're
you're incentivized to think on a daily
daily basis of publishing
papers um and getting funded whereas if
you're a policy maker you want or
somebody in government you're you're
actually trying to affect policy so I
worked at the um I worked at the mayor's
office under Bloomberg for six months in
Health and Human Services working with
um homeless data so I can talk about
that but like it's a very different
approach to what you decide to talk
about um or what you avoid talking about
I think is a better way of approaching
that um to when you're in when you're
working in proprietary startup land
which I did um for a few years sometimes
it's a marketing technique you do
sometimes you are literally just the
Quant in the corner as you know hey we
got quants they're phds right there um
sometime so sometimes you just have to
exist and that's that's that's not
really data science but other times when
you do actual data science what leaks
out is um is more about PR than than
than really about
science um and sometimes you you
actually are trying to inform the public
and we saw an example of that again with
the environmental score which was
great but but I just want to make the
point that all the people that I wish
would come and be part of the data
Science Institute at Yale or whatever
you call it um they all have different
metrics of success so it's it it would
you'd have to find a way through you
know however it gets funded or however
people get brownie points or however
people get what they want you have to
figure out a way for everyone to have a
reason to be there and and of course
part of it would be that they they
learned how to uh do better science
so here's the thing the really urgent
reason we need this is because there is
no nobody doing it quite like you could
do it here you guys have a Yale law
school which is an incredible place um
they already have something called the
internet and Society Center um so
they're already talking about ethics and
standards um for for for doing data in
in industry but it could be a wider
discussion as well we have an incredible
amount of complexity going on it's it's
almost impossible for nonata experts to
understand what's actually happening in
Google or
Facebook um and it affects policy so I
went to um a I went to a house
subcommittee meeting on big data and
analytics about a year
ago and I was really unimpressed with um
the people that were talking there and
their their approach to explaining how
big data was important and how everybody
doesn't mind their privacy violations
and it was staffed by the head of
research at IBM um and other um industry
Representatives so it was it's just a
lopsided discussion here I'm not saying
those people don't deserve to talk I'm
just saying that what the policy makers
are hearing is incredibly biased towards
commercial interests and that doesn't
have to be
true um I'll just say that again
commercial interests this man said that
privacy is dead and like he shouldn't
have the last word on that he has too
much money coming in to think otherwise
so we should have some people thinking
about data in a critical way that don't
get rich off of it don't get rich off of
um obscuring what's actually going
on I also wanted to if I'm not radical
enough yet let me just say um I really
think we could take some lessons from
the financial crisis the way I look at
the financial crisis as I said the
finance was was Big Data was data
science before um before data science
was a term and one of the things they
made uh there's a lot of ways you can
think about the financial crisis but one
way you can think about it is that it
was a siloed mistake that we had
different characters who were aware or
semi- aware of bad things happening in
the mortgage
Market but we in particular well but not
nobody was aware of everything that's
one of the problems unless unless there
were people who were aware of everything
and in case in which case those
people but most people were just aware
that what they were doing locally was
kind of sketchy but they were making a
lot of money off of it and they didn't
they didn't think they didn't have to
think um in a more Global sense so it
was a question of siloed information and
in particular particular and the most
massive Silo was between fin Wall Street
and the regulators and that's a mistake
I think that cost the the the the people
of this the taxpayers the people who
lost their homes Etc that was a is that
was the repercussions for that so I
guess what I'm saying is I think what we
can do when it comes to Big Data data
science is we can make better science
but we can also make sure that we are
not like screwing the average person
with the big data models that that we
already have by keeping in touch with
who's actually working on the data and
keeping in touch with regulators and
policy makers about what that actually
looks like and what the real risks are
and I have seen progress on this front
one of the most um impressive things
I've seen lately is Obama's Big Data
report um with podesta who went around
the country and talked to people about
various civil rights um violations that
are potentially happening with big data
so great to see that but it's like just
one report and we should have an
Institute devoted to
that or not only to that but that should
be one of the things that so where is
that conversation going to happen I mean
that's another way of looking at it it's
not going to happen at Facebook Facebook
is spending millions of dollars lobbying
against the European privacy laws it's
not going to happen it's going to happen
in an institution but it has to be an
institution that has enough actual
information about the way data is used
that they can have an informed
discussion so I I feel like an Institute
maybe in the centered in the Law Center
but maybe here um I mean maybe at the
Yale data in um Institute could invite
policy makers I'll get i'll get to that
in a
second so what would a data Science
Institute look like so what do the I I'm
I'm kind of a party planner so the first
thing I think about is parties with um
wine but we could have a colloquium
first um
it has to be a community is what I'm
saying you it's the way you get people
to figure out I use Lambda for tuning
parameter oh I use a Lambda for that you
know the way you do that is you get
people to talk to each other and the way
you get people to talk to each other is
you you get them together in the same
physical location and you talk about
your research um and you also you also
share food and wine and you promote
cross-disciplinary research with um
support um from Grants
um from you know we we've seen today a
lot of a lot of potential um support for
this kind of thing so that's awesome you
need a place a space to work in so the
Columbia um ity has like they're
building out space in the north west
corner of this of Campus um right now
they don't have space so it's not
absolutely critical if as long as you
get to like rent rooms and stuff in on
your campus theoretically ideally you'd
have conferences devoted to the stuff um
you know with really good speakers that
know how to cross disciplinary lines and
know how to like think a little bit
higher level about what works and what
doesn't work in their field like a kind
of um what are those words the survey
papers but survey survey talks I would
love to see that about data like um data
management and data analytics in a given
field and again I think workshops for
policy makers because the policy makers
are not actually bad people they're just
really busy and don't have any details
at all so the
lobbyists tell them what to think
because that's what lobbyists do but
lobbyists are you should think about it
this way lobbyists are performing a
function that other people could perform
which is giving them information that
they want to hear they love to hear
information from people who are academic
and
trustworthy
or they might not come themselves but
they'll send their AIDS and and
congressman's AIDS are really smart um I
think there's a huge need for
educational initiatives which a data
Science Institute would provide that
would be probably the easiest thing to
set up actually is setting up you know
Masters and PHD programs um at least the
very the first semester you could you
could hire some people to teach graduate
classes I actually think that um this
concept of numerical and computational
literacy should be at the core of the
curriculum and for undergraduates the
stuff I did with my journalism students
this summer I could have done with
freshmen at college and it would have
helped them it would have helped them in
a lot of ways so I don't see why
18-year-olds aren't doing that and I
don't see why data Science Institute
wouldn't um wouldn't take the initiative
on that and it would be a really popular
popular class I would expect I also
think that you know I you heard me talk
about this um interaction with the
public the public is at is a stakeholder
here and I think the stake the the some
of the public really wants to understand
this stuff and where are they going to
go for that so it's not just about your
the undergraduates although I know this
is a very undergraduate focused campus
um which is great I also think that the
general public should we should have
like um information for the general
public on how you know what is it you
know what does Facebook actually know
about you and what are they allowed to
do with that that something you could
Google for but it would would be a lot
more um interesting and effective if we
had like really good speakers explaining
that I think the um a data science
intitute would ideally provide resources
to the academic researchers so this
would be another reason for them to want
to be part of it Computing
infrastructure we talked a lot about
today um we have basically ad hoc
solutions to Computing problems in every
Department if not every research lab and
the question of how to think about that
in a more holistic sense and like how to
solve that problem um probably save
money overall I don't know how the the
actual funding would work with
that I need a few staff to organize the
colloquium and the wine um I said you
need space you need money I mean ideally
you'd have so um Colombia started out
with $50
million um although that was all fake in
various ways um I think I think in in
the following sense that um they they
didn't actually get any money from
Bloomberg they just got like a decrease
on their sewer taxes for like 15 years
until it was worth $50 million or
something um so it's kind of a weird
situation but I the the point is that
you can hire people for the Institute um
and you could do it one of two ways you
could hire people for the Institute like
you could hire a person be part of our
Institute or you could hire someone in
engineering or in computer science or in
um biometric uh bioinformatic research
and then they' be joint with the
Institute that's the model they use at
Colombia and then just for people who
are interested I also found out that
they when they have grants coming in
some percentage of it gets siphoned off
into the um Institute so that's how it's
all about the money I know that um also
the way they do it in at um at YY is
they have um outside Partners so they
they have like Partnerships contracts
that they've now they've now um firmed
up where they have like certain things
they offer larger companies like IBM or
GE or Accenture and they have different
kinds of contracts for startups because
startups want different things than big
companies do and they also offer
different things so big companies offer
money they want things like expertise in
a certain general area and education in
that area so they might send some people
from IBM to columia to learn about this
kind of field um startups um want to
take students to get um internships and
they want to be able to call someone up
and ask them a very specific machine
learning question which is a very
different kind of ask anyway so but
establishing those kinds of Partners
would be an important part of an um
Institute for data science um and you
know it's a different ecosystem in New
Haven than it is in New York City I
realize that but I I think there are
partners it just might be more on the
side of policy or a different a
different um industry than than exactly
the same thing in New
York so this is where I get to the part
where I don't really have opinions but I
do think these are important questions
to ask um so how would you actually set
this up like who would even be included
in this I mean from my experience in
journalism and um data Science and
Mathematics I I'm getting more and more
to the point where I think a broad
definition is good like you do want
people from all sorts of departments
that are interested in this now at the
same time you probably don't want to
just get everyone in the room and say
hey what do we do you want to have like
some projects in mind or you might have
themes you might have like for these two
years here's what we're going to do like
here's an idea for for three years we're
going to focus on people who actually
analyze the data and how do we analyze
the data how do we collect our data and
how do we manage our data and then the
next three years like we can talk with
people who don't analyze the data but we
they do interact with the results of our
analysis like not not the medical
researchers but the doctors who use the
results of our analysis and that would
be a different project and the three
years after that you might want to
interact with um you want to bring in
people who are impacted by your analysis
because there's all sorts of different
ways of thinking about data science and
how it interacts with the world and of
course you could be thoughtful and set
up your data Science Institute to be
itself data driven so you can see what
works and what doesn't and what in what
inspires people and what brings in
Grants and what actually seems to in a
long-term sense um create um good
research so couple lessons I got from
Chris Wiggins before I left any kind of
and he's on the Executive Board of ity
he's also on the education board and on
the entrepreneurial board so he set up
Partnerships with on with the startups
um any kind of mission that you create
Mission attached to a data Science
Institute has to be novel has there has
to be something you offer that you don't
see at Cornell um the the new Cornell
Tech or you NYU which also has a new
thing or ity um it has to be coherent it
has to be doable I didn't write that
down but it has to be doable um and as
and there's an inverse relationship
between size and velocity so one of the
reasons in the end that iy took three
years to start making progress is
because they started out massive their
first um campaign was to hire 75 faculty
so that you know as if you try to do
boil the ocean it takes a while so I
don't know what that means it might all
it means is you have to be patient
depending on how big you want to be also
obviously there has to be a good
incentive structure in place as I think
I might have said the funding for ity
went into the engineering school and all
the SCH schools are siloed in terms of
their money so there's Arts and Sciences
there's the medical school and you and
they had to think pretty hard about how
to get medical researchers interested in
doing this and it's about
money and finally I just want to make
the point that well earlier from one of
the speakers we um heard this idea that
that when the data from different fields
sits next to each other we will
magically find connections I don't think
that's true going back to my original
examples people use different vocabulary
even if they've come to the same
mathematical or analytical approach they
use different words I was thinking once
of um building a huge network of
mathematics papers like connected in
directed graph like this one was
referenced by that one and this is
referenced by that one or maybe not um
just explicit references it would be
even better if I just said topics these
are related because they have some of
the same using natural language
processing to say these are the related
to each other in topic and then I
realized that that wouldn't actually get
me where I wanted to go because what I
really want to go is I want to say when
are two math two math papers related in
ideas that's not the same thing as words
and that's the what we've learned is
that people who come at the same ideas
but they have totally different
vocabulary that's not going to happen
through a machine learning algorithm
that's only going to happen through a
community so the connectors so El so
Noemi told me that in the last three
years she's she's become the connector
between the medical school and the
computer science department she knows
everyone there she knows what they do
and when someone needs to know who can I
talk to that does this she knows who to
go to them to go to so you need
connectors so I just want to thank Chris
Wiggins and noemy for my interviewing um
them with Annoying questions and I'd
love to take questions
thanks
so we'll have a respondent first and
then take questions if we could so uh
let me introduce to you Steve gerin
Steve is the Deputy Provost for Science
and Technology as well as the Eugene
Higgins professor of physics and applied
physics his academic research is in
theoretical quantum physics his
portfolio includes a long list of things
including central campus science
departments the school of Forestry and
Environmental Studies
School of Engineering and applied
sciences and collaboration on science
strategy with the school of medicine and
a good partner for me in working in high
performance Computing
Steve well thank you Kathy for uh making
an interesting case for um for data
Science
Institute uh let me start by saying I've
met a large set of mathematicians and a
large set of people persons and until
today the intersection was a n
set um so I'm pleased to pleased to meet
you um so you've I mean I was struck by
sort of the the one slide where he used
the word
urgent
um uh about ethics standards policy and
complexity and and
perhaps universities are the last place
standing that can try to sit down and
think about some of these important
topics and in a way
that's um as unbiased as possible it's
certainly true that
we're the last Bastion for basic
curiosity driven research that has no
apparent like most basic research no
apparent applications and yet
decade after
decade uh surprising applications do
appear often on a rather long time scale
uh inconsistent with um corporate
budgeting and
federal annual budgeting
processes uh and of course a place like
Yale that has very strong Humanities and
uh 12 Prof uh professional schools and
excellent law school as you mentioned
um is a place that can think about some
of the implications for the human race
for some of these uh amazing tools that
the scientists and engineers and U
entrepreneurs are creating and
unleashing on
us
um and I one of my hopes is that
[Music]
um we can find a way to to bridge the
gap between the humanities and the
sciences and
Engineering uh with there's a stupendous
Gap uh and there we are programs in
digital Humanities and there some
humanists beginning to think about
statistics of use of words in different
books and so forth on ancient
texts um and we have a Computing in the
arts program but we still have a you
know a tremendous Gulf I mean when we we
had a Yale College faculty meeting about
grade inflation and an economist gave a
brilliant committee report saying
um that you know when you have inflation
in economics you change the currency and
so let's switch from a letter grade
system to a numerical grade system and
people won't be able to exactly map
between them and it'll be fine and and
the human humanist responded that I I
don't treat my students as numbers so we
have a we have a lot of work to to get
the whole Yale Community interested in
statistics and
numbers
um so I think um I had some slides but I
I don't need to show them I my last
slide a few slides about the data that's
pouring into
Yale um uh brought to you by the evil
side of mors law namely the automated
machines that can generate the data
faster and faster in the huge telescopes
and the genome sequencing Center that
does a human exome every eight
minutes uh and so forth but we are my my
final slide was on a topic sort of
related to your um proposal here which
is we we have under discussion active
discussion creation of a a Yale
Center
for research Computing or computational
science which could
have a big overlap with uh the proposal
you're making and we have an eye on some
space and uh even has an auditorium in
it uh we're thinking about a colloquium
series and getting people
together uh to talk is is and learn
about each other's um research problems
and finding commonalities or stealing
tricks that people have learned from
other fields uh is an incredibly
important activity and such things so uh
I think I have more uh just that bit of
commentary rather than questions for you
and let's let the audience ask the
questions thank you
again uh it's more this is more of a
suggestion than a question but uh it
seems to me that several people
including Kathy have commented on one of
the ways to bring multiple disciplines
to the same table and get them to start
struggling with communication is to have
a junior faculty member or a fellow
who's trying to do a project that's at
the interface between those two groups I
would say another way of doing that not
competing but a complimentary way is to
try to be to have teams trying to solve
a problem together uh and comparing and
contrasting the approaches they might
use from the disciplines that they were
trained in uh because then all that
language issue begins to be quite
apparent but also you begin to
understand how the mapping Works between
those two different two or three or four
diff different
disciplines so I I really uh liked
you're going through all the um elements
we' need for data science and to here I
thought that was fantastic but one
element I was was thinking about is one
of the things we really need for data
science is we need data and what data
would we work on in this data Science
Institute I mean where would that data
come from because you know I hear all
the time about all these interesting
things that Google and Facebook are
doing or that all the Wizards On Wall
Street are doing but I I don't know
where to get that data and you know I I
think where where do we get data to do
interesting things in data
science well there's two ways of
thinking about that it's a great
question um one of them is that the
people who are involved in your
in your Center would already have data
because they already have projects but
another answer is I think you get it
from
Facebook no because I mean Facebook has
a terrible PR problem right now because
they're so proprietary and they're doing
relatively um questionable activities
and I think if you said you know like a
public call for for examining certain
things about the way they act I think
they would probably give it to you
because they'd want to clear their
name I mean I think I think that's the
kind of thing you should do if you had
an Institute you should be challenging
Facebook to show that they're not doing
something that's wrong I think having an
Institute would also create a library of
data so to speak I mean and also an
understanding of where and how one goes
about getting that data whether you're
talking about EMR data or Facebook data
or I mean you learn from each other
about how to break through the barriers
I think I I thank you I mean and I think
the Librarians here have already
explained that they they want to help
curate that library of data I also
wanted to mention that I didn't put into
my slide deck that um an Institute like
this would not only give us a way of
collecting data but probably an
opportunity to build tools for research
that don't exist but should that would
promote um the kind of collaboration
that would be useful in an Institute so
I'm again that that's something that
would be novel I don't think that's
happening anywhere else um for the most
part most of the other um institutes
that I know of are in some sense like
vehicles for NIH and NSF grants more
than places where they're actually
building tools so I I like to say that I
couldn't have done my data journalism
program without the IPython notebook
it's a tool which is minimal it's it's
got to get better it will get better but
it's a it's a great tool and so it's the
first step towards something that we
could make that's really excellent that
would make research interactive and
collaborative yeah I was just going to
say um in regards to partnership with
external organizations I think that's
key to really making such a department a
success because to your earlier point
you really need that practical or that
real life data to analyze to to really
understand um how things will work in
the the real world so to speak um my
background is in baskets and Supermarket
retail analytics and it's very hard to
practice sort of data mining on those
millions and billions of rows of data
without actually using the actual basket
data that has come from a you know a
retailer so I think um having those
Partnerships is really key to to making
such a uh an Enterprise a
success
yeah I'd like to throw in that if you
make the data Science Institute to some
extent kind of like a consultancy that's
what Consultants do that's the model of
consultancy which is that you you get
paid to do jobs you don't own well the
question of Ip should be separate but
you you basically learn on the job how
to do certain things and and and then
you know how to do them and then you can
even build your own product to solve
that problem once and for all once
you've done this the same but in any
case that's another way you could learn
not only learn techniques but also get
access to
data like what we were talking about
freedom information type yes that's
right yeah I did want to throw in that I
I really think that the law school is
just such an incredible resource because
at the very least we were talking last
night um about the
um the medical records um and I think it
was eban mowan and his group that um
sued to get the VA open sourced like the
VA system of medical recordkeeping open-
sourced and like um I mean so in other
words lawyers are a partner in in doing
this the right way and the very least to
have them on your side so you can
threaten to sue if people do something
wrong or to get foyer requests which is
freedom information act requests which
is a trick I learned in journalism
school um yeah the if you were to have a
data Science Institute the thing I would
want from them would be I guess maybe
the consultancy aspect to be able to
come in and say I have data I need to
know how to Archive it and curate it and
make it accessible to others can you
people help me is that I I'm not sure I
really saw that on your slides is that
part of what you see is being the
function of that kind of Institute
well certainly it I some basic education
in that Arena would be part of the
educational initiative I mean part of it
any education and data science would be
that kind of thing but in terms of
whether there would be actually a
service where you can I think that's
what the Librarians already
are but I don't know that that's enough
well but they're going to up their game
so it's cool
okay
um I have a I have a question on on the
potential for collaboration between uh
academics and Industry when it comes to
things like
IRB um especially you mentioned the
Facebook studies that have been very
controversial and something that I've
been thinking about is what if tech
industry set up its own
IRB um and it seems like what You'
talked about some of the unique things
that Yale has when it comes to
interaction with policy makers might
allow it to influence or talk about best
practices um in a way that you know
there's either a board that's set up or
just guidelines that are created in this
data science center um so just to get
your thoughts about something like that
and what role Yale Yale could play well
I absolutely agree with you that that's
another great um examp example of how
perfectly situated are for that kind of
thing the current state of course is
that people opt into the rules on
Facebook or Okay Cupid and then there is
no IRB to to board to pass um the
conversation has like evolved recently
because of the I don't know if you guys
have looked at the OK Cupid data
scientists book called Data CSM he's
gone on like NPR a bunch of times like
laughing in the face of the concept of
opting in he's like nobody reads that
nobody understand understand that um
he's you know playing a dangerous game
which I'm enjoying because I feel like
at some point policy makers are going to
have to say actually no one understands
that and nobody reads that and it's
insufficient maybe that's but that's the
conversation a data Science Institute
should hold with the public and with
policy makers that is absolutely and by
the way policy makers can't hold that
conversation by themselves because they
don't understand data
enough so I just wanted to to say one
more thing is so first of all it's was
really great that you mentioned the lisp
which is actually called The Information
Society program and really I think is
frankly thinking a lot about these data
science issues and I just I wanted to to
just follow up a little bit on the
question I asked previously about where
the data is going to come from what I
see in Academia is there's this
interesting Dynamic where there's a
tremendous amount of biological data and
also data from say astronomy and Natural
Sciences but most of the driving force
in data science is the people in the
commercial world you know hiring these
people in the financial world or the
retail World advertising and so forth
and whereas we we can't actually study
that data because it's all locked up and
proprietary and I was wondering if
there's some way of thinking about how
to train students on available Natural
Sciences data but sort of make them
valuable for that commercial world
because it seems that's what ends up
happening I think Phil Bourne kind of
pointed this out too with the Google Bus
type of thing and how to think about
that
process well you I certainly think that
um the education initiatives I I was
talking about in in my mind do do that
that they fulfill the role of setting up
students to be useful um for a job like
Google and having said that Google is
like its own universe and um you know
the statisticians at Google don't even
work with raw data anymore because they
have such an amazing infrastructure they
only use higher level languages um like
are um so it's it's kind of weird I mean
and then you have other things like
startups that do things like scrape the
web and have completely unstructured
data um I guess what I'm saying is it's
just so varied it's hard it would be
hard to to prepare students for
everything so um but I do want to just I
guess it's a great moment to go back to
earlier today when I heard some maybe it
was you talking about stata versus R
like I one of the things that you do
have to be you just have to be Scrappy
as when you work in data science
right so you just I learned SQL over two
days because that I needed to do
something with a SQL database you just
have to learn everything and you have to
just get used to the fact that whatever
you've gotten really good at is going to
be old hat in a year which is one of the
reasons like when I see people talking
about Hadoop Hadoop Hadoop I'm like
that's not that's not what I'm going to
be using next time I get a job in
Industry I don't know what it's going to
be it's going to be on the grid it's
going to have aspects
of Hadoop it's going to be parallel it's
going to be fast it's going to heat up
the world's water but it's not
necessarily going to be called to dup
anymore excuse me my my understanding is
that the and I I have a question on that
U for you so my understanding is that
the main problem in data science in espe
ESP specifically in Academia it's not
neither the data and nor the algorithm
so we have frequent a lot of different
very good data sets and they can be used
in one or another way and uh we have a
lot of different algorithms and the real
potential of them remain mainly
untapped so I think the most important
problem is as you put it very well is a
kind of subject matter experts in
between of different domains and
disciplines like in medicine between uh
medical studies and computation and well
in computation between comput uh those
who do computation and now about
algorithms and software Engineers who
can help to create a build and a build
up a more sophisticated and you know
combined set of algorithms instead of
just a few line of algorithm to do one
task yeah so I'm just gonna make a
really short pitch from my book called
doing data science which just not
because I get the commission although I
do um but because it the first chapter
or two I think we talk about building a
data science
team and it's crucial in fact that you
don't first of all you don't think of it
as a project it's usually you're
building up a a code
base and you have layers of models you
know you this model will tell you
whether they click this model will tell
you whether they buy this model will
tell you whether this other model will
take those two models and decide whether
they're they're clicking and going away
and not coming back and buying you know
that kind of thing um and in order to do
that in order to assemble a team you you
find people who are good at different
things you have a domain expert you have
somebody who's good at communicating
with the business people you you have
someone who's good at algorithms you
have someone who's good at coding you
have someone who's good at making it
fast you have someone who's good at
collecting the data overnight that you
need and so it's a team effort in a way
that I'm not sure it's it's thought of
the same way in research but maybe it is
depending on the
field any other
questions thank you
[Applause]
guys
so that is the end of our programming
for today thank you all very much our
official end time is 5:30 so if you want
to talk amongst yourselves or take more
food more coffee thank you very much for
coming uh please fill out your
evaluation forms because that can help
us a lot with next year since the
Provost said apparently we have an
annual event now that makes it true so
please help us make next year's event
better by filling out the evaluation
forms and putting them outside um thank
you very much
[Applause]